hello everyone and welcome to the
advanced ethical hacking course video by
simply learn ethical hacking is the
practice of using hacking techniques to
test the security for computer system
Network or application with the goal of
identifying vulnerabilities and
improving the overall security of the
system in this video we'll explore all
the important advanced level concepts of
cyber security and ethical hacking but
before that let us understand what
ethical hacking involves and why it's a
profitable career option let's Jump
Right In ethical hacking is the practice
of using hacking techniques to test the
security of a computer system Network or
application with the goal of identifying
vulnerabilities and improving the
overall security of the system ethical
hackers use the same techniques as
malicious hackers but they do so with
the consent of the owner of the system
ethical hackers work to help
organizations identify and fix potential
security vulnerabilities before a
malicious hacker can exploit them with
the increasing Reliance on digital
systems in various Industries there has
been a growing demand for skilled
ethical hackers ethical hacking offers a
a lucrative career option with a high
salary and the potential to work as a
freelancer or part of a team according
to statistics the average salary of an
ethical hacker is approximately hundred
thousand dollars per year which is
significantly higher than many other
jobs additionally ethical hacking jobs
are in high demand across various
Industries including Finance Healthcare
and government making it a versatile
skill to have with that being said it is
sufficiently evident that cyber security
and ethical hacking are amazing career
options for every individual out there
and before we begin with the course if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a show
to Simply learns post-graduate program
in cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered now let's take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers
[Music]
you're never too old to learn anything
new whether it's an art a new language a
new sport or learning new skills to
advance your career hi I'm Phillip I'm
61 years old and last year I upskilled
with simply learned post-graduate
program in cyber security after working
30 years in the I.T sector in various
different profiles I'm happy to tell you
that I was able to clear and pass my
cissp and ccsp certification exams on
the first attempt after taking the
course a funny story I want to share
with you
I started off aspiring to be a DJ where
I became interested in electronic stereo
systems and how they connected and how
they operate and what made them function
and four years ago I began a journey to
understand and learn more about the
cloud on the way I develop a natural
understanding for the security needs and
began to focus my studies to understand
more about the cyber security aspect of
the cloud landscape
I work with many companies before the
security analysts and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course I've been an adjunct
faculty member at Prince George in
college and been in many different
learning and training experiences but
the experience as a student is simply
learning something I will always cherish
of course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors because I
believe in living a fulfilling life at
61. I am still trained students in
martial arts I've been practicing
martial arts for the past 40 years and
my efforts were acknowledged by the
Eastern United States International
Martial Arts Association
where I was inducted into the Hall of
Fame for a lifetime achievement of
dedication service and martial arts I've
been many things in my life
first and foremost I've been a learner
be a learner first
and now we will see the agenda for this
Advanced ethical hacking full course we
will cover a wide range of topics
firstly we will dive into understanding
who an ethical hacker is and the need
for the expertise in today's digital
landscape next we'll explore the
essential skills required to become an
ethical hacker we'll also focus on
various ethical lacking tools and their
functionalities the course will include
practical sessions starting with
installing Kali Linux and demonstrating
basic commands we'll then move on to
important hacking techniques like
phishing SQL injection and VPN usage
additionally we will examine the
significance of firewalls in protecting
systems and networks the agenda will
also cover different areas of ethical
hacking giving participants a
comprehensive understanding of the field
we'll explore the meta slot live
framework and its application in
conducting Advanced attacks furthermore
we will discuss the role of a certified
ethical hacker CH and the benefits of
obtaining CH certification the course
will conclude by highlighting various
ethical hacking certification available
and the career prospects in the field by
the end of the course participants will
have gained practical Knowledge and
Skills to pursue a successful career in
ethical hacking so without any further
Ado let's jump on to our topic right
away and if these are the types of
videos you would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press the
Bell icon to not miss on any further
content for individuals who illegally
hack into a system for monetary gain on
the contrary we have white hat hackers
to exploit the vulnerabilities in a
system by hacking into it with
permission in order to defend the
organization this form of hacking is
absolutely legal and ethical hence they
are also often referred to as ethical
hackers in addition to these hackers we
also have the gray hat hackers as the
name suggests the color gray is a blend
of both white and black these hackers
discover vulnerabilities in a system and
report it to the system's owner which is
a good act
but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval sometimes gray hat
hackers also ask for money in return for
the spotted vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story Dan runs a Trading
Company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and Dan's business was
booming until a hacker decided to hack
the company's servers the hackers stole
the credentials of various trading
accounts he asked for a lump sum Ransom
in exchange for the stolen credentials
Dan took the Hacker's words lightly and
didn't pay the hacker as a result the
hacker withdrew money from various
customers accounts and Dan was liable to
pay back the customers
Dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers after this
incident Dan gave a lot of thought as to
what could have gone wrong with the
security infrastructure in his company
he wished there was someone from his
company who could have run a test attack
to see how vulnerable systems were
before the hacker penetrated into the
network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does
to do this job he hired an ethical
hacker John
John was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad John in this scenario exposed the
vulnerabilities in the existing Network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases let us look at
these faces step by step with respect to
how John our ethical hacker will act
before launching an attack the first
step Jon takes is to gather all the
necessary information about the
organization's system that he intends to
attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and hping for this purpose
John then tries to spot the
vulnerabilities if any in the Target
system using tools like nmap and Expos
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after John makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system
the Metasploit tool helps him with this
this phase is called maintaining access
John is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best not to leave any evidence
of his attack this is the fifth phase
clearing tracks we now have the last
phase that is reported in this phase
John documents a summary of his entire
attack the vulnerabilities he spotted
the tools he used and the success rate
of the attack looking into the report
Dan is now able to take a call and see
how to protect his organization from any
external cyber attacks don't you all
think Jon is an asset to any
organization if you want to become an
ethical hacker like John then there are
a few skills that you need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as Windows Linux Unix and Macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as HTML
PHP python SQL and JavaScript networking
is the base of ethical hacking hence you
should be good at it ethical hackers
should be well aware of security laws so
that they don't misuse their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like John
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification ceh CompTIA pin
Test Plus and licensed penetration
tester certification to name a few
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert master's program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cyber security expert you could have a
look at it by clicking the link in the
description so here's a question for you
in which phase of ethical hacking will
you install back doors in the Target
system
a scanning B maintaining access C
clearing tracks D reconnaissance
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below three
lucky winners will receive Amazon gift
vouchers the endless growth of
Technologies in this area is directly
proportional to the number of cyber
crimes cyber crimes are estimated to
cost 6 trillion dollars in 2021 hence to
tackle these cyber crimes organizations
are continuously on the lookout for
cyber Security Professionals the average
annual salary of a certified ethical
hacker is ninety one thousand dollars in
the US and approximately rupees 7 lakhs
in India
so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an ethical hacker
like John and put an end to the cyber
attacks in the world so let's talk about
a few of the tools that the ethical
hacker would utilize uh in their testing
scenarios to be honest there are
hundreds of tools out there what you see
on the screen as just a few examples of
them uh nessus is a vulnerability
scanner what is a vulnerability scanner
it is an automated tool that is designed
to identify vulnerabilities within hosts
within operating systems within networks
so they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified at the
scan the network against that database
to find out any possible flaws or any
possible vulnerabilities that currently
exist on the host or the operating
system or on the network similarly there
would be application scanners like
acunetics or Arachne that would help you
scan applications and identify flaws
within those applications as well now
all of these are automated tools the
essence of ethical hacker is when these
tools churn out the reports the ethical
hacker can understand these reports
analyze them identify the flaws and then
craft their own exploits or use existing
exploits in a particular manner so that
they can get access or they can bypass
the access or security controls
mechanisms that are already in place how
can they do that with the tool called
Metasploit you see that Big M there on
the right hand side that M logo is for a
tool called Metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nasus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using Metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where meta it helps us do that Wireshark
could be used in the background while we
are doing both the activities using
nessus or Metasploit to keep a track of
what packets are being sent and by
received on the network which will help
us analyze those packets so whenever I
run a necess scanner I would run a
Wireshark in the background it will
capture the data package and I can go
through those data packets and analyze
that data package to identify what
nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when I try to attack a machine
using exploit on Metasploit I will keep
on Wireshark running in the background
to capture the data package that have
been sent and the responses that I've
received from the victim so that I can
also go through those packets and
analyze the responses and analyze the
attack whether it was successful to what
extent was it successful and basically
will also give me a validation of proof
of the activity that has happened nmap
is another automated tool that allows me
to scan for open ports and protocols so
why would I use nmap because Pro ports
and protocols become an entry point for
a hacker to gain access to devices for
example when we connect to a web server
we connect through a web browser but we
automatically connect to Port 80 using
HTTP and Port 443 is using https so if
I'm connecting to a web server using
https it is safe to assume that Port 443
on the web server is open to accept
those connections similarly there would
be other services that may be left open
on the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted Services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then I can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that I'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
I want to do a SQL injection attack or
if I if nessus tells me that there is a
SQL injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
I can use an automatic limited tool
called SQL map or SQL map that would
allow me to automatically craft all the
queries that are required for a SQL
injection attack and help me do that
attack at the same time so here I do not
have to manually create my own queries
uh the SQL map tool would automatically
create them for me what I would do is I
would use nessus to identify that
particular flaw if nessus reports that
flock I would then go use the tool SQL
map configure it to attack that
particular web server and when I fire
off the tool it will then automatically
start directing queries SQL injection
queries to the database to see if those
databases are vulnerable and if yes what
data can be retrieved from those
databases so all of these tools in a
nutshell would help me hack networks
applications operating systems and host
devices and this is what ethical hacker
does they use these kind of tool sets
they identify what attacks they need to
do they identify the right tool for that
particular attack and they write their
exploits they create those attacks and
then they start attacking analyze the
response and then give a report to the
management uh providing them feedback
about how the attack was created or
crafted what was the response to that
attack and whether the attack was
successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so we're going
to talk about the concepts about what
constitutes an ethical hack and what is
a penetration test you're going to talk
about the different types of penetration
tests and how they can be done we are
going to talk about an operating system
called Kali Linux and we're going to
talk about its usage and its importance
in cyber security we will also be
discussing the different phases of
penetration test and how people or
hackers would utilize these phases to
gain their objectives we will also be
discussing in what areas can we do a
penetration test how to do those
penetration tests we'll be discussing in
quite a few bit of penetration testing
tools that are available in the Kali
Linux space and then we'll be looking at
a couple of demos at the end of the
session to understand how these tools in
the operating system can be utilized for
various hacks so let's start with what
is ethical hacking now plainly Define
ethical hacking is locating weaknesses
or vulnerabilities of computers and
information systems using the intent and
actions of a malicious hacker the major
differences here that we are hired to
discover those weaknesses in a legal and
ethical manner that means first and
foremost our intent should not be
malicious we do not wish any harm to the
organization and whatever we discover is
reported back and not misused once we
report back we will also be trying to
help them out to mitigate or remove
those weaknesses or vulnerabilities to
enhance the company security posture so
essentially we would have the same
training or the same knowledge as that
of a malicious hacker except that the
intent is going to be different the
intent is going to help the organization
achieve security to protect themselves
against malicious hackers and the second
most important thing about ethical
hacking is that we are authorized to do
that activity I cannot in good faith
hack somebody and then tell them you
know what I just I just wanted to help
you out and here are your
vulnerabilities and this is the way you
can prevent them I first need the
authorization from the other party and
only then can I perform an ethical hack
so in this example hacker attacks an
individual with malicious intent and
makes misuse of whatever information
they have gotten they steal the data
they maybe fry the operating system
Hardware destroy it and thus they leave
the victim without a device with
authorization an ethical hacker can also
attack the same individual minus the
destruction of course and the intent is
good so they're willingly finding out
the vulnerabilities and helping the
victim plug them out so that they
wouldn't be a victim of a malicious
attack now here the first thing is
authorization from the victim and the
second thing is the good intent where we
do not miss you use those
vulnerabilities and we report them back
to the victim or to the client and help
them patch those vulnerabilities that's
the main difference between a white hat
and a black hat so Security Experts are
normally termed as white hat hackers
malicious hackers are termed as black
hats now the responsibilities of ethical
hacker are multi-fold first and foremost
you have to create scripts test for
vulnerabilities first have to identify
those in the first place so there's
World military assessment identifying
those vulnerabilities and then you're
going to test them to see the validity
and the complexity of those
vulnerabilities so your one of your
responsibilities would be to develop
tools to increase security as well or to
configure Security in such a way that it
would be difficult to breach performing
risk assessment now what is the risk
risk is a threat that is posed to an
organization by a possibility of getting
hacked so let's say I as an ethical
hacker run a vulnerability scanner on a
particular client I identify 10
different vulnerabilities within those
10 vulnerabilities I do a risk
assessment to identify which
vulnerability is critical would have the
most impact on the client and what would
be the repercussions if those
vulnerabilities actually get exploited
so I'm trying to find out in risk
assessment that if the client gets
hacked with the vulnerabilities
identified what is the loss they would
be facing once they get hacked and the
loss could not only be loss of data it
could be Financial losses it could be
loss of reputation penalties they have
to pay to the client for breaches or
penalties that they may have to pay for
pay the governments in case of breaches
that happen that couldn't be controlled
under the responsibility of the ethical
hacker is to set up policies in such a
way that it becomes difficult for
hackers to get access to devices or to
protected data and finally train the
staff for network security so we've got
a lot of employees in an organization we
need to frame the staff of what is
allowed and what is not allowed how to
keep themselves secure so that they
don't get compromised thus becoming a
vulnerability themselves to the
organization the policies that we have
talked about are administrative policies
to govern the employees of the
organization for example password
policies most of the organizations will
have a tough password policy where they
say you have to create a password that
meets a certain level of complexity
before that can be accepted and till you
create that password you are not allowed
to log in or you're not allowed to
register so let's move on to understand
what is penetration testing now for
penetration testing there is a phase
called vulnerability assessment that
happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing about running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration test this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only of the
information systems so you have
identified that flaw maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be a buffer over and flaw or it
could be a simple password cracking
attempt your idea is to create those
tools create those attacks and try to
penetrate into those areas where
security is weak the essence of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks should be anything
like a phishing attack a password
cracking attack a denial of service
attack or any other vulnerabilities that
you have identified during a
vulnerability scan so what is Kali Linux
and why is it used Kali Linux is an
operating system often used by hackers
and ethical hackers both because of the
tool sets that the operating system
contains it is Operating System created
by professionals with a lot of embedded
tools it is a dbn based operating system
with Advanced penetration testing and
security auditing features there are
more than 600 plus or tools on that
operating system that can help you
leverage any of the attacks man in the
middle attack sniffing password cracking
any of these attacks would be possible
with all the tools is available you just
need to know how to utilize the
operating system and its tools contains
like I said 100 of hundreds of tools
that are used for various information
security tasks like computer forensics
reverse engineering information finding
even getting access to different
machines and then creating viruses worms
Trojans anything that you will 600 plus
tools in the Kali Linux operating system
there are periodic updates that are
given out to the operating system as
well it is open source that means it is
free to utilize you can even have the
source code you can modify it if you
want to test customizations available
for all the tools you can download
third-party tools and install them if
you want there's a wide support for
wireless network cards multiple
languages are being supported at the
time at the same time as well and you
can create a lot of attacking scripts
you can create attacking tools and you
can write your own exploits as well on
Kali Linux so this all all in all helps
you create a very robust system where
you can create your own tags and then
launch them against unsuspecting victims
now that is illegal so as far ethical is
concerned once you have authorization
you're going to identify which tools to
be utilized you're going to get the
appropriate permissions and only then
are you going to attempt those attacks
let's talk about the phases of
penetration testing now there are five
different phases the first one is the
reconnaissance phase also known as the
information gathering phase this is the
most important phase for any hacker this
is where the hacker or the ethical
hacker if you will will gather as much
information about the target's victim or
vice versa the victim right so once you
have that information you would then be
able to identify what tool sets to
include and how to attack the victim for
example you want to find out the IP
addresses the domains subdomains the
network architecture that is being
utilized you want to identify operating
systems that are being utilized the
network IP ranges that are being
utilized and so on so forth you might
want to identify employees within an
organization for social engineering
attacks in the future email addresses
telephone numbers anything and
everything that will help you validate
and give you information about the
target is something that you want to do
in the recognizance phase at this point
in time we are not going to question
whether whatever information we are
getting is useful or not only time will
tell depending on the various attacks
that we will be building up later on
this becomes your Baseline this becomes
your database with all the information
about the victim so that you can come
back from later stages back to the
reconnaissance phase to look at the
information that you have gathered and
then you can fine tune your attacks once
you have done that you are going to then
start the scanning phase based on the
information that you have gathered you
are going to identify live machines
within a network once you've identified
the live machines you'll scan them for
open ports protocols and procedures any
processes that are running and then we
were going to identify vulnerabilities
Within These processes and within his
open port so in the scanning phase uh
why do we need to find live machines
because we want to find out the machines
that have booted up have an operating
system and are running on the network if
an OP machine is not available on the
network or is in a shutdown mode that
machine cannot be hacked through a
technical attack then it would be a
physical attack where you physically go
to the machine and then do whatever you
want to do with it for a technical
attack you will have to identify the
machines that have booted up then you're
going to scan the open ports because
that's going to be your entry point and
on the port would be a service that is
running so you scan the service as well
identify the version of the service and
then do a vulnerability scan to identify
if there any vulnerabilities on those
services that are running and then based
on all of this information we are going
to develop our attacks as we go on so
once we have this we go on to the
gaining access phase where we are going
to attack and try to get access to our
victims machines could be a social
engineering attack based on the
information gathering have done in the
technical assessment and scanning phase
if you have identified a vulnerability
you are going to identify a relevant
exploit and then use that exploit to try
to gain access or we might just craft a
Trojan and try to execute that Trojan on
the victim's machine to check if we can
get access through that particular
manner once we have the access it could
be even a simple password cracking
attack which we have been able to
accomplish and we have cracked the
password of the person and now we have
gained access to that person's computer
right but these attacks would be
temporary for example we have cracked a
password somebody changes the password
every 30 days after that period our
attack would be useless if atrogen is
executed we get a connection to that
machine for once but then how do we get
get a repeated connection over and over
again if you want to reconnect to that
machine so that's where we come into the
maintaining access phase where we
install root kits key loggers sniffers
and things like that where we could get
a backdoor entry to the victim's machine
if we have already been successfully
installed at Trojan we would want to add
the torsion to the startup menu so that
every time the operating system starts
the Trojan gets automatically executed
and thus we maintain the back door entry
to that victim's machine once we have
done all of this all these activities
are going to leave a trace in the
victim's machine so if we install a
Trojan a Trojan being an application
would create directories and files a
virus would be destructive in nature if
you are executing a script it will leave
some logs behind if we even log in
through the cracked password that we
have it will create a login entry and
for that particular timestamp along with
the IP address that we utilized in the
covering tracks we are essentially
trying to avoid detection by deleting
traces of our activity that means that
we need to identify where logs are being
stored we need to address those logs and
we need to delete them or modify them in
such a way that our activity is not
traceable so these are the five main
phases of a penetration test gather as
much information as you can scan for
machines ports protocols and services
running on the victim's device try to
gain access by password cracking
intrusions exploits for the
vulnerabilities if any maintain that
access by installing further software
which will allow you to get backdoor
access to that particular system and
then try to cover your tracks by
deleting all traces of your activity
once successful the victim will have no
idea and you have a back door entry and
you can monitor the victim to the extent
that you want now in a ethical hackers
perspective this penetration test can be
done in multiple aspects so again
understand the fact that we are doing an
authorized activity we have identified
the tools that we have to use identified
the attacks we've got the appropriate
authorization and based on that
authorization we are conducting a
penetration test the penetration test
may be asked to be done in one of these
manners first is the Black Box test the
Black Box test is where no information
is given to the ethical hacker about the
it infrastructure so they have no idea
what it is they start right from the
first phase of the information gathering
gather as much information they can and
based on the gathered information they
try to create and launch attacks to see
if they are going to be successful now
not only does it test the knowledge of
the penetration tester it would also
test the security implementations that
the organization has done to see whether
they can identify the attack and prevent
it in the first place so this is the
simulation of a malicious hacker
scenario where a malicious hacker having
no idea about the organization first
tries to gather information and then
tries to attack that organization so no
source code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the ID infrastructure is
given think of it from a employee's
perspective a regular employee in an
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges like an administrator but
it's just a regular employee does that
means that they want limited access
within the organization based on on
which they get some knowledge of the IIT
infrastructure so this is an attempt of
an Insider simulation attack where a
regular user may want to try to misuse
the access that they've been given and
then try to gather information or try to
gain access to other devices which they
are not authorized to the third test is
white box where there's full knowledge
of the ID infrastructure that has been
given so this is again a simulation of
an Insider attack a malicious Insider if
you will but at this point in time the
person has complete knowledge of the
infrastructure could be in an
administrative position and then they
are trying to leverage their access to
see if they can get information or they
can compromise any staff any of the data
so the three attacks would be the first
one black box where we are simulating uh
external threat a hacker sitting outside
the organization trying to gain access
the gray box is an Insider threat where
there is a regular employee who is
trying to get access to infrastructure
that they are not authorized for and in
the third order is a white box audit
where there's an administrator who has
all the level average all the access and
the visibility within the infrastructure
and then they are trying to misuse their
access to see what else they can get
from whatever access has been authorized
to them now let's look at the areas of
penetration testing where all could we
do a penetration test thus compromising
the security of the application or of
the server or of the user so first and
foremost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in the network all of these
are devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been correctly
secured they would leave some
vulnerabilities behind if we as ethical
hackers are able to identify these flaws
these misconfigurations these
vulnerabilities we could then try to
exploit them and try to gain access to
the network and devices within that
Network by getting access to the network
in the first place then we have the web
applications web applications are
nothing but softwares that developed
over or deployed over a web server and
are made available over the intranet or
the internet for example websites that
we visit or web applications like
Facebook if you will right so if these
applications have vulnerabilities within
them we then try to attack the web-based
applications and thus try to bypass
authentication or get access to database
or try to leak information through those
applications if not then we try to
attack the client side now web
application is at the server level and
it is hosted by the deployer so that's
at the server side the client side is
where we as users are using a computer
with a browser and trying to interact
with the web application now the browser
and the operating system that we are
utilizing would have its own
vulnerabilities thus identifying a
client-side vulnerability and then
exploiting it to either either hack the
client or then piggyback on the client's
connection and try to get access to the
server so either you could attack the
network the web application or the
client side itself or you could attack
wireless networks this test would
examine all the wireless devices which
are used in a corporation most of the
wireless would have laptops smartphones
tablets phablets all of those connected
to them if you are able to access any of
these devices to the wireless it would
help you gain access to other devices on
the wireless as well and in Social
Engineering so this is where you're
trying to attack humans you are tracking
an employee of a corporation to reveal
some confidential information knowingly
or unknowingly by tricking them with
fake mails or fake websites or malicious
emails that you have sent to them which
they have failed to recognize as
malicious and they click on it thus
getting victimized social engineering
attacks are always successful because of
the gullibility of humans empathy
sympathy humans basically have emotions
emotions can be toyed with and then
taken advantage of if the person is not
careful enough for example the most
common social engineering attack that we
see is the Nigerian fraud where we
receive an email that someone one
somewhere has died and has left a huge
estate behind a few hundred million
dollars and we have been identified as
the person through whom they want to
transfer the money to a foreign land to
save on taxes what are the chances of
that happening on a daily basis right
how many princes are there so that's
something that we do not verify it's
just the I guess the greed if you will
of striking it rich quickly that makes
us believe these kind of emails we have
also received emails of lottery tickets
that we have won over a period of time
without even having bought a lottery
ticket so if you haven't bought one what
did you win but we don't ask these
questions we just get excited about the
amount of money that we have won and
then we try to bet on our luck and try
to see if that email is going to
fructify or is it just under the scam so
social engineering attacks are time a
dozen these days and we need to be very
careful on what we trust on the internet
let's look at the penetration testing
tools there are hundreds and thousands
of tools out there most of these have
been concised and collected together and
host did on a operating system known as
Kali Linux that we have talked about
earlier now the predecessor to Kali
Linux was backtrack backtrack is no
longer continued it has been
discontinued and Kali Linux has taken
the place of backtrack within which are
all the tools that you see on your
screen Metasploit is one of the most
favorite penetration testing tools of
hackers and ethical hackers there are a
lot of inbuilt exploits over there and
we'll be doing a demo at the end of the
session on this nmap is the information
gathering tool which will scan for live
devices scan for open ports protocols
and services beef would be an
application testing tool that would help
us find exploits within applications
nessus vulnerability scanner is a
network and a host based scanner that
would help you identify vulnerabilities
within such hosts Wireshark is a
Network's differ which allows you to
capture Network packets and and analyze
them to see if there are there is any
information worth capturing within those
packets SQL map is a automated tool used
for SQL injection attacks so you don't
even have to craft your queries for SQL
injection it will be done by the SQL map
tool you just need to identify whatever
is possible through the queries that
this SQL is going to create and then
based on the activity that you've
identified you just need to redefine
your search parameters to get access to
the database we will be doing a demo on
SQL map or SQL map as well and then
there is John the Ripper John the Ripper
is a tool that is used for password
cracking so dictionary attacks Brute
Force attacks are done using John the
Ripper what is a dictionary attack a
dictionary attack is an attack where we
create list of all probable passwords
store them in a txt file and run that
list against the password tool to see if
any of those passwords are going to
match a Brute Force attack is trying the
same attack but with every permutation
and combination of the alphabet that we
have and we are going to try to figure
out if we are able to crack the password
at all so these are just some of the
tools for every tool there are another
supporting 100 tools or more than that
like for an SS vulnerability scanner
you'll have college vulnerability
scanner you have ga5 Lan card and there
are other lots of other softwares out
there but these are some of the most
commonly utilized tools let's look at
the Metasploit attack Metasploit is a
framework of penetration testing that
makes hacking very simple you just need
to know how to utilize the tool you need
to identify the vulnerability associated
with a particular exploit and then run
the exploit on Metasploit we'll be
demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits in active exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit these exploits wait for incoming
requests and exploit them as soon as
they connect they can also be used in
conjunction with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
preload we like a reverse connection
payload we send it to the victim once a
victim installs that software the
machine will then initiate a connection
into us our machine will be in a listen
mode and then we will once the software
is executed at there and we would then
try to connect and exploit that
particular vulnerability this is the uh
practical that we'll be doing on
Metasploit so let's move on with the
demos and then we'll see what we can
discuss amongst them all right let's
have a look at some of the demos that we
had talked about in the ethical hacking
and penetration testing module we are
going to look at three different demos
the first one is going to be a SQL
injection attack that we are going to
perform on this tool that we have the
second one is a password tracking attack
on Windows 7 and a third one is uh
Meetup reader based or a Metasploit
based shell shock attack on a Linux
based web server so let's get cracking
I've powered on this virtual machine
which is the ovas broken web application
it is a tool that is provided for people
who want to enhance their skills and
they can practice how to do these
attacks in a legal manner so we are
going to go to this site I'm just going
to open up my browser the IP address
71.132 and that's the ovas broken web
application that we want to utilize we
are going to head off to mutility2 and
we are going to look at a SQL injection
attack where we want to bypass
authentication now this takes us to the
login screen so we can just try our luck
here and see that the authentication
mechanism works the account does not
exist so the username and password that
we have supplied is not the correct one
so we want to ensure that there's a SQL
database and we can try to attack it and
see if we can bypass the authentication
now what we want to do is we want to
create a SQL based malformed query that
can give us a different output so I'm
just going to type in a single quote
over here and type login and you can see
that this is now suddenly recognized as
a operator and there's an error that is
given out compared to the login that we
tried earlier when we used a proper text
based login mechanism it gave us the
account does not exist but here the
single code give us a error and it shows
us how SQL works this is the query that
we had created now in the trainings that
you have for ethical hacking there would
be explanations of what these queries
are all about how the syntax works here
we're just going to see if we can create
a malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is
create the query over here I'm going to
give it a comparison so we're going to
give it a r 1 equals one space hyphen
iPhone space and if you now click login
you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database an Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
them at a demo this is how a SQL
injection attack works now let me log
out here similarly now we are in a login
page the same query work wonders where
it allowed us to bypass authentication
so it also depends on what kind of a
page I am and what query would be
accepted at this point in time so here
application understanding would also
come into the picture where uh which
function we are calling upon when we are
connected to a particular page now this
is a user lookup function right so again
here we try the same method test test
that's not going to work authentication
error bad user or password and if you
type in the same query over here single
quote or and give it a condition single
quote or one equals one high space
hyphenation space now here it is not
going to log Us in because this is not a
login page this is a user lookup form so
here it will instead give us a dump of
all the databases that it has so you can
see all the usernames and passwords
coming in that are stored in the user
lookup field so this is where the
understanding comes in of which query to
create at what page we are depending
upon the function that is has been
called right so that's the SQL injection
attack that we wanted to look at let's
move on to password tracking now this is
a Windows 7 machine that we have I'm
just going to do a very basic password
tracking example we're just going to log
in now here the assumption is that we
are able to log in we have access to a
computer and we want to check out other
users who are using this computer and
see if we can find out their passwords
so that we can log in as a different
user steal data if required and we
wouldn't be to blame if there are any
logs that are created so here we've got
a tool called K N able that is installed
right here now I'm already an
administrator on this machine and
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges or any other
user who may be on this system whose
password I can crack and thus I would be
able to get access through their account
and then do any malicious activity right
so this allows me to go into a cracker
tool and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify all the use users
and passwords that are there in this
particular machine right so I'm just
going to click on the plus sign and I'm
going to import hashes from a local
system so where are these files stored
where does Windows store its passwords
and what format are they stored and what
this tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as a
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users are hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
the user called virus as well and you
can see that this is the hash value of
the password that is being utilized now
there's a particular format for a hash
value for Windows and how it stores but
once we have these hash values let's say
if I want to crack this password there
are various attacks that we can do for
example a dictionary based attack or a
Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so we
are going to try to create an ntlm hash
attack and here we are going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and uh lowercase A through Z uppercase A
through Z numeric zero through nine and
all the special characters let's say the
password is between 7 and 16 characters
and this is the character set that you
want to try the Brute Force attack on
what is a group Force attack it is an
attack where the computer is going to
try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100 successful given the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to be become a little
bit redundant there are other attacks
that we can do which can easily identify
this data for us as well but that is
something that we will look on in future
videos so that's how we can get access
to users and passwords there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we are going to
try to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
lineage web server that I have that I'm
going to power on I'm going to use a
Kali Linux machine to hack that device
and I'm going to just power off my
Windows 7 machine give it a minute till
it boots up now this is also a demo
machine that we have which has its own
pre-configured vulnerabilities so here
we've got something from the pen testers
lab and has a shell shock vulnerability
implemented inside shell shock value
nobody affects Linux Mac and Unix based
operating systems for a particular
version of The Bash shell bash is the
bone again shell which is the command
line interface in these operating
systems so what we are trying to do here
is we are going to use the Kali Linux
machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we are going to use Metasploit to attack
this machine now the first and foremost
thing is we want to identify the IP
address we have no idea what the IP
address is we are in the same subnet so
we are assuming that we are able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called zenmap I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my appearance is
this with a subnet mask of
255255255.0 so I want to see if there
are any other machines that are live in
the same subnet and we are doing a pinch
swipe over here to identify which
machines are live in a minute we'll get
all the IP addresses 71.1 to 133 25400
120 we know that we are 128 at this
point in time uh 254 is the DHCP server
so we are assuming that 133 is the
machine that we want to look at and
let's then try to see if we can scan
that machine 133 and we're going to do
an intense scan to find out which ports
are open what services are running over
there and if it is whether the pen test
machine that we were looking for you can
see of the start Port 22 and Port 80 and
somewhere here it's going to give us the
ports that are open and the details
about those ports and somewhere here it
will tell us that this is the pen tester
lab machine that we wanted which is
correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what we
are going to do is I'm going to use
another GUI based tool called Sparta
which I can just find out from here
Sparta uses two tools in the background
nmap tool and a tool called Necto so
we're just going to start scanning 192
168 71.1 33 was the IP address add to
scope and over a period of time you can
see all of these you will start
populating with information the VR
that's the nickto tool coming in
scanning on Port 80 which is uh which
means that it's a web server using HTTP
it tells us it's an Apache HD httpd
2.2.21 and gives us the 22 port number
as well if we head over to the tab of
nickto or let's look at the screenshot
first this is what the website will be
looking like and nikto gives us the
options over here it tells us that there
is a vulnerability over here for shell
shock and this is the path where the
vulnerability is going to exist so what
we're going to do we go back to the
command line sorry we open up a new one
minimize all these other windows and we
are going to open up Metasploit
Metasploit is a penetration testing tool
that is used by most hackers and ethical
hackers to test applications and test
existing exploits and vulnerabilities so
just give it a minute till it starts you
can see there are already around 1700
exploits right here we're going to see
all those exploits with these commands
okay we are sorry for the typo and it
will just give us a list of all the
exploits that are stored in Metasploit
in this version so all of these are
windows based if we scroll up we will be
looking at other vulnerabilities as well
or exploits the unique specs exploits
Linux OS X multi-exploits and we are
looking for a exploit for a multi-based
Apache or HTTP let's go up uh let's look
at so this is the one that we're looking
for Apache mod CGI bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we're just going to copy it go back to
the bottom say use exploit and paste the
one that we wanted press enter say show
options so it will ask us to configure
this I'm just going to configure it
based on the knowledge that we have set
our host which is the remote host the
victims machine so we put in the IP
address it asks us for the Target URI so
that's the path that we saw set Target
URI to CGI hyphen bin slash status enter
now with exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want so we say show
payloads and it will give us a list of
all the compatible payloads with this
exploit and we want to create a reverse
TCP connection which is this so we know
it's a Linux operating system we want
this payload to be set so set payload
press enter that's the payload coming in
show options now that we have set the
payload this is the options for the
exploit and now we want to set our
options for the payloads as well so we
are creating a reverse TCB connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side and making the
victim connect back to our machine which
means we need to set up a listener so I
need to put my IP address over here set
localhost or lhost
192.168
71.128 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine we which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack I can see that it
has created a meter Builder session at
the victim side and it has opened up a
session so if I do a PWD now PWD is a
Linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we'll
connect it to where
www.cgi hyphen win do an LS it will list
all the files that's the status file
over there do a CD backslash it will
take us to the root of this machine now
remember we saw the passwords on a
Windows machine similarly we can head
over to the cdetc folder LS and you can
see these files psswd and Shadow now
psswd is the file where Linux Stores it
usernames and Shadow is the file where
passwords are showed so do a cat command
psswd and you can see these users coming
up so you can see the last user pen test
lab and you can see there are no
passwords so let's do a cat Shadow and
that's your hash value for the password
that we have for the user in this lab so
these are the different attacks that we
need to understand and we need to create
based on the vulnerabilities that exist
on different machines so if you just
looked at windows and Linux and how we
can exploit them depending on existing
vulnerabilities as a ethical hacker this
is uh what we need to learn in our
trainings and then we need to clear our
exams based on this knowledge of how
these things work so that we get
certified and then we can position
ourselves for the penetration testing
jobs and before we begin with the course
if you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities
then try giving a show to Simply learns
post-graduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT Schwartzman
College of Engineering and the course
link is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that we would follow so there are six
steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
reconnaissance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hackers
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a Windows
based server and I use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a Linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so I need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase I want to
identify all of that information once I
have that information done I'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we are
going to try to see the open ports open
services is and protocols that are
running on that server that can give me
possible entry points within the network
or within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap I would run
a vulnerability scanner the necess
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
acunetics for applications and then I
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once I have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a
vulnerability that I may have found
during the scanning phase once I have
gained my access I want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist or existing
or somebody changed the password that we
I may have cracked does I no longer have
access so what do I do to maintain my
access I installed Trojans or back door
entries to those systems using which I
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my own time as long as those devices
are available over the network so that's
where I maintain my access I have hacked
them now I want to maintain my access so
I install a software which would give me
a backdoor entry to that device no
matter what once I have done this I want
to clear my track so whatever activity
that I've been doing for example
installing a Trojan a Trojan is also a
software that would create directory
directories and files once installed on
the victims machine so I want to hide
that if I have access data stores if I
have modified data I want to hide that
activity because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline thus my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason I'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so I would be
deleting references of any of the IP
addresses or Mac addresses that I may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is where I will be able
to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once I
take off those traces the victim would
not be any wiser of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or the expected output of
that attack I'll create a report which
would give a detailed analysis of all
the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that ethical hacking process would take
uh just going through this recognizance
is where you're going to use hiking
tools like nmap HP to obtain information
about targets there are hundreds of
tools out there depending on what
information you want then in scanning
again nmap next pose these kind of tools
to be utilized to identify open ports
protocols and services in gaining access
you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the Metasploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install back
doors you can use meta square at the
same time you can craft your own scripts
to create a Trojan and install it on the
victims machine once you have achieved
that clearing tracks is where you're
going to clear all evidences of your
activity so that you do not get caught
or the victim doesn't even realize that
they have been hacked and once you've
done all of this we are going to create
reports that are going to be submitted
to the management to help them
understand the current security
evaluation of their organization so now
let's see how we can hack using social
engineering now what is social
engineering social engineering is the
art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's take a
look at examples right if you see on the
screen phishing activity what is
phishing we receive a lot of frequents
on a regular basis we have always
received those emails where we have won
a lottery of a few million dollars but
we have never realized that we didn't
purchase a lottery to win a lottery in
the first place we have always had those
Nigerian frauds where a prince died in
some South African country and and you
out of 7 billion people on the planet
have been identified where they want to
transfer a few hundred million dollars
through your account and they want to
give you 50 of that money in return as
thank you so some very basic attacks
where you go on to websites and there's
a banner flashing at you saying
congratulations you're the one millionth
visitor to this website click here to
claim your price all of these are social
engineering attacks phishing attacks
fake websites fake Communications being
sent out to users to prey on their
gullibility most of humans always have
that dream of striking it rich winning a
huge Lottery once and for all and living
their life lavishly ever after but sadly
in the real world that's not that
doesn't happen that often and if you're
receiving those meals it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those Communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotion
machines do not try pleading with the
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social engineering attack
where you can plead with them saying if
I do not get access to this account
immediately I might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack we
it would be easily be able to gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
cool that you attended you probably have
that listed on your LinkedIn profile
where a purpose and and just go in there
and see your academic qualifications and
identify the school that you were in
right similarly it might also be a
question what was your mother's maiden
name that's a very good attack and
that's uh I mean if a person can
interact with you let's say they're
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it phishing
as discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing comes into mind
uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is open
a generic attack whoever Falls victim
will fall victim so if I just throw
around a few USBS in the parking lot
obviously with Trojans implemented on
them some people who are curious or who
are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in there those pen drives on
their computers the virus or the Trojan
would get infected and cause harm to
their machine when exploiting human
greed we just talked about the Nigerian
frauds and the lotteries those kind of
attacks the fake money making gimmicks
now basically this is where you Prey
Upon the person's agreed kicking in and
they are clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal use user the
only person with the key to unscramble
the data would be able to unscramble it
and make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the end user using this same key would
then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer would once made into
unreadable format would look like eqor
xvgt for an end user it wouldn't make
any sense but the person who has a key
to unscramble that would be able to
convert it back to computer and then
understand the meaning of that word so
this is just a substitution Cipher that
is being shown on the screen so what is
the alphabet the key is alphabet plus
three so C plus three alphabets that
becomes e o becomes q m becomes o so the
key that is utilized to scramble the
data is the character that you are at
the third character from there would be
the corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponding
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out or you want
to decrypt that data now as ethical
hacker you wouldn't be for paying a
ransom to the hacker would you so it is
now your prerogative of how you're going
to work around and how you're going to
try to crack the encryption mechanism
how to crack the cipher to decrypt that
message and see what's within it right
decryption without the use of a secret
key that is known as a crypt analysis
Crypt analysis is the reversing of an
algorithm to figure out what the
decryption was without using a key so
Crypt analysis can be done using various
formats the first one is a Brute Force
attack second is a dictionary attack
third one is a rainbow table attack a
Brute Force attack is trying every
combination permutation and combination
of the key to figure out what the key
was it is 100 successful but may take a
lot of time a dictionary attack is where
you have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out the similarities between between the
text that you have and the encrypted
data that you wanted to decrypt in the
first place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tant amount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the ciphertext
is compared with another ciphertext you
find out similarities and then you try
to work a reverse engineer your way
accordingly so let's have a quick demo
on cryptography before we begin this
session so to begin with the demo of
cryptography we are on our website
called spammy.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
I say I want to encode a message I turn
a short message into spam so what this
does is you want to send across a secret
message you type in The Secret Message a
short one and it will convert that into
a spam mail you send it across so
whoever is reading that spam mail would
never get an idea of the embedded
message within it so if I want to type
in a message here hi this is a secret
message the password is ASD at the rate
one two three four and I want to send
this out to people or to one of my
colleagues but I want to send it out in
a secret manner so that others are not
aware of this so when I press on encode
what the algorithm would do is it will
convert this message into a spam mail so
my message hi this is a secret message
the password is at the rate one two
three four or ASD at the rate one two
three four gets converted into this now
if you read it dear e-commerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you this doesn't
make sense there is nowhere or no
reference to the actual message that
I've already sent so if I copy this
entire message and I send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
I've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is Pam mimic what
they can do is now in this instance what
I'm going to do is I'm going to open up
a new browser and I'm going to go to the
same website and at this point in time I
am going to click on decode when I click
on decode I'm going to paste the message
that I have just copied there we are and
this message is now being copied into a
different browser and if I decode this
you will see that it will convert it
back to the original message that there
was so the key is there at spam mimic
and it is embedded within the message so
whenever we paste the message in the
decode Factor it knows what the key was
and it can decrypt that message and give
me the actual message that was embedded
within it there we are the entire
message this is what we created in the
Google Chrome browser and in the Firefox
browser we decoded similarly if I want
to protect these kind of messages there
is an aspenencrypt.com website where
let's say we use text encryption and I
want to encrypt the same message this is
a secret message the password is ASD at
the rate1234 and then I give it a
password to protect this message let's
say the word password and I use the
cipher to scramble this by using let's
say AES which is the strongest Cipher
right now and I say encrypt so this is
what the encryption would look like and
basically if I don't have the password
over here if I decrypt it you would see
that there it has occurred if I type in
the password over here and then decrypt
it it will be able to convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original message was
this is a secret message the password is
ASD at the rate one two three four so if
I want to keep my data secure from
hackers I want to scramble it in such a
way that they would not be able to crack
it or it would be very difficult from
for them to crack it and this is one of
the first mechanisms that would be
recommended by any ethical hacker to
keep the data secure
foreign
are you ready for an epic showdown in
the vast realm of cyberspace a battle
rages between two formidable forces the
red team and the blue team get ready to
dive into the thrilling world of Red
Team Versus Blue Team cyber threat in
this digital Battlefield cunning hackers
with the red team tactics Clash had on
with the mighty Defenders of the blue
team it's a high stakes game of which
strategy and Cutting Edge technology
with the fate of our online World hangs
in the balance unleashing their arsenal
of hacking skills the red team seeks to
infiltrate breach and expert
vulnerabilities in the digital Fortress
but fear note for the blue TEAM stands
Vigilant on which state of the art
defenses and unwavering determination to
protect our digital realm this Clash of
cyber Titans pushes the boundaries of
innovation and pushes Defenders to their
limits the red team's Relentless attacks
serve as a wake-up call revealing
weaknesses that The Blue Team swiftly
fortifies ensuring a stronger more
secure Digital World join us as we
unravel the secrets of the Red Team
Versus is blue team cyber threat delving
into the tactics the challenges and the
triumphs of those who defend against the
ever-evolving forces of cyber Darkness
get ready to witness a battle where the
only outcome is resilience Innovation
and a safer digital future brace
yourself for the Ultimate Clash of the
Cyber Titans Red Team Versus Blue Team
cyber threat before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a show
to simplyness postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered and if these are the types of
videos you would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press the
Bell icon to never miss any further
content now let's get started first
we'll start the agenda of this tutorial
so first we'll start with the
introduction then we'll see what is red
team and then the skill set of red team
and then we'll see what is blue team and
the skill set of blue team then we'll
see the cyber security showdown in which
we will see both the teams how they work
for an organization now we'll see the
introduction that is when it comes to
protecting sensitive data and defending
against cyber threats organizations
employ two teams that is the red team
and the blue team but what do these
teams do and how do they work together
let's find out so we'll start with the
red team the red team also known as the
offensive team it consists of seasoned
Security Professionals who specialize in
mimicking real world attack strategies
their mission is to identify and exploit
vulnerabilities in an organization's
cyber defenses and now we'll see the
advantages of the red team the red team
approach offers several advantages first
it boosts Network safety it helps find
flows in the system term encourages
competition and cooperation and
amplifies knowledge on detecting and
stopping cyber assaults they play a
crucial role in ensuring an
organization's Readiness for prevention
detection and Remediation right team
activities involve thinking like a
hacker to break into a company's
security system with permission of
course they perform various tasks such
as penetration testing social
engineering card cloning and
intercepting Communications by
constantly challenging the blue team's
defenses the red team helps improve
overall security now we'll see the skill
set of their team members so to Be an
Effective red team member will need
skills in software expertise penetration
testing and social engineering
understanding the risk and creatively
strategizing attacks are essential to
overcome the blue team's defenses now
see the certifications that could be the
add-ons for a red team member aspiring
writing professionals can enhance their
credentials through certification such
as certified ethical hacker CH giac
penetration tester licensed penetration
tester offensive security certified
professional and certified red team
operations professional the
certification demonstrate expertise in
offensive security and penetration
testing now we'll see what is a blue
team now we'll shift our Focus to the
blue team that is also known as the
defensive team their primary role is to
maintain an organization's internal
Network defenses against cyber attacks
they work tirelessly to protect valuable
assets detect threats and respond
swiftly to any security breaches now see
their activities so what do they do so
the blue team is responsible for
analyzing digital traces auditing the
domain name system constructing
firewalls monitoring Network traffic and
employing access controls their aim is
to establish a stone security posture
and prevent unauthorized access now we
will see the skill set of blue team
member so to Be an Effective member of
the blue team one must possess skills in
risk assessment threat intelligence and
hardening techniques they work with
intrusion prevention systems inclusion
detection system and other security
software to defend against cyber attacks
now we'll see the certifications that
will be the add-on for beauty members
social educations like home tier
Security Plus giac certified incident
Handler certified Information Systems
auditor giac Security Essential
certification system security certified
practitioner Advanced security
practitioner and certified Information
Systems security professional these can
help blue team professionals enhance
their defensive security expertise and
the red team and The Blue Team must
collaborate effectively to ensure
optimal security The Exchange
information about emerging dangers and
hacker techniques enabled board teams to
stay one step ahead however in some
cases the blue team may not be informed
so the red team and The Blue Team must
collaborate effectively to ensure
optimal security now we'll see the cyber
security showdown in which we will see
how they operate now we'll dive into the
intense showdown between the red team
and the blue team now which are this the
red team launches a sophisticated attack
on the organization's Network attempting
to breach its defenses and gain
unauthorized access to sensitive data
now the red team utilizes their Advanced
skills that is penetration testing
social engineering and exporting
vulnerabilities to carry out their
attack their goal is to infiltrate the
network and extract valuable information
without getting code on the other side
the blue team is constantly Vigilant
monitoring Network traffic analyzing
security logs and employing advanced
defensive measures their objective is to
detect and prevent any any unauthorized
access and swiftly respond to any
security breaches as the red team
progresses through the network they
encounter various obstacles put in place
by The Blue Team firewalls intuition
detection systems and other security
measure challenges their every move but
the red team is persistent utilizing
their expertise to find loopholes and
exploit weaknesses meanwhile The Blue
Team closely monitors the red team's
attack patterns analyzing their
techniques and reinforcing their
defenses in real time they actively
collaborate sharing information and
strategizing to mitigate the ongoing
threat the main objective as the red
team is to help organizations identify
vulnerabilities in their systems by
simulating real world attacks they
provide valuable insights that enable
The Blue Team to enhance their defensive
capabilities and the red team plays a
crucial role in cyber security strategy
their simulated attacks push blue team
to the limits and reveal weaknesses the
red team plays a crucial role in our
cyber security strategy their simulated
attacks push us to the limits that is
push blue team to the limits and reveal
weaknesses that they might otherwise
Overlook it's a constant battle but it
helps them stay prepared and strengthen
their defenses ultimately the red team
and The Blue Team rely on collaboration
and mutual respect to succeed while the
red team exposes vulnerabilities the
blue team's role is to learn from their
experiences adapt their defenses and
continuously improve the organization's
overall security posture and before we
begin with the course if you are someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security by graduating from the
best universities then try giving a show
to Simply learns post schedule program
in cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered discuss the common types
of attacks the first and foremost and
the most common attack in today's world
is that the denial of service attack or
a distributed denial of service attack
this attack is launched by attacker not
to not for personal gain but to harm the
other organization by crashing those
services or making the services
unavailable for legitimate users thus
causing monetary harm and reputational
harm to the organization they actually
try to restrict the access to these
resources for legitimate users by
consuming all the bandwidth or the
resources made available then there are
password attacks these attacks are
essentially where you're trying to crack
the password of a user so that you can
get access to their account and through
their access you can then leverage those
access and capture data that you
wouldn't have otherwise gotten access to
when man in the middle attack is where
you are trying to capture data package
over the network that are flying between
the victim and the target server so
essentially placing yourself between the
communication channel that has been
opened between the victim and the
targeted server and you're trying to
capture the data package you're trying
to analyze those data packets and
capture any secret information like
usernames passwords any other
transactions that the user might be
doing then you have email attacks the
attacker sends bait offer in the form of
an email so these would be your phishing
attacks that would come under the Gambit
of social engineering phishing attacks
are nothing but fake mails that look
very genuine to the end user and thus
persuade them to click on links that
lead to malicious servers thus
compromising the device of the victim
SQL injection attacks are normally
targeted to websites or web applications
ever that have a database connected to
them the database and the application
interact with each other using SQL
language or structured query language if
not configured properly and if there are
no firewalls watching a user can craft
malicious SQL queries which can then
dump data or give out unwanted
information to the hacker that should
have been protected in the first place
and then if you have the eavesdropping
attack where the attacker observes the
traffic on the system and works and the
work you are doing on your computer
eavesdropping could be where your truck
you're tracking wipe calls or you have
installed a Trojan on somebody's mobile
phones and you're trying looking at all
that information let's look at the
certifications that are available in
this field the foundational knowledge
that you would require is a graduate in
computer I science or any IIT security
related field most of the universe
universities nowadays provide this kind
of certifications you should have solid
grounds in ID fundamentals that means
you should be technically very Adept you
should understand how protocols work how
networking works you should be somewhat
convergent with some scripting languages
and should be able to understand
programming knowing networking and
mastering networking is a very
fundamental requirement even if you
later on decide to go into application
security and you're looking at
programming languages applications still
work over the network and you need to
know how these networks are going to be
configured and how data is going to be
transmitted over this network coding
skills like I said programming not from
a developer's perspective but at least
good enough to understand how the
program functions what the flaws may be
in the programming code that has been
given and how you can break that
particular code that is what is required
a few scripting languages like PHP pull
python Ruby they would be a lot helpful
at this point in time maybe bash
scripting or Powershell scripting as
well and then our understanding of the
architecture of an operating system we
just don't want to know how the
operating system works and how it
functions we should be able to
troubleshoot the operating system to
recover from errors flaws and we should
know how the operating system works
stores data and interacts with the
hardware at the first place with
everything there is now cloud and cloud
is gaining traction a lot we got public
clouds like Amazon Microsoft and Google
we got private clouds like VMware
Microsoft again Citrix and so on so
forth most of the organizations in
today's world have a hybrid environment
where they've got a part physical ID
infra and part Cloud infrastructure so
learning what cloud is the nuances of
cloud the services that a cloud can
provide software as a service
infrastructure as a service and platform
as a service understanding them and then
knowing how you can secure these or what
the vulnerabilities are in the first
place and then trying to secure them is
of very much a sense in today's world
over a period of time you will have to
learn Cloud security to be relevant in
today's world especially with iot
artificial intelligence and machine
learning uh picking up pace and then
malware analysis and reverse engineering
so let's say there's a new virus that
has been released and there's an
anti-virus company who's working to
figure out how the virus Works what are
the signatures that are created by the
virus and this is where those malware
analysis skills come into the picture
even in real terms or in normal terms if
you have working in an organization and
if a machine has been infected or is
suspected of an infection you need to
investigate the machine to identify
whether it was a worm virus or a Trojan
and need to take effective action to
prevent further compromise from
happening and that is why malware
analysis is of importance as well the
certifications that you have certified
ethical hacker it will train you in
reverse engineering so this is where you
basically look at offensive security
this is where you're looking at hacking
and you're looking at how the
methodology is the five steps that we
have talked about and this course deals
with each and every one of those five
steps and helps you analyze and
understand the tool sets and the skills
that are required for each of that
particular step salaries May range
between 71 000 US Dollars and above in
the U.S market and around around five
lakh rupees and more in the Indian
market after ceh we have got the ecsa
slash lpt course ECA says the easy
Council certified security analyst
Course once you get certified that you
can then apply for the lpt which is the
license penetration tester so it's for
CH then ecsa EC console certified
security analyst and then lpt license
penetration tester this gives certified
penetration testers the opportunity to
practice their skills and gives you a
license where you have a certificate
that proves that you have understood the
methodology and are very Adept at the
skills of hacking when we hear the term
hacker we may picture a dangerous cyber
criminal however not all hackers are
inherently bad they are powerful
individuals who use their technical
skills to break into computer networks
and bypass security measures
hacking is not always bad and it is to
be noted that the world of computers is
actually safer to an extent because of a
particular type of hacker
a hacker is deemed to be good or bad
depending on their motive and whether or
not they are breaking the law in this
video we will acquaint you with the
differences between a white hat hacker
black hat hacker and a gray attacker
through a short story hackers are
basically categorized by the type of
metaphorical hat they don't white hat
gray hat and black hat hackers can
either be a black hat or a white hat or
a gray hat hackers can be good or bad
depending on which color hat they decide
to wear and by this we mean that hacking
motives and obviously not in the sense
of creating a fashion statement here
let's have a look at our story
our story here revolves around Dan who
is the owner of a company that provides
a platform for video conferencing
his platform enables online
communication for video meetings audio
meetings and webinars
just like other video conferencing
platforms his platform too has built-in
features like chat recording screen
sharing and so on
everything went well and his business
increased tremendously with the onset of
the covid-19 pandemic
covid-19 accelerated the rise of the
worldwide digital economy and it made
people rapidly adopt video conferencing
tools and apps in a contactless world
starting from employee interactions to
family get-togethers to Virtual workout
classes everything happened virtually
dance video conferencing platform
enabled long-distance communication and
enhanced collaboration
so now you might be wondering what could
have gone wrong well there are many
risks involved when it comes to the
safety of these online platforms
online meeting rooms are susceptible to
a number of digital threats Dan received
complaints from his customers that his
platform was insecure and safe anymore
little did Dan know that the popularity
of his video conferencing platform made
hackers eager to disrupt the virtual
meetings and hijack the conferences
his platform witness complaints like the
addition of an unknown participant in
every meeting room someone covering up
information that is being presented and
also unknown screen recording of a
meeting to name a few
peace Intruders were sneaky hackers who
tried to gain access to sensitive
information and who try to disrupt
meetings
and how did these hackers manage to do
all this well this was done by
exploiting weaknesses in Dance computer
network in order to obtain unauthorized
access to crucial data and sensitive
information
this is known as hacking and the
individuals who carry this out are known
as hackers
in this form of hacking that Dan
witnessed hackers exploited Dance
Company security posture by identifying
weaknesses in it in order to intrude
into the meetings and gain access to
business data or personal data and this
form of hacking is definitely bad and
unethical the hackers who carried this
against Dance Company are known as black
hat hackers
these hackers are cyber criminals who
carry out cyber attacks with a negative
intention
these attacks can be in the form of
trojan virus malware attacks phishing
attacks DDOS attacks man-in-the-middle
attacks SQL injection attacks and so on
so who exactly is a black hat hacker
like in the case of dance organizations
Cyber attack
ERS are highly skilled cyber criminals
who break into computer systems and
networks with malicious intent they
illegally hack into a system and this is
obviously without the system owner's
approval
such hackers do not abide by the laws
they violate loss and disrupt networks
the motive Behind these attacks vary
from Montreal gains to personal profit
usually they are for monetary gains
black hat hackers May violate the
confidentiality Integrity or
availability of a company systems and
data they may also use malware to
destroy files or steal passwords credit
card numbers and other confidential
information
black hat hackers are also sometimes
called crackers
but this is who a black hat hacker is
moving back to Dan's story black hat
hackers disrupted his business and he
lost his customers as nobody wished to
communicate on an unsecure platform it
is but true right would you be okay to
use a platform that is unsafe none of us
want to have unknown people in our
meetings right this is how dance
customers fell too and this new spread
and his company's reputation took a bad
hit
that is when Ted approached Dan so who
is dead let's have a look at that snow
Dead who was unknown to Dan explained to
him that he found Dance Network to be
weak Ted told Dan that he has identified
vulnerabilities in dance systems and
networks and he will fix them provided
Dan pays him well Dan had nothing to
lose and without any further delay he
painted a good amount of money to fix
the vulnerabilities in dance networks on
receiving the money Ted began his work
and he fixed all the issues and
vulnerabilities in Dance Network he made
sure that nobody can exploit Dance
Network vulnerabilities again and this
way he safeguarded Dance Network for the
time being so who is dead well he's
called a gray hat hacker as they say not
all things are black and white so is the
concept of gray hat hackers as
fascinating as the name sounds let us
dive deep into understanding the role of
a gray hat hacker a gray hat is a
security expert who may at times violate
the loss or the ethical standards
however they do not carry a malicious
intent unlike a black hat hacker hence
they are known to work both defensively
and offensively they land between the
good and the bad gray hair attackers
look for vulnerabilities in a system
without permission but with good
intentions
just like how Ted informed Dan about how
he could exploit dance system
vulnerabilities gray hat hackers inform
an organization the same and in return
ask for a fee to fix it in some cases
when the organization doesn't comply
gray hat hackers may become black hat
hackers although a gray hat Hacker's
intention might not be bad what they do
is still illegal since they do not have
permission to break into another system
back to our story all the dance issue
was sorted by Ted for the time being he
had a few concerns
his first concern was history repeating
itself yes he was worried about what if
black hat hackers hack into his systems
again although his system
vulnerabilities are fixed at the moment
it was a matter of time before they
could be exploited again with new
hacking techniques
his next thought was to have a
professional who could constantly keep a
tab on his networks and protect it from
hackers don't you think his concerns
were Justified yes it was as this was
the only way he could provide a safe and
secure video conferencing platform in
the long run
that is when Dan's friend came to his
rescue and introduced Anne the ethical
hacker to him and being an ethical
hacker a short Dan that she would scan
and identify his Network for system
vulnerabilities before an outsider
exploits it and she would fix those
vulnerabilities on a regular basis such
ethical hackers like Anne are called
white hat hackers now that we saw who
black hat hackers and gray hat hackers
were it is time we learn about a third
type of hacker who is a white attack
hacker a white attacker gains access to
networks with an intention to fix the
identified weaknesses
they also perform penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments and break
into systems with permission
they search for loopholes or
vulnerabilities in any given piece of
technology just like how a black hat
hacker would do however white attackers
hardened their organization system
before the bad guy can get in
their goal is to spot system and network
vulnerabilities in order to improve
system security white hat hackers are
also known as ethical hackers since they
obey the law of the land and follow a
code of ethics
many companies and government
organizations employ white hat hackers
to help them secure their systems
these hackers are typically hired by
organizations to look for
vulnerabilities in a system like other
hackers
the only difference being they are given
permission to break in
one Stan spots the vulnerabilities she
documents her findings and gives Dan
advice on how to fix that or she'll even
take it up to fix them so that an
outsider cannot spot it in the future
and does this on a regular basis as
system updates happen regularly and it
is imperative to be on track with it and
fix new vulnerabilities
this made sure dance network is now safe
and secure gradually he regained his
customers trust and his platform got
back to being one of the best and safest
platforms for video conferencing
this resulted in a huge business growth
and Dan was very happy
just like how Ann put an end to dance
business problems there are many white
hat hackers out there who are in great
Demand by organizations to safeguard
their networks from cyber attacks and if
you are interested in a career in
ethical hacking then simply learn can
help you fulfill your dreams simply
learn CH version 11 certification
provides you the Hands-On training
required to master the techniques
hackers use to penetrate Network systems
and fortify your system against it
this ethical hacking course is aligned
with the latest CH version 11 by EC
Council and will adequately prepare you
to increase your blue theme skills so
what are you waiting for get certified
with simply learn and become a certified
ethical hacker and put an end to the
Cyber crimes in the world
remember the more active white hat
hackers are the fewer opportunities
black hat hackers have for system
exploitation cyber security has become a
struggle for organizations in 2021
recent Trends the side effects of a
global pandemic and cyber security
statistics reveal a huge increase in
hacked and breach data for increasingly
common sources in the workplace like
mobiles and iot devices
on top of this the covid-19 has ramped
up remote workforces making inroads for
cyber attacks this kind of growth would
not have been possible if not for
several Reliable Tools and services from
scripts that find intricate details of
companies to software that can Brute
Force servers with a single command
today's lesson is all about such tools
that make an ethical hacker effective
let's learn about what is ethical
hacking ethical hacking involves an
authorized attempt to gain unauthorized
access to a computer system application
or data carrying out an ethical hack
involves duplicating strategies and
actions of malicious attackers
often carried out in the form of
security audits ethical hacking is
extremely beneficial to organizations
who are looking to secure the data from
falling in the wrong hands
there are three variants of hackers
while a black hat hacker is notorious
for criminal activities white hat is an
ethical hacker or a computer security
expert who specializes in penetration
testing and other testing methodologies
that ensure the security of an
organization system
there are a few that fall under the gray
hat hacker umbrella where the hacker
occasionally have not authenticated
themselves before attempting to hack an
organization while sometimes requiring a
small fee to report the vulnerability to
the developers directly
the purpose of ethical hacking is to
improve the security of the network or
the systems by fixing the
vulnerabilities found during testing
ethical hackers may use the same methods
and tools used by the malicious hackers
but with the permission of the
authorized person for the purpose of
improving the security and defending the
systems from attacks ethical hackers are
expected to report all the
vulnerabilities and weaknesses found
during the process to the management
directly
ethical hacking has proven itself to be
quite a productive career option for
many ambitious individuals the demand
for its course is today is at an
all-time high and rightfully so it
provides you with an engaging job that
never gets tedious some certifications
like the comp Tia plus ceh and Cisco
CCNA are highly acclaimed and will teach
a learner all there is to know before
dipping their toes in the industry
when it comes to web app hacking It
generally refers to the exploitation of
applications by HTTP which can be done
by manipulating the applications via its
graphical user interface this is done by
tampering with the uniform resource
identifier also known as a URI or
tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be compromised
anyone who uses a computer connected to
the internet is susceptible to the
threats that computer hackers and online
Predators post these online billions
typically use phishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise the computer
security
computer hackers can also try to access
your computer and private information
directly if you are not protected by a
firewall they can monitor your
conversations or produce the back end of
your personal website usually disguised
with a bogus identity Predators can lure
you into revealing sensitive personal
and financial information
a web server which can be referred to as
the hardware the computer or the
software which helps to deliver content
that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertext transfer protocol or http
so hackers attacked the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like DDOS
attacks syn flooding pink flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other end
although wireless networks offer great
flexibility they have their own security
problems a hacker can sniff the network
packets without having to be in the same
building where the network is located as
wireless networks communicate through
radio waves a hacker can easily sniff
the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main hacker
social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer systems
coming to our main focus for today let
us have a look at the top 5 most
essential ethical hacking tools to be
used in 2021
at the top of the chain lies and map
nmap which stands for network mapper is
a free and open source utility for
network discovery and security auditing
many systems and network administrators
also find it useful for tasks such as
Network inventory managing service
upgrade schedules and monitoring host or
service uptime
it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
Bridge the device
nmap uses raw IP packets in novel ways
to determine what hosts are available on
the network what service they are
running what operating systems are
installed what type of packet filters
and firewalls are in use and dozens are
the characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fines against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked device
next on our list we have Metasploit
the betasploit framework is a very
powerful tool that can be used by cyber
criminals as well as ethical hackers to
probe systematic vulnerabilities on both
networks and servers
because it's an open source framework it
can be easily customized and used with
most operating systems
with Metasploit the ethical hacking team
can use ready-made or custom code and
introduce it into a network to probe for
weak spots as another flavor of threat
hunting once the flaws are identified
and documented the information can be
used to address systemic weaknesses and
prioritize Solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the necessary exploit is
value to the system there are a host of
options for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the device
a big advantage of Metasploit is the
ability to run full-fledged scans on the
target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
software having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the list
moving on we have the acunetics
framework
s is an end-to-end web security scanner
which offers a 360 degree view of an
organization security
it is an application security testing
tool that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web assets
the need to be able to test application
in depth and further than traditional
vulnerability management tools has
created a market with several players in
the application security space
accuratics can detect over 7000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other out-of-band vulnerabilities
it can scan all pages web apps and
complex web applications running HTML5
and JavaScript as well it also lets you
scan complex multi-level forms and even
password protected areas of the site
iconetix is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as sast scanners
sast tools only work during development
and only for specific languages and have
a history of reporting lot of false
positives whereas Dynamic testing tools
also known as dast have the ability to
streamline testing from development to
deployment with minimal issues
next on our list we have air Garden
this is a multi-use bash script used for
Linux systems to hack and audit wireless
networks like our everyday Wi-Fi router
and its counterparts along with being
able to launch denial of service attacks
on compromise networks this multipurpose
wi-fi hacking tool has very rich
features which support multiple methods
for wi-fi hacking including WPS hacking
modes WP attacks handshake captures evil
twin and so much more
it usually needs an external network
adapter that supports monitor mode which
is necessary to be able to capture
Wireless traffic that reverse the air
channels
thanks to its open source nature air
Garden can be used with multiple
Community plugins and add-ons thereby
increasing its Effectiveness against a
wide variety of routers both in the 2.4
gigahertz and the 5 gigahertz band
finally at number 5 we have John the
Ripper
John the Ripper is an open source
password security auditing and the
password recovery tool which is
available for many operating systems
John the Ripper jumbo supports hundreds
of hash and Cipher types including for
user passwords of operating systems web
apps database servers encrypted keys and
document files
some of the key features of the tool
include offering multiple modes to speed
up the password cracking automatically
deselecting the hashing algorithm used
by the passwords and the ease of running
and configuring the tool to make it
password cracking easier
it can use dictionary attacks along with
regular brute forcing to speed up the
process of cracking the correct password
without wasting additional resources
the word list being used in these
dictionary attacks can be used by the
users and allowing for a completely
customizable process
we also have a few honorary mentions in
our list that just missed the car
let's Parker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported vulnerabilities
the burp suit professional is one of the
most popular penetration testing and
vulnerability finder tools and is used
for checking web application security
the term book as it is commonly known is
a proxy based tool which is used to
evaluate the security of web-based
application and to do Hands-On testing
moving away from websites and
applications Wireshark is a free and
open source packet analyzer which was
launched in 2006. it is used for Network
troubleshooting analysis software and
Communications protocol development and
education
it captures Network traffic on the local
network and stores data for offline
analysis
captures Network traffic from ethernet
Bluetooth wireless networks and frame
relay connections
now that we learn about the different
types of tools that can be used when
conducting an ethical hacking audit
let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits
being able to identify defects from an
attacker's perspective is game changing
since it displays all the potential
Avenues of a possible hack one can only
prepare for the known vulnerabilities as
a defensive specialist but proactively
trying to breach a network or device can
make hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for
this kind of unpredictability goes a
long way in securing a network against
malicious actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
Network infrastructure as seen on many
occasions a real breach will cause loss
of data and irreparable damage to the
foundation of an organization
being able to gauge such shortcomings
before they become public and can be
used exploited is a benefit most
organizations make use of
this is not to imply that such security
audits are only beneficial to the
organization paying for it when coming
across companies that provide certain
Services a reliable third-party security
audit goes a long way in instilling
trust and confidence over their craft if
the ethical hackers cannot find any
major vulnerabilities that can be
leveraged by hackers it just accentuates
the technical Brilliance of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount with the rise in
censorship and general fear over privacy
loss consumer security is at an all-time
high risk technology has made our life
so much easier while putting up a decent
Target on our personal information it is
necessary to understand how to
simultaneously Safeguard our data and be
up to date with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet Anne Anne wanted to
look for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and founder rather Shady
website that offered a 50 discount on
the first purchase once and submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was
their HTTP webpage instead of an https
one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers Hatcher used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iPhone enthusiasts could have
avoided this particular incident this is
why it's never recommended to visit
unknown websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics we covered today
we take a look into what cryptography is
and how it works we learn where
cryptography is being used in our daily
lives and how we are benefiting from it
then we will understand the different
types of cryptography and their
respective users
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action
let's Now understand what cryptography
is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is a primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply run is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text the only
ones who can are the people who know how
to decrypt the coded word thereby
reversing the process of encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text to encrypt the
message we use certain algorithms that
serve a single purpose of scrambling the
data to make them unreadable without the
necessary tools these algorithms are
called ciphers they are a set of
detailed steps to be carried out one
after the other to make sure the data
becomes as unreadable as possible until
it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it through
the cipher algorithm and get the
encrypted data this encrypted text is
called the ciphertext and this is the
message that is transferred between the
two parties the key that is being used
to scramble the data is known as the
encryption key these steps that is the
cipher and the encryption key are made
known to the receiver who can then
reverse the encryption on receiving the
message unless any third party manages
to find out both the algorithm and the
secret key that is being used they
cannot decrypt the messages since both
of them are necessary to unlock the
hidden content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit more than 65 billion
messages are sent on WhatsApp every day
all of which are secured thanks to
end-to-end encryption
there is a huge Market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption
and hashing let's find out how much we
have understood until now
do you remember the difference between a
cipher and ciphertext leave your answers
in the comments and before we proceed if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up before
moving ahead let's look at symmetric
encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times
Caesar Cipher Enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further
for example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob she can apply a
substitution Cipher or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext stream
ciphers convert the plain text into
ciphertext one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks
in today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is AES
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128-bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available other primitive
algorithms like the data encryption
standard that is the Des the triple data
encryption standard 3des and Blowfish
have all fallen out of favor due to the
rise of AES AES chops UPS the data into
blocks and performs 10 plus rounds of
obscuring and substituting the message
to make it unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key the
public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message Bob uses his own private key
to decrypt the data this way nobody can
intercept the message in between
transmissions and there is no need for
any secure key exchange for this to work
since the encryption is done with the
public key and the decryption is another
private key that no one except Bob has
access to both the keys are necessary to
read the full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information
RSA encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard it is
named after its Founders West Shamir and
Edelman and it uses block ciphers that
separate the data into blocks and
obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time since asymmetric
encryption takes longer to decrypt large
amounts of data the full information is
encrypted using a single key that is
symmetric encryption that single key is
then transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the diffie-hellman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general the
calculations that do the job of messing
up the data collection form the hash
function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in plain text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered passwords
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
Julius Caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table a spy can't decipher the
original message at first glance for
example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use the substitution
shift of plus 2 a becomes c b becomes D
and so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus 3
becomes d w w d f n this Cipher has been
appropriately named the Caesar Cipher
which is one of the most widely used
algorithms
the Enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic Cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the Nazi German armies
when the world wars they were used to
protect confidential political military
and administrative information and it
consisted of three or more rotors that
scramble the original message depending
on the machine's State at that time the
decryption is similar but it needs both
machines to stay in the same state
before passing the cipher text so that
we receive the same plain text message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of RSA encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the ciphertext in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know RSA encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetric key cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well
in RSA we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from a 512 bit to
1024 bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the ciphertext
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on pass freezes the tool we are
using right now generates this
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the
ciphertext this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself in this
scenario let's try and encrypt the word
simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once you click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods now that we are done with the
encryption process let's take a look at
the decryption part
the receiver gets this ciphertext from
the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once you click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of RSA encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner here we just have to take
the private key and use that to encrypt
the plain text and select the same in
this checkbox as well you can see we
have generated a completely new Cipher
text
this ciphertext will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites let's take a
look at Wikipedia here pretty standard
https website where the edge stands for
secured let's take a look at how it
secures the data
Wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use the software to see the traffic that
is leaving our machine and to understand
how vulnerable it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to Wikipedia
[Music]
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a HTTP webpage
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks there is a login form here which
needs legitimate user credentials in
order to Grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform instead we can see the
data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the Wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find our current credentials
if any website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it have been really easy to get a hold
of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid HTTP
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online due to the increase in the
network transactions in the modern era
there are often cases when we Face some
problems regarding network issues
exactly network issues or is somebody
spying on us
well such cases are regarded as Network
sniffing cases
but how exactly a hacker hack into a
network system
well for today's topic we'll understand
the same
let's take a look at Network sniffing
to access the network related
information between devices to gain
profit or use the Hacked data for
illegal purpose is known as Network
sniffing this is a process where a
hacker automations programmer spy into
the network devices of our system
they can access different websites that
we visit often or see our Network habits
let's take a look at different tools
that are suitable for sniffing purpose
Network sniffing tools are softwares
that are available on the internet that
can be used to sniff into the network
let's take a look at some of the famous
Network Tools first one is Avic this is
a networking sniffing tool which has a
specialization in intelligent analysis
for Network packets
next is Wireshark this software tool is
best to look into protocol related data
packets that are often transmitted over
the network
and lastly we have solar wind Network
packet sniffer where the performance of
this sniffing tool is best where the
Performance Management is to be looked
into
let's take a look at the Wireshark
sniffing tool this is an open source
Network sniffing software which is
specifically designed to attack data
packets during a transmission over the
network this type of software uses
different color combinations to
represent different packets and
protocols let's take a look at some of
the uses for the sniffing software
the first uses it is used to analyze
Network packets
whereas it can also be used to
troubleshoot different network issues
which are often used by different
Engineers to test whether the software
or network device is susceptible to an
attack
and lastly it is also used to check
malicious and hacking possibilities on
the network now that we are completed
with the briefing for the software that
is known as Wireshark let's take a look
at the actual demo how exactly Network
sniffing is done you can directly access
the Wireshark software website
where you can find the download option
and download the most suitable
version for your laptop or computer
device
after downloading the software when you
install it
you will get something like this
as we can see these connections are the
connections that are connected to my
laptop right now
and the difference in the graph that we
can see over here represent the traffic
on the network that is present
to much better understand what exactly
is going on the network we can access
one of them let's access the Wi-Fi
network on my laptop
after accessing the network we can see
some packet settings like this
these represents the packet transaction
that has been made on my network through
the internet
and this is how a hacker or a cyber
criminal knows how exactly we use the
Network Services
this part of the Wireshark represents
different detail information about the
transaction that has been made
and the last section represents some raw
data or Garbage data
but how exactly a hacker use all this
jumble data and hack into a system
well to clarify this is an option that
can be used that is known as diff
display filter on the Wireshark software
if you want to search for a specific
protocol for example TCP we can write
TCP in the search filter and search
and now as we can see
we only get the protocols that are
related to TCP
this is how we can differentiate
different protocols and access some of
them to gain knowledge about what
exactly is going on in the network
let's try accessing some other protocol
now
for example
DNS
and as we can see
only the protocol and the data packet
that is related to DNS protocol is
visible to us
to further enhance the display filter
let's try accessing a
different page on the web browser for
example
simplylearn.com
when we access a simply learn website we
can see the professional courses that
are available but let's take a look at
the changes that has been made on the
Wireshark
to know this let's write
TCP and a keyword included contains
and one more thing to include over Eis
during the display filter if you write
something that is related to the
software it will represent in a green
color like this but if you write some
error related keywords like this it will
represent in the red
let's continue with the search setting
including the contains keyword and
writing
simply learn
and entering now as we can see these two
related data packets represent the
simply learn website that we access just
now where the source destination IP
address represent
my system address whereas the
destination that is
13.224.21.74 represent the simply learns
IP address let's take a look
and in the garbage area or the raw data
we can take a look simply learn website
to see some more details regarding the
same
you can access the transport layer
security
and the transmission control protocol
where we can see the source Port the
destination Port which is always 443
as well as
the flag
and the timestamp for the same
this is how hackers get the data about a
network settings
but if we want to search for more data
related to Simply learn website that we
visited just now
they send another filter that we can use
for example
using IP Dot addr
space equal equal and writing the IP
address for the website simply learn
that is
30.224
.21.74 and when we press enter we get
all the related data for the simply
learn website
and this is how we can see the related
data
to much further enhance our display
settings let's try in another example
access your internet browser
and access some other website for
example
dot for example the State University
and access the alawat State University
and some other are net for example the
university State PDF
let's see the changes in our Wireshark
settings
and try using http
when we write this we get the data that
is related to the HTTP but what is the
use for the same
when you access this and right click on
the same and choose the option follow
and HTTP stream
and over here we can take a look at the
post that is the website that we just
visited
now imagine if we were a hacker and we
knew all this we can access any website
that a user visited
and we can hack into his system through
the website
guys but the point that has to be noted
over ERS if we use the network snuffing
tool why shark or some other tool that
is available on the internet for
research purpose or experimental use
that's fine but we shouldn't use all
these softwares for any malicious
activity because that is illegal
now
some of the options that we can see are
the Red Box
this action is used if we want to stop
the traffic connection that means if we
press this option
and clear this and press enter
this shows
that the network settings has stopped
receiving any traffic that is available
on the network but if we want to access
them again
you can choose this Bluefin option
continue without saving and the software
against
start recording the websites or the data
packets that are available on the
network
now let's take a look at an example as
we all know we often visit different
websites and there are some cases we
often see when the Chrome represent a
non-secure option
that represents that the website is
unprotected against network attack
for example we can access a experimental
website
this is a website that allows us to
access the non-secure part of a website
if we write for username as
admin1213 and for password as
simply learn
and login
as this is an experimental website it
says it's sorry and the login has failed
let's take the changes in a Wireshark
software
now as we already did earlier if you
want to access a specific website we
should write
TCP
contains and the keyword of the website
that was
admin
through this we can see this was the
website that we visited just now
but if we want to access the actual
important data that was the password
that we typed
we can use this option
and over here we can see the simply
learn
which was encrypted earlier in the
website
this is how a hacker or a cyber criminal
use different sniffing softwares and
gain data about different users in this
video we bring you the best programming
languages for hacking here we will give
you the top 5 programming languages that
will help you enhance your hacking
skills
first let's understand the importance of
knowing programming for hacking you
might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker as you
might be aware hacking involves breaking
the protocols and exploiting a network
thus being a hacker requires you to
understand the languages of the software
that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim yes there
are several ready-made scripts available
today however you might need to apply
your skills in case the available
scripts don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack it will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking techniques
and make your cyber security career
worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers let
us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn
there are several programming languages
for hacking and it might be overwhelming
to choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that do
keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top five programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language it plays a
crucial role in writing hacking scripts
exploits and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example OS modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security Integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them python has a massive
community that helps with third-party
plugins every day it is also an easy to
read language with a simple syntax this
will be helpful for beginners you can
easily write automation scripts using
Python and it also makes prototyping
much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have JavaScript
currently JavaScript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of JavaScript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitations since most of their web
apps use JavaScript or one of its
libraries
knowing JavaScript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
JavaScript can be used to read saved
cookies and Security Experts also use
JavaScript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
JavaScript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
JavaScript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially JavaScript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development this implies a
larger field for exploitation
a hacker can now use JavaScript to Snoop
the typed words inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is PHP
hypertext preprocessor or PHP is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand PHP as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you're into web hacking
then getting your hands on PHP would be
an asset PHP is used in server-side
scripting using PHP you could write a
custom application that modifies
settings on a web server and makes a
Target server susceptible to attacks
with the help of PHP you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
PHP is one of the most powerful
server-side languages used in most of
the web domains this shows how learning
PHP can help you with web hacking and
also help you fight against malicious
attackers
popular content Management Systems run
on a foundation of PHP hence having a
strong knowledge of PHP can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is SQL SQL is the
acronym for structured query language
although SQL is not a traditional
programming language it is a language
used for only communicating with
databases
several systems like MySQL postgresql
store their data in databases
SQL is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of SQL lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
SQL is used for the purpose of web
hacking SQL is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into a large databases
it will be impossible to counteract
database attacks without a good
understanding of SQL using SQL hackers
can perform an attack known as SQL
injection attack such an attack enables
hackers to access confidential
information from databases SQL is used
by hackers to develop various hacking
programs based on SQL injection
SQL injection is used to bypass web
application login algorithms that are
weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
View and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the C
programming language
it is no surprise that we have C the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field it helps with exploit writing and
development the low-level nature of C
provides an edge over other programming
languages used for hacking
a hacker can use the C programming
language to his or her Advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level Hardware
components such as the ram
Security Professionals mostly you see
when they are required to manipulate
system resources and Hardware
C also helps penetration testers write
programming Scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in C language hence
learning C you will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
C is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits built undetectable
malware key loggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both C and C plus as they both come in
handy for hackers
so those were our top 5 programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
Master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always on that note in addition to
previously mentioned programming
languages we have an additional list of
languages that are also well recognized
for hacking let's have a look at our
honorary mention
first we have Ruby the Ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now there can be a
close comparison drawn between Ruby and
python based on its syntax however Ruby
is more web focused
Ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits Ruby has been used by several
hackers to exploit corporate systems it
is not that easy to master Ruby and that
is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know Ruby
second we have Pearl although Pearl has
lost its old Fame it still holds value
in the hacker Community for exploit
writing
there are systems that still run on Perl
as it was the go-to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate Linux text files and help you
create tools and exploits
pull code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is HTML many of you
might have wondered why we didn't
mention HTML yet yes no programming list
is complete without mentioning HTML
the hypertext markup language HTML is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glues the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web this shows
the importance HTML has
an understanding of HTML is vital to
play with web applications
HTML also Finds Its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
HTML is a must if you want to master
this field having said that HTML is not
that tough a language to learn hence it
is advised to master HTML if you want to
compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have a simply level
language it is undoubtedly one of the
most powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn
it is a complicated low-level
programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine Hardware or
software using it
Assembly Language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and Trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse Engineers use Assembly Language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go-to choice
as complicated as a language sounds the
results it produces are highly fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages help cyber
Security Professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals Kali Linux is an
operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution that is
made specifically for penetration
testers let's start by learning about
Carl Linux in general
Kali Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools that
are targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
Kali Linux is a multiple platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and hobbyists
among all the Linux distributions Kali
Linux takes its roots from the Debian
operating system Debian has been a
highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop
while the operating system is capable of
practically modifying every single part
of our installation the networking
components of Kali become disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a deeper
element of control to the most
enthusiastic of users
we did not get Kali Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its history
Linux is based on years of knowledge and
experience in building penetration
testing and operating systems during all
these project lifelines there have been
only a few different developers as the
team has always been small the first
project was called warp X which stands
for white hat knopex as can be inferred
from the name it was based on the nopics
operating system as its underlying OS
Optics had releases ranging from version
2.0 to 2.7
this made way for the next project which
was known as wax or the long hand being
white hat slacks the name change was
because the base OS was changed from
nopics to slacks wax started at version
3 as a Nord at carrying on from mop X
there was a similar OS being produced at
the same time auditor security
collection often being shorted to just
auditor which was once again using
nopics
its efforts were combined with wax to
produce backtrack backtrack was based on
slackware from version 1 to version 3
but switched to Ubuntu later on with
version 4 to version 5. using the
experience gained from all of this Kal
Linux came after backtrack in 2013. Kali
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when Kali Linux became a
rolling operating system
now that we understand the history and
the purpose of Kali Linux let us learn a
little more about its distinct features
the latest version of Kali comes with
more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either simply did
not work which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality
the Kali Linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code basis to external asset greatly
reduces the risk of source contamination
which can cause Kali Linux users
worldwide a great deal of damage as a
direct victim of cybercrime
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in their native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in general
since rmbs single board systems like the
Raspberry Pi are becoming more and more
prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Kali Linux is available on a wide range
of arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainland
distributions so the tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution
all this information is necessary for
users to determine if Kali Linux is the
correct choice for them if it is what
are the ways that they can go forward
with this installation and start their
penetration testing Journey
the first way to use Kali Linux is by
launching the distribution in the live
USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the Kali Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB
some people don't need to save their
data permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the caviar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USPS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations
but what if the user wants to store data
permanently in the installed OS the best
and the most reliable way to ensure this
is the full-fledged hardness
installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of Linux
the next alternative route for
installing Kali Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtualbox the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and Kali Linux
can be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window
the hardware requirements will be
completely customizable starting with
the allotted Ram to the virtual hard
disk capacity
the usage of both a host and guest
operating system like car Linux allows
users a safe environment to learn while
not putting the systems at risk if you
want to learn more about how one can go
forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where Kali Linux is
being installed on VMware while running
on a Windows 10 operating system you can
find the link in the description box to
get started with your very own virtual
machine
the final way to install Kali Linux is
by using a dual boot system to put it in
simple words the Kali Linux OS will not
be overrating any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and Kali Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system there are multiple ways
to install Kali Linux we can either
install it on a normal hard drive in a
virtual machine software such as VMware
or virtualbox or we can do that in hard
bare metal machines now for the
convenience of explanation we're going
to install Kali Linux today on a virtual
machine software known as VMware
VMware is able to run multiple operating
systems on a single host machine which
in our case is a Windows 10 system
to get started with Kali Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image file
you go to get Kali
and as you can see there are multiple
platforms on which this operating system
can be inverted as per our requirement
we're going to go with the virtual
machine section as you can see it is
already recommended by the Developers
this is the download button which will
download a 64-bit ISO file we can
download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet
after clicking on the download button
we can see we have a window archive
which will have the ISO files
for now we have downloaded the ISO file
and it is already present with me so we
can start working on the VMware side of
things
once the ISO file is downloaded we open
up VMware Workstation
go to file
and we create a new virtual machine
in these two options it is highly
recommended to go with the typical setup
rather than the custom one the custom is
much more advanced and requires much
more information from the user which is
beneficial for developers and people who
are well versed with virtualization
software but from 90 of the cases
typical setup will be enough
here we can select the third option
which will be I will install the
operating system later and some
operating systems we can use the ISO
file here directly and VMware will
install it for us but for right now in
the case of Kali Linux the third option
is always the safest
color Linux is a Linux distribution so
we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here I have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels
every distribution has a parent
distribution for example Kali Linux as
Debian and there are other distributions
which are based or forked from some
parent distribution columnist is based
off Debian so we can go with the highest
version of Debian which is the Debian
10.x 64-bit
go on next we can write any such name we
can write Kali Linux so that it will be
easier to recognize the virtual machine
among this list of virtual machine
instances the location can be any
location you decide to put by default
this should be the documents folder but
anywhere you put it will hold up all the
information of the operating system all
the files you download all the
configurations you store everything will
be stored in this particular location
that you provide
when we go next
we are asked about the disk capacity
this disk capacity will be all the
storage that will be provided to your
virtual machine of Cal Linux think of
your Windows device if you have a one
terabyte of hard drive you have the
entirety of the hard disk to store data
on how much data you give here you can
only store up to that amount of data not
to mention some amount of capacity will
be taken up by the operating system
itself to store its programs and
applications
for now we can give around let's say 15
GB of information or if a recommended
size for type in is 20 you can just go
ahead at 20 it depends all on the user
case if you are going to use it
extensively you can even go as high as
50 or 60 GB if you have plans to
download many more applications and
perform multiple different tests
another option we get over here is
storing virtual disk as a single file or
storing them into multiple files
as we already know this virtual machine
run entirely on VMware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over here
instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible
for all scenarios except it is much
easier if the split the virtual disk
into multiple files now even if this
makes what importing virtual machines
easier from either system to system or
software to software let's say if you
want to switch from VMware to virtualbox
or vice versa the performance takes a
small hit it's not huge but it's
recommended to go with storing the
virtual disk as a single file if you
have no purposes of ever moving the
virtual machine even if you do it's not
a complete stop that it cannot be ported
it's just easier when using multiple
files but in order to get the best
performance out of the virtual machine
we can store it as a single file over
here
this is a summary of all the changes
that we made and all the configurations
that have been settled until now now at
this point of time we have not provided
the dot ISO file yet which is the
installation file for the Kali Linux
that we downloaded from this website
as of right now we have only configured
the settings of the virtual machine so
we can press on finish
and we have color Linux in the list now
to make the changes further we press on
edit virtual machine settings
the memory is supposed to give the ram
of the virtual machine
the devices with ram of 8GB or below
that giving high amount of ram will
cause performance issues and the host
system if the memory has some amount of
free storage left let's say on idle
storage my Windows machine takes about
2GB so I have 6 GB of memory to provide
although if you provide all of the 6gb
it will be much more difficult for the
host system to run everything properly
so for this instance we can keep it as
2GB of memory for the virtual machine
instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as well
hard disk is pre-set up as the SCSI hard
disk and it does not need to be changed
for the installation of this operating
system at all
cdid DVD this is where the installation
file comes you can think of the ISO file
that we downloaded as a pen drive or a
USB thumb drive which is necessary to
install an operating system to provide
this
we're going to select use ISO image file
we're going to click on browse
go on go to downloads and select the Im
so file over here
select open
and you can see it is already loaded up
next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use Nat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or Lan segments but those are
not necessary for installation
rest of them are pretty standard which
do not need any extra configuration and
can be left as it is
press OK and now we can power on this
virtual machine
in this screen we can choose how we want
to proceed with the installation
we have a start installer option over
here
so we're going to press enter on that
you're going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO file
the first step in the installation is
choosing the language of the operating
system
for this we can go with English as
standard
this is a location this should be used
for setting up the time and some of the
internal settings which depend entirely
on the location of the user so for this
we're going to go with India
configuring the keyboard it's always
recommended to go with the American
English first many people make a mistake
of going with the Indian keyboard if it
is possible and it provides a lot of
issues later on so it's always prefer to
go with the American English and if
later we see some necessity of another
keyboard dialect that business required
we can install it later but for now we
should always stick with American
English as a basic
at this point it's going to load the
installation components from the dot ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a hostname for the system
this hostname can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a lan cable let's say if we
use the name Kali
domain name you we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation
this is the full name for the user
let's say we can provide the name as
simply learn as a full name
next you're going to set up a username
this username is going to be necessary
to identify the user from its use root
accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one two three
now we have to choose a password for the
user now remember since this is the
first user that is being added onto this
newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator
we can use whichever password we like
over here
and use the same password below and
press on continue
at this point it's going to detect on
the components on which the operating
system can be installed
like here there are multiple options
like the use entire disk use entire disk
and setup lvm this entire disk and setup
encrypted lvm for newcomers it is
recommended to just use the first one
since lvm encryption is something that
we can learn afterwards when you are
much more Hands-On with the Linux
operating system for now we're going to
use the use entire disk guided
installation and press on continue
when we set up the virtual machine on
VMware we had set up a disk capacity
that we gave a preposition 20 GB that is
the hardest which is being discovered
here even though it is a virtual disk on
VMware it acts as a normal hard disk on
which an operating system can be
installed
so we select this one and press on
continue
here there is a multiple partition
system
all the operating systems that are
installed have different components one
is used for the keeping of the
applications one for the files other for
the RAM management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one partition
and we're going to select that and press
on continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine
we can press on finish partitioning and
write changes to disk and continue
it's just a confirmation page as you can
see it showed that SCSI 3 is our virtual
hard disk of 20 GB disk capacity
write the changes to the disk we press
yes and click on continue
at this point the installation has
started now this installation will take
a while depending on the num amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quick assistance this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a while
since this is going to take some time to
install as it is being run on a virtual
machine with only 2GB of RAM we're going
to speed up this part of the video so we
don't have to waste any more time just
watching the progress bar
foreign
is completed it's asking us to configure
a package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and in the app
store for the Apple devices
it's an interface to install external
applications which are not installed by
default let's say for Google Chrome or
any other browser which can be used to
browse the internet
at this point of time it's ask us to
select our Network mirror we're going to
select as yes and move forward with this
next
is going to ask us for a HTTP proxy
which we can leave it as blank and press
it as continue forward
at this point of time it's looking for
updates to the Kali Linux installation
this will fetch the new builds from the
Kali server so the installation is
always updated to the latest version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it has installed the grub
bootloader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press continue
remember the installation was conducted
on dev SDA
so we're going to select installation of
the Guard loader on the same hard disk
that we have configured
we press this one and press continue
so now the grub bootloader is being
installed
the grub is highly essential because it
is it shows the motherboard where to
start the operating system from even if
the operating system is installed
correctly and all the files are in
correct order the absence of a
bootloader will not be able to launch
the OS properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete so now we can press on
continue
and it's going to finalize the changes
foreign
Linux being booted up straight away it
doesn't check for the ISO file anymore
since the operating system is now
installed onto the virtual hard disk
storage that we had configured before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up before
and we have the calendar system booted
up
and this is your home page
we can see the installed applications
over here which are being used for
penetration testing by multiple security
analysts worldwide
all of these come pre-installed with
Carl Linux and others can be installed
using the APT package manager that we
had configured
we can see a full name over here
and with this our installation of the
Kali Linux is complete
in today's world an organization's most
valuable asset is its information or
data
this is true for all kinds of businesses
be it public or private on a daily basis
they all deal with enormous amounts of
sensitive information
as a consequence terrorist groups
hacking teams and cyber thieves often
attack them to ensure the safety and
protection businesses use a variety of
security measures and regularly update
their index
organizations must be proactive in this
age of digitalization by regularly
assessing and updating their security
hackers discover new methods to breach
firewalls ethical hackers or white hat
hackers provide a fresh perspective on
security the conduct penetration test to
validate security measures generally
they will penetrate your networks and
give you relevant information about your
security posture once an organization
has this knowledge it may upgrade its
security procedures accordingly
the latest version of Kali Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed
after reviewing every tool that was
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a great number of tools that
either simply did not work
or which duplicated other tools that
provided the same or similar
functionality
occasionally when conducting penetration
testing or hacking we must automate our
activities since there may be hundreds
of conditions and payloads to test and
manually examining everything is time
consuming
to improve our productivity we utilize
tools that come pre-packaged with Carly
Linux these tools not only save us time
but also accurately capture and process
the data
the Kylie Linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external assets greatly reduces
the risk of source contamination
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need to do for the
job
since Arm based single board systems
like the Raspberry Pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Kali Linux is available on a wide range
of arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainline
distribution so tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution tools let's begin with
some terminal Basics on Kali Linux
when most people hear the term Linux
they Envision a complex operating system
used only by programmers however the
experience is not as frightening as it
appears Linux is an umbrella term for a
collection of free and open source Unix
operating systems there are many
variants like Ubuntu Fedora Debian these
are distributions which will be a more
precise term when using a Linux
operating system you will most likely
utilize a shell which is a command line
interface that provides access to the
operating system Services the majority
of Linux distributions shipped with a
graphical user interface also known as
GUI as their primary shell this is done
to facilitate user interaction in the
first place having said that a command
line interface is suggested due to its
increased power and Effectiveness by
entering the commands into the CLI tasks
that require a multi-step GUI procedure
may be completed in a matter of seconds
we can start the terminal by clicking on
the prompt icon here on top
once the terminal is open
we can put up a command use another
command known as mkdir which is supposed
to stand for make directory and I write
nf2 shortage for new folder 2.
if I open up the NF you can see the new
folder is created
this is how the PWD command works
another important command
to change directories it's called the CD
command let's say right now if I am in
NF I want to create a new file in an F2
folder or something else in the nf2
folder I have to shift to CD and F2
now if I write PWD
it will show the present working
directory of Home simply learn desktop
NF and inside that I am in nf2 right now
it is done to navigate through the Linux
files and disk directories it requires
either the full path or just the name of
the directory if we have to move a
completely different folder on a
completely different file then we can
use the entire path like this
for now CD Works another few commands is
we can write CD dot dot and it will come
back one folder now the PWD will be just
NF and not nf2
let's say we are in this folder and we
want to go a different file let's say if
we just go for CD
home
simpler
that's it
right now these are the folders in our
current present working directory
we have the desktop the documents
downloads Etc
from here we can again go to the desktop
using the same CD command
cross check the changing of directories
and check the files again and yes there
we go and if how do we know this what
are the command that we are used to show
the files and folders that folder is
known as the ls command LS can be used
to view the contents of a directory by
default this command will display the
contents of your current working
directory if we add some other
parameters we can find the contents of
other directories as well
there are some hidden files as well in
Linux which cannot be showed just with
ls for example if we just go to cdetc
which is a configuration folder for
Linux if we write LS now these are the
files that can be seen
if you want to see the hidden files
we'll have to add one more parameter
here like LS minus a and as you can see
the number of files have increased this
time around
there are other things as well that we
can see with Linux
LS minus a l will show the hidden files
along with some of the parameters and
some of the permissions that has been
provided for each file
as you can see many of these files have
root access some of them can write some
of them can read
it differs file to file and the ls minus
Al command is used to check each of
these files permission and change them
accordingly if needed
the next command that we can look for is
the cat command or concatenate
it is one of the most frequently used
commands and it is used to list the
contents of a file on the output
for example let's say if I have a file
at the desktop
in this nf2 folder I will create a
document
create an empty file
e file
I'll open up the document
and I'll write it as
hello Kali
I will save this up
now to change the directories from Etc
to nf2 we have already discussed how to
use the CD command using just the folder
name now if you want to go through the
entire directory we can write Siri
home
as you can see it is already prompting
us to complete the name of the directory
at this point we just have to press tab
and it completes it for ourselves
next we already know we have to enter
the desktop
NF and nf2
and this brings us to the current
working directory here if we press LS we
can find a file over here now as
discussed for the concatenate it is used
to show the contents of a file so right
now if we press cat which stands for
concatenate
if I
as you can see we have written hello
Kali in the text file and we can see the
output right now
we can also use it to create new files
for example if we write cat
any file name such as e-file 2.
here we can write anything
hello Kali again
once you press Ctrl C here we can check
e File 2 and we have hello Kali again
printed over here we can see the same
using the concatenate command as well if
I press LS you can see we have two files
here and I can go with cat e file to
and I have Hello Kali again this is how
the concatenate command works
apart from this it can be used to copy
there is a different command like called
CP which is used to copy the files from
one place to another mindful this is not
moving this is only going to copy the
command for example currently our PWD
which is the present directory
is in the nf2 folder as you can see over
here
let's copy the E File 2 to the NF folder
we can write CP
e file to
and give the path of the NF folder which
will be home
simply learn
Tech stock
and an F
now if I press LS I'll find both the
files in nf2 since I copied
to go back to the NF folder again we can
again use the same command of
no we can again use the home
simply learn
desktop
and just an F no nf2 this time just
enough
as you can see this will change back our
present working directory now when we
press LS we will find the E file to file
and the nf2 folder and we can confirm
this using the GUI as well
this is the NF folder and you can see
the nf2 folder and the e-file to
document if I write cat e file to
cat e file to
we can see the contents of the file now
this can be done using moving as well
for example if I go to CD nf2 which is
the inside folder it has both the
document files like e file and e-file 2.
let's say I want to move the e-file
completely from nf2 to NF1 instead of
writing CP the command I'm going to use
is MV MV e file and again give the path
of the folder into which I have to copy
which will be again home
foreign
simply learn
desktop
and NF as you can see the contents of
the nf2 have appeared here and e-file
has been moved
from nf2 to
NF
this is this nf2 and we don't find e
file here anymore if we press CD dot dot
and we go back to NF LS right now and we
can file both the files e file that we
moved and E file to that we copied from
the nf2 folder so this is how copying
and moving will work using the terminal
now this is just a simple one line
statement that might take a couple of
clicks when using GUI this is why the
command line interface is considered to
be much more streamlined for Linux
operating systems
another very important con command for
Linux operating system is the sudo
command Sudo is short for super user do
the command enables you to perform tasks
that require administrative or root
permissions you can think of it as how
we run programs administrator on Windows
systems it is not advisable to use this
cupboard for daily use because it might
be easy for an error to occur and the
permissions of root are very intricate
so new beginners are advised to use the
sudo command only when absolutely
necessary for example
sudo SU
with this command I am giving this
terminal a root permission this Su
stands for this user
at this point it's going to ask for my
admin password
once I enter my password
and I now have root access note how the
password that I entered did not show up
here this is a security measure to
prevent people from snooping on your
root password which is the end game of
all this operating system
as you also can see the symbol changed
if the dollar symbol is showing its
source as a standard user when you
switch to root you can easily see a hash
symbol
this opens up a separate shell inside
this terminal command for example we can
exit out of the root user to the
standard user using the command exit and
once again we have the dollar sign and
the root has vanished over here there
are some commands that will only work
with administrative access for example
when updating the Kali Linux system we
have to use apt update
as you can see it says problem unlinking
the file because permission denied now
let's try this using sudo
sudo APD update
as you can see it is updating the
package repositories which work as the
software installed on the system
this can be done using either writing
the pseudo command every time we want to
perform a root access or we can just
write sudo Su once and write apt update
alone
the fetching is complete over here
for the second example let's say I just
write sudo Su and this time is not going
to ask me the password because at this
current terminal process I've already
provided the root password once and it
is in memory right now now when we used
to update the system we had to write
sudo apt update that was because we were
running it as a standard user now we are
running it as a root user so all we have
to write is if it update and it's going
to continue its work
there you go
another command that can be useful is
the Ping command
self-explanatory it's going to be
checking the internet connectivity you
can be used to check internet
connectivity or you can see if there is
a local server on your system which
needs to be ping then you can check
there for example if we have to write
ping and we can use either IP address or
domain let's say if you want to check
that if we can access google.com using
this Kali Linux installation or not we
can write ping google.com
and you can see it shows the bytes being
sent and received and how much time it
took to take up the request
this can be done for local systems as
well for example this installation of
Kali Linux is being run on a virtual
machine
once this machine is running I still
have my host machine running over here
the IP address of which is
192.168.29 179
if I try to Ping this from here
as you can see the time to complete the
request is drastically low compared to a
website on the internet considering this
is on the local network
this is how the pink command is worked
and it can show you what kind of
packages are transmitted how many are
received if there was any kind of packet
loss between the connection window and
other details
a very important command when working
with the terminal for long duration is a
history command
pretty self-explanatory there are so
many commands that are being run
sometimes people forget what was the
change they did oh what was the
directory name they put a history
command helps to recover some of the
commands that you have written it
doesn't go all the way back but it takes
up many commands that were inputted in
the last few processes
this is how the history command works
these are some of the most commonly used
terminal commands if you want to learn
more about this terminal and every other
feature of this please let us know in
the comment section and we'll try to
make an in-depth tutorial especially
figures
repeat if you want to learn more about
the terminal please let us know in the
comment section and we will try to make
an in-depth tutorial specifically for
terminal commands on Linux
moving on we learn how to configure
proxy chains on a system
proxying refers to the technique of
bouncing your internet traffic through
multiple machines to hide the identity
of the original machine it is a good
tool that hackers use to accomplish this
goal is proxy chains
essentially you can use proxy chains to
run any program through proxy server
this will allow you to access internet
from behind a restrictive firewall which
hides your IP address
even allows you to use multiple proxies
At Once by chaining them together
one of the most important reasons that
proxy chains is used in a security
context is that it's easy to evade
detection attackers often use proxies to
hide their true identities while
executing an attack
and when multiple proxies are chained
together it becomes harder and harder
for forensic professional to trace the
traffic back to the original machine
when these proxies are located across
countries investigators would have to
obtain warranties in the local
jurisdictions where every proxy is
located
to see how proxygen works let's open
Firefox first and check our current IP
address
write Firefox
and there we go
as we can see Firefox is now open
let's check our current IP address right
now
if we go to an address called my
ip.com
and you can see the easily detects our
country is in India and this is a public
IP address
now if we move to the terminal again
here we can now write
proxy chains
minus h
what this minus H does is it finds a
help it it stands for the help file this
is for help file
what we found out using this is proxy
chains has a config file here
Etc
proxychains4.conf this is the config
file found using this config file we can
customize how our proxy change should
work
if we want to open that we have to use
it in a text editor on Windows we have
notepad and other things like that
Microsoft Word to edit documents on
Linux we have a tool called Nano to
access the Nano we use the command Nano
and give the path of the file that we
want to check as of right now the proxy
chains config file is located over here
so we're going to follow the path there
chains 4 Dot comf
and here we go we see the config file
there are three basic types of proxy
chaining here
we have a strict chain where all the
proxy in the list
will be used and they will be changed in
order
we have a random chain where each
connection made through proxy genes will
be done via random combo proxies in the
proxy list so in your Dynamic chain it's
the same as strict chain but dead
proxies are excluded from the chain
and here we can set up whichever type we
want
to enable or disable a particular type
we use the hash symbol here as you can
see right now all the lines have a
hashtag symbol at the front except this
one a dynamic chain this is the current
one being used let's say if I want to
use a strict chain method so I can add a
hash value here
and remove the hash here at one point of
time any one of these three four types
should be enabled
let's go for the denim Dynamic chain
we can disable this strict Chain by
putting the hashtag in front
and removing the dynamic chain
as you can see below we have few
commands to how to handle the Nano text
editor this symbol is known as the
control button on your keyboard now if
we want to write out which is synonymous
to saving the file
supposed to go with Ctrl O So if I press
Ctrl o on my keyboard it says file name
to write and we have to press enter here
since we want to overwrite the proxy
chains 4.0 and F5 we don't want to
create a new file over here so just
press enter
and we get a permission denied this
permission denied we're getting is
because we have opened this using a
standard user Etc is a system folder to
be able to use make some changes you
have to use it using a sudo command to
exit this Nano we have to use the
control X command we use Ctrl X
we're going to clear
and this time we're going to use the
sudo command
sudo Nano
Etc
proxy chains
4.0
and we have the same file open up again
now this time if you want to make a
change let's say we're going to add a
strict chain instead of a dynamic chain
which remove the hashtag from straight
we're going to use Ctrl o for the save
file option we're going to press enter
and it says root 160 lines
again if you want to reverse this change
we put the hashtag over here
enable Dynamic chain
we press Ctrl o
press enter and it says root 160 lines
now we can exit straight away using the
control X format
right now we have not provided any file
or a proxy chain we can have proxy IP
addresses from the internet but we have
to make sure that they are safe and they
don't Snoop on our data
when there is no proxy change being
provided personally it going it's going
to use the Tor Network but for that we
have to start door
is a service in Linux to know more about
the store we can write sudo systemctl
which is used to know the status of
services on the Linux operating system
and status of torque
a system CTL sorry uh as instead of STL
it should be system CTL status Tor as
you can see it is a toss service
anonymizing overlay Network for TCP
connections and it's currently inactive
now to start this up we have to write
sudo system CTL start
Dot now if we repeat the same sudo
system CTL status Star as you can see
it's active now
you can see the green logo over here
okay
to integrate the Firefox and the browser
we can use the proxy chains command
directly over here we can write proxy
chains we can use Firefox to launch our
web browser and let's say if you want to
visit google.com
we press enter
and the Firefox window is launched
and it should open up google.com next
and there we go
if we go to myip.com once again
as you can see we have a different IP
address and the country is a known as
well
so this is how we can use proxy chains
to anonymize a internet usage when using
Kali Linux
next on our agenda is the ability to
scan networks using nmap
at its core nmap is a network scanning
tool that uses IP packets to identify
all the devices connected to a network
can learn more about nmap using their
help file
as you can see these are some of the
parameters that can be used when
scanning ports of a system you can see
the version and the URL of the webs of
the service
over here the primary users of nmap can
be broken into three group processors
first the program gives you detailed
information on every app IP active on
your network and then each IPA can then
be scanned
secondly it can also be used to
providing a lot of live hosts and open
ports as well as identifying the OS of
every connected device
thirdly
and map has also become a valuable tool
for users looking to protect personal
and business websites
using nmap to scan your own web server
particularly if you are hosting your
website from home is essentially
simulating the process that a hacker
would use to attack your site attacking
your own site in this way is a powerful
way of identifying security
vulnerabilities
as we already discussed The Host Windows
10 machine on the system has an IP
address a 192 168 29.179
if you want to test the OS scan of the
system we're going to first get the root
permission over here
we use the sudo command and now we are a
root user we're going to launch the
command and map
minus o which is supposed to be an OS
detection scan the IP address we can use
of the host system
192 .168.29.179
in a legitimate penetration testing
scenario we can use the IP address of
the vulnerable disk device over here
we are going to let it scan for a while
and it's going to give us some guesses
on what can the OS be
as you can see the scan is done and it
has shown some of the ports that are
open
you can see the msrpc port open at the
https 443 Port open which is used to
connect to the internet and it has some
aggressive OS guesses as well for
example it thinks there's a 90 94 chance
that it's going to be a Microsoft
Windows XP Service Pack 3. that's partly
because a lot of the Windows XP update
packages are still prevalent on Windows
now that the OS detection is confirmed
there are multiple more details that we
can gather from nmap
let's go with the NF minus a command
which is supposed to capture as much
data as possible
there is also a speed setting you can
call it a speed setting or a control
setting of the minus t
minus t ranges from t 0 to T1 to T true
all the way up to D5
this basically determines how
aggressively the victim is being scanned
if you scan slowly it will take more
time to provide the results but it will
also give a less chance for the
intrusion detection system on the
vulnerable machine firewall to detect
that someone is trying to penetrate the
network for now if we want to go with
somewhat of a high speed we can go with
the T4 and provide the same IP address
of the local machine I am trying to
attack
it's going to take a little bit of time
since it's trying to capture a lot of
information
as you can see the results are now
here
it launched a scan and took a few top
ports that are most likely vulnerable
from a Windows XP perspective and it
showed
a few ports over here it has not shown
991 filtered ports which could not be
attacked anyway since they were closed
for outside access it shows a few
fingerprint settings like the connection
policies and the port details
it shows an HTTP options some other
intricate details that can be used when
you attacking its servers
it shows a VMware version that it's
running
and some few other ports over here
apart from that we also have the
aggressive OS gases over here just like
we did with the minus o and you can see
this time it is showing Windows 7 as 98
percent
no exactos matches since uh if there was
any exactos matches we could have seen
100 chances over here
this is a trace route a trace route will
be the time and the path a connection
request takes from the source to the
destination for example this request
went from 192
168.72.2 to a destination address since
this is a local machine it took only a
single step and multiple occasions so if
you're trying to access a remote system
it's going to be a number of free suits
when it jumps from firewall to firewall
and router to router
this is how we can use nmap to find
information about a system and find some
vulnerable ports we can access
moving on we have a tutorial on how to
use Wireshark to sniff Network traffic
to start using Wireshark we're going to
have to open the application first now
during installation of Wireshark there
is an option to enable if non-root users
can be able to capture traffic or not in
my installation I have disabled that so
I will be launching Wireshark when using
the root user itself
also to capture data we need an external
Wi-Fi adapter
you can see it over here in the VM tab
removable devices
our link 802.1 and WLAN
this is a external Wi-Fi adapter which
is inserted into my USB system
you can see it over here if I write
iwconfig
this is the one wlan0 this is absolutely
necessary because we need to have a
monitor mode required but it won't need
it for sniffing data on Wireshark right
now but it's going to be necessary later
on in this tutorial as well as we will
see for now we can just start up
Wireshark by writing its name on the
command line and it should start the
program
here we go
here it's going to check which of the
adapters we want to use for example
right now the eth0 which supposed to
stand for ethernet 0 Port you can see
data is being transmitted up and down
we're going to select eth0
and we have started capturing data you
can see this data requests from the
source so destination and the time and
the which protocol it is following
everything we can see and we can see the
ipv4 flags here as well
as you can see over here
capture internet traffic
we can try running Firefox
if we just write Wikipedia
.com
and you can see the number of requests
increasing
okay this is spelling mistake Wikipedia
yeah
you can see the application data of all
these requests going up
and they're connected to a destination
server of 1 0 through 102.166.224
now if you even if we check the
transmission control protocol Flags over
here and so many more things we cannot
find anything beneficial as you can see
the information over here is gibberish
which is supposed to be since it's
supposed to be encrypted
now
this is possible due to this being an
https website hence you can see the lock
symbol over here and connection is
supposed to be secure
now what about HTTP ports we have seen
many people recommend to not visit HTTP
ports
repeat
we have seen many people recommend to
not visit HTTP websites and even if we
have to visit to not provide any
critical information
for example let's go to a random
HTTP page over here
as you can see this is
saying connection is not secure and this
is an HTTP HTTP page and not https
now let's check for some of the
information that is passing through this
this is a login form let's say I have a
legitimate account over here
if I write my account name
and my password is supposed to be
password one two three four
I press login
and the password does not match because
I do not have an account over here but
let's say I did and I was logged in as
expected you can go to Wireshark we can
use filters over here now all the
requests that I am sending it's a TCP
request so I can write a filter
containing TCP
contains
whatever string if it is being passed
let's say for the end user name I write
my account name
so I can just write my account name over
here
and press enter
to find a request over here now as you
can see
there are many flags over here
if we go to the HTT HTML form URL
encoded and open up some of its Flags as
you can see I can see my account name
and simply learn password over here this
is the same
details that I input on the website
let's say I did have a legitimate
account on this website I would have
logged in with no problems but anyone
who would be using Wireshark to sniff on
the data can easily get my credentials
from here this is why it's recommended
to not provide any information on HTTP
Pages the security is not up to the mark
and always look for the lock symbol when
visiting any website or making any
internet transactions or providing any
information
this is how we can use Wireshark to
detect transmission and sniff packet
data that is being transferred to the
network adapter
next we have to learn about what is
Metasploit
the Metasploit project is a computer
security project that provides
information about security
vulnerabilities and AIDS in penetration
testing and IDs development
we can open up the terminal here we're
going to allow root access
and to open up Metasploit the key word
is msf console
that's going to take a little bit of
time to start it up
now the Metasploit console has been
loaded
from here we can decide what type of
attack we want to launch and what kind
of exploits we can launch against
vulnerable targets for example like we
already discussed I am running this
virtual machine on a Windows 10 host
machine so if I open the command prompt
for my Windows 10 over here
if I need to check the IP address once I
go with ipconfig
here you can see the IP address of this
local machine
moving on
if we have to attack that machine let's
say we want to see what kind of exploits
are going to work over there
now we already know that Windows has
some common vulnerabilities one of those
vulnerabilities is the HTA server
vulnerability HTA is supposed to be a
HTML application but when past the right
payload it can be used to open a back
door into a system
to start off with the Metasploit and
accessing such applications
we're going to use the command use
exploit and the name of the reverse HTA
server is this windows
for miscellaneous
HDA server
as you can see it already found this one
all right now there are some options
that we need to set for this exploit to
go through for example you can see some
of the options over here there is a
payload the payload is supposed to be
the malicious file that we are going to
send on the HTML application which
allows us to give the back door
for example right now the payload which
is the malicious file is a Windows meter
printer reverse TCP
thank you
completely understandable now let's set
the L host
L host and R host and SRV host should be
the one where we are going to launch the
attack from for example if we launched
another tab of this console
and we just press i f config
the IP address is 192 plus 168 72130
so we're going to set the L host as
192.168.72.130
and we're going to do the same thing
with SRV host
we're going to set up port
where we need to capture the back door
axis
next the payload has already been set
this payload will launch a back door and
give us meta printer access to the
system metaprita is can be considered as
an upgrade of a normal command prompt
shell
we will look into it once we get the
access in the first place
now that we have set the commands we can
press on exploit and press enter
now you can see we have a URL over here
we're going to copy this URL
once the URL is copied we take it into
the browser
and paste it
this will ask us to download this file
now as per browser security settings
this file should be blocked by default
we can decide to keep it and with the
correct formulation of this malicious
package even the website browser
antivirus softwares will not be able to
detect good payloads we're going to save
this file
and we're going to open it
publisher could not be verified if we
press run and we go back to our meter
beta access over here
you can see it has already captured the
URL of an HD server and it is writing
delivering payload
just have to wait for a few seconds so
the payload is delivered
it has sent this much amount of data
meter Peter session one is opened
and we should get the access soon
there we go now to understand where is
the session set
we can write sessions minus I
as you can see it has a meter beta over
here we're going to write sessions minus
I
recession ID is one so we're going to
write 1. and we have the meter beta
access now to get a fair idea of the
system
we're going to write Source info and
it's going to the computer name the OS
architecture all these things we can
write the help command to see what are
the things that we can get out of the
system we can take screenshots we can
control the webcam and start a video
chat
we can take a lot of things over here
there are other commands as well where
we can change the file directory like
the cad command CD command there are so
many things that work in the normal CMD
which we can run on the meter beta as
well now if you want to access this
command prompt of the system directly we
can go with this we have to write shell
and there we go we are in the downloads
folder right now to see if this is the
same computer or not we're going to
write ipconfig
as you can see it is our victim machine
with 192.168 or 29.171 we can just press
exit and we're back with the meter beta
access
this is how we can use metafreter and
Metasploit to gain access to a Windows
10 machine next let's take a look at how
we can get to root access from a Windows
10 system
we just learned how we can get a meter
beta access from a system
we can background this meter Builder
session by writing background and
pressing enter
we can still we can still see the shares
sessions minus I it's still present over
here
now
these kind of access are not
administrative access these are the kind
of back tools that can be created for
standard users but to get a complete
access of a system including the program
files the windows documents we need to
have root access or administrative
access
through that we're going to use another
exploit
reminder that the meter Peter session of
the standard access is already present
and we're not messing with it right now
we're going to set up another session
albeit with the same machine
that exploit name is
use exploit windows
local
bypass USC
Event Viewer
and there we go now if we check the
options that we can put in the system
we have to choose an exploit Target
we need to put a session as well
let's say we going to use the session
one this is the session that has the
meter beta access with the standard user
it doesn't have the system user
we're going to write
set Session 1
and we're going to run export run a few
commands and it opened a second meter
beta session
as you can see it is the assessment too
if I write this info
you can still see I am not the
system user right now I'm still just a
normal user how can we check that
if you go to Shell
it's still CC users canopy downloads all
these things
if I press exit
go back to the meter paper there is a
command on meter beta get system it
attempts to elevate your privilege to
that of the local system which basically
means you get promoted into root access
so if we write get system
and due to pipe impersonation we now
have the system root access
as you can see now it has become x64 and
we are the admin users now if I go to
Shell
I can easily go back
windows
and I can easily access these things
this kind of control over the windows
folders and the program files folders
these kind of things are not possible if
you are not an admin access or the
command prompt has not been run with
admin permissions this is how we can use
privilege escalation to get into an
admin access system
we use the second exploit which was the
bypass us Event Viewer exploit
and essentially used to do the first
session as you can read here Windows
escalation USA protection bypass
it was first disclosed on 2016 but it
still works on some systems so let's
start out by learning what parrot
security is
parrot OS is a Debian based index
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom hard Linux kernel while
being founded in 2013.
parrot security contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and hobbies
it features a distant forensics mode
that does not Mount any of the system
hard disks or partitions and has no
influence on the host system making it
more stealthy than regular mode this
mode is used on the host system when
there is a need for executing forensic
procedures
in software development a rolling
release is a paradigm in which software
upgrades are rolled out constantly
rather than in batches of versions this
ensures that the software is constantly
up to date a rolling release
distribution such as parrot security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market
the basic introduction to the operating
system out of the way let us have a look
at the bare minimum system requirements
necessary to be able to run this
operating system
first up we got a CPU requirement which
states that a one gigahertz dual core
CPU is the absolute minimum in order to
use parrot OS while multiple core
systems will provide more Optimum
performance a small beginner has been
included
a very distinct thing to be noted is
that the operating system can be
installed on all variants of chipsets
build 32-bit 64-bit and the newly
popular arm portfolio of devices
unlike Kali Linux which requires some
amount of graphical acceleration needed
to display the operating system
correctly paratoos has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of machines
taking into account the ram issue a
minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free Ram
provides the optimum usage scenarios
even when the OS is installed on a hard
drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB
information which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box
when it comes to booting options you
have the option of going with the Legacy
BIOS settings or with the more modern
UEFI settings
these are just some of the requirements
for the installation of parrot security
OS to understand this process more
vividly and to learn how visualization
can help install an OS in our existing
computer please follow the link to our
parrot security installation video
linked right above
let's understand what some of the things
that make parrot security unique among
all the other penetration testing
operating systems
along with all the giant catalog scripts
parent security has its own custom
hardened Linux kernel which has been
modified explicitly to provide as much
security and resistance to hackers as
possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second Gateway taking
care of malicious requests and dropping
them off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the paratos development
team will most likely iron it out first
before passing it on as an update
the custom hardened kernel wasn't
reasoning enough parrot security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the galley Linux
users
all the tools you found in Kali are
present in paratos and then a few extra
ones for good measure this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
size of the installation file between
both operating systems
however it's not all productivity points
for parrot OS they provide a choice
between two different desktop
environments the main desktop which
comes pre-installed by default and KDE
for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a Linux
system being highly modular in nature
one can use Kali Linux or parrot OS
while adding another desktop environment
which they find appealing
has only a single option parators has
managed to provide two optimized bills
with made desktop and KDE desktop
ready-made on the website
one of the primary advantages of parrot
OS over Kali is at its relatively
lightweight
this implies that it takes frequently
less disk space and computing power to
function properly with as little as 320
MB of ram required
in reality parrot OS is also designed to
operate successfully of a USB stick but
Kali lilacs does not work well from a
USB stick and is generally installed in
a virtual machine
parrot OS can be seen as more of a niche
distribution if you're searching for
something lighter than Carl Linux there
are multiple ways to go about with this
installation
many people prefer to install it
directly onto a hard disk where the
parrot security OS will override
whichever data the hard disk already has
now this is beneficial if you want to
preserve your data for the long term but
this might pose some trouble to people
who do not have a spare hard disk or do
not want to lose their current
installation of Windows operating system
another way to use parrot security is by
using the live boot but whatever changes
you make to the live boot operating
system those changes are removed the
moment we restart or shut down the
system
a very good Common Ground between both
these installations is virtualization
using virtualization software like
VMware or virtualbox we can install
parrot Security on our systems while
simultaneously saving our data and
having the convenience of a host machine
such as a Windows operating system in
case things go wrong
to start the installation we first need
to get a ISO file for the parrot
security operating system
this can be found in the current website
parrotsac.org
once you enter the website move into the
download section
and select the get security Edition over
here
parent security OS has multiple desktop
environments to you to choose from these
desktop environment serves as a
different user interface for the user
for example right now we have the made
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to them
for our example let's go with the made
desktop
we have two options either we can go
with the direct download or we can get
the torrent file
for this example if we press on the
download button
and our download will start
I have already downloaded this file but
the ISO file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around four and a half GB of space it
will be used to install this operating
system in VMware
once the file is downloaded we can close
this and open VMA Workstation
VMware can also be used as a player
version or the Workstation version if
you have much more familiarity with
using virtualbox or virtualization
application we can use that as well
once the VMware is open
we click on file and select a new
virtual machine
for the first time installation we're
going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine OSS going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with a typical
option
moving on it will ask us for a source to
where to install the operating system
from since you're going to use a live
ISO first we're going to select the
third option which will be I will
install the operating system later and
press next
as we already know parent security is a
Debian derivative so When selecting a
guest operating system type we're going
to go with Linux
and the selection we're going to choose
whichever the highest version of Debian
is along with a 64-bit OS
we're going to click on next we're going
to name our virtual machine let's say
parrot security
OS
we're going to select the location where
we want to save the virtual machine this
will have all the hard disk of the
operating system installation
we're going to click on next
for the disk size we're going to specify
how much of the current memory are we
going to allocate this is the hardest
memory of the operating system
installation whatever changes you make
in the operating system whatever
applications we install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage you
can go as high as possible and we're
going to select the recommended 20 GB as
written
when given the choice of storing the
virtual disk as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that helps
them stay portable people change systems
and sometimes they want to swap their
instances between the work and their
personal computer
if there is no portability in mind
storing the virtual disk as a single
file gives the best performance and
should be the recommended go to when
installing for the first time
we click on next here and it's going to
give us a summary of the settings we
have already settled till now
we're going to press on finish
and there we go we have our installation
First Step completed
here on out we're going to click on edit
virtual machine settings
here we're going to have a look at some
of the requirements that the parrot
security OS will need
it is known to be a memory lightweight
operating system but just to have the
almost Optimum performance we're going
to provide around 2 GB of RAM from our
host system which is a Windows 10
machine
when it comes to the processors I'm
going to increase it to 2 and the number
of course to 2 as well so giving out a
total four processor cores to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at hand
size has already been set at 20 GB and
the rest of them are pretty standard and
we can go on
one thing that we need to make sure is
selecting the CD DVD IDE here we have to
use a ISO image file over here
previously it should be used physical
drive and at Auto detect we're going to
use a use ISO image file over here we're
going to click on browse
we're going to go to where we have
downloaded the ISO file which is over
here
and select it
press OK here
and we can now power on this virtual
machine
at this point of time there are two
options we can go with the try install
option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode
to get a better user experience we're
going to go with the try install mode
specifically press enter
and it's going to start the live boot
ISO meanwhile
VMware has an
prompt over here where it will try to
install some VMware tools on it while
this is not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that we can get some additional features
like drag and drop with the host system
and many more things for now we're going
to close this prompt
foreign
security operating system
currently it's running the mate desktop
as we have downloaded in the website
the live boot ISO is necessary to get a
good feel of the operating system there
are many good Linux distros that have
this live boot option so that you can
give a try of the operating system
before installing it permanently
once you are into the live board we can
start off with the installation using
the shortcut as you can see install
parrot
I'm going to double click it
and this is a calamaris installer
choose your language as American English
and press next
you can select your time zone according
to your location
character and we can go next
at this point of time you have to choose
the correct keyboard now what many
people go get confused is choosing their
own language keyboard but people must
keep in mind is what keyboard the laptop
provides
most of the systems that come pre-built
provide the English US keyboard so
whatever keyboard you choose make sure
to type here and test that all the
buttons including the superscript and
the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this step
once you've settled on the keyboard that
you need to install
you can go ahead
here it'll ask you to select storage
device and the only option you are going
to get is the amount of hard disk
storage you have given in the virtual
machine settings we have already
provided 20 GB of storage we're going to
choose that
and we're going to erase this disk
manual partitioning can be useful when
you are going to install parrot Security
on an operating system or on a hard disk
where it is already including a Windows
OS for now we're going to select erase
disk and press next
we're going to give our full name Let It
Be simply learn
you can give the name of the computer
and if this is the username which you
will use to log in
this is your root password that we are
going to give over here the root
password of this Kali Linux will act as
the administrative access and it will be
necessary it will make changes through
the system or installing an updating
software
enter the password
and repeat it over here
you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this disabled
click on next
this is another summary of the
installation that we are going to move
forward with have a look at whatever
changes we have made is according to
your requirements and once everything is
checked we can press on install
click on install now
and we're going to let it complete the
work
as you can see the installation of
parrot security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart Now button over here disabled
I am going to click on done
we're going to shut down this live boot
ISO
I'm going to click on menu
turn off the device
and shut down
we're not restarting straight away
because if you remember correctly in the
virtual machine instance settings we had
given it an ISO file
please remove the live medium and press
enter to continue we can just press
enter to continue
and it's going to shut down now to move
on we're going to click on edit virtual
machine settings
go into CD DVD and we're going to use
physical drive now
we're going to remove it from the iso
image file because installation has
already been completed and we don't want
to use the same ISO file again and again
by using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20 GB hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it
I'm going to press ok
and we're going to power on this virtual
machine for testing
make sure this you clicky s over here
this is the grub menu
at this we get different choices for
example which NVIDIA drivers off or with
some other Advanced options
more often than not we're going to
choose the first option and press enter
if you remember clearly we did not get
the option of try install or a terminal
run just like we did in the live boot
ISO since this is running straight from
the 20 GB hard drive storage it's going
to start the OS directly
now with the login screen you can see
our username over here as we provided in
the installation
we're going to enter our root password
and press enter
and this is a currently working desktop
of the Paris security operating system
you can open the terminal over here
and we're going to try our root password
and installation
to install any software we're going to
use the keyword sudo APD
installed and Neo fetch
we're going to use the root password
that we use to log in
I'm going to press y for yes
this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had provided
now that we have installed a Neo fetch
we can write the command new fetch
and this is going to give us some
information about our installation
you can see the OS name as parrot OS
4.11 is running on a VMware host it's
the kernel versions and some of the
other information like the number of
packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once
and some other things you can see the
memory is supposed to be 1951 megabytes
which is supposed to equal around 2GB of
RAM usage that we had provided
let us compare both these operating
systems directly with respect to their
Hardware specifications and usability
in the end we can decide on what
distribution is fit for each type of
user
for a first point of comparison let's
take a look at the ramp required
for Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature Prime usage is a very
important facet while College Linux
demands at least 1GB of Ram Power
security can operate optimally with a
minimum of 320 MB of RAM
for correctly displaying graphical
elements Kali Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parent security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user side
once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos
they take up a minimum amount of hard
disk storage both of these operating
systems have a recommended disk storage
of minimum of 20 GB in Kali Linux and a
minimum of 15 GB in parrot security so
they can install all the tools necessary
in the ISO file
when it comes to the category and the
selection of tools Carl Linux has always
been the first in securing every single
tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry better
security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a notch
while specializing in Wireless pen
testing parrot security makes it a point
that all the tools that Kali Linux
provides has been included in the iso
while simultaneously adding some extra
tools that many users will have to
install from third party sources in Kali
Linux
being a decade role penetration testing
distribution Kali Linux has formed up a
very big Community with strong support
signature parent Security on the other
hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers
a primary drawback of Kali Linux is the
extensive Hardware requirement
to perform optimally it requires higher
memory than private security it also
needs graphical acceleration while
demanding more virtual hard disk storage
parrot Security on the other hand was
initially designed to run off a USB
drive directly thereby requiring very
minimal requirements from a hardware
perspective like just 320 MB of RAM and
no graphical acceleration needed this
means parrot security is much more
feasible for people who are not able to
devote massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk directly
with the comparison done between both of
these operating systems let's take a
look at the type of users both of these
are catered to
one can go with color Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years
if they have a powerful system which can
run Kali Linux optimally without having
to bottleneck performance
and if they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners
one can decide to go with parrot
security if they want to go with a very
lightweight ending distribution that can
run pretty much on all systems
it also has a lot of tools pre-installed
and some of them are not even present on
car Linux
it is much more suitable for
underpowered rigs where users do not
have a lot of Hardware resources to
provide to the operating system and
thereby it is much more feasible for
people with underpowered laptops or no
graphical acceleration
compared to Kali Linux parrot Securities
desktop environment is also relatively
easier to use for new beginners for
people who are just getting into ethical
hacking pirate security does a
relatively better job of introducing
them to the operating system and the
various tools without having to dump
them into the entire intricacies
in recent years the cost of data
breaches has steadily risen the
additional vulnerabilities that occur
due to the move to a remote Workforce
dramatically enhance the chances for
cyber attacks and introduce several weak
points for hackers to exploit
additionally automated hacking assaults
and the capacity to exchange Bitcoins
via ransomware have increased the cost
of cyber crime in general
companies workforces have transitioned
to full-time work from home models which
gives rise to new attack surfaces threat
actors target the people who are most
vulnerable by taking advantage of
current events and shifting situations
to better understand this growth in
digital crime let us go through a few
statistics
2020 brought with it a slew of new
problems for both businesses and
consumers the midst of a worldwide
epidemic forest fires and political
instability it's easy to overlook a
serious albeit less physical threat it
set a record for data loss due to
cyberth attacks as well as the sheer
volume of attacks 2020 is already
outpacing its predecessor the graph
below denotes the percentage of
companies that fell victim to at least
one Cyber attack in the respective year
with numbers growing steadily we are yet
to see the true Crux of this digital
Revolution
in situations like these penetration
testing has been a gift for
organizations worldwide while security
testing cannot guarantee a 100 solution
it can go a long way in securing those
critical data from falling into the
wrong hands
hey everyone this is Baba from simple
learn
next we know about the benefits of
penetration testing and how the help
organizations save money in the long run
moving on WE familiarize ourselves with
the different types of penetration
testing or ethical hacking with each
serving a different category of
personnel
in the next section we read about the
five distinct phases in every ethical
hacking campaign and how they helped
clear up the extensive report at the end
of every penetration testing session
finally we have a live demonstration on
how we can check for vulnerabilities and
the ways hackers can break into devices
without adequate security measures in
place
let's start by learning about
penetration testing in general
organizations can Define penetration
testing based on the objectives of the
test
all networks applications devices and
physical security components are
included it imitates the behavior of
harmful individuals or the hackers
experience cyber security specialist use
penetration testing to strengthen our
company's security posture and eliminate
any weaknesses that leave it vulnerable
to attacks penetration testing when done
correctly goes beyond simply preventing
thieves from Gaining unauthorized access
to a company systems it generates
realistic scenarios that demonstrate how
well our company's present defenses
might perform in the face of a full
skilled cyber assault the simulation
AIDS in the discovery of the sites of
exploitation and the testing of it
breach security
businesses May acquire professional and
biased third-party input on the security
procedures by conducting frequent
penetration testing
when testing while relatively time
consuming and costly can Aid in the
prevention of highly destructive and
expensive breaches
a white hat hacker employs hacking
talents to find security flaws in
Hardware software or networks on the
other hand whitechat hackers follow the
rule of law when it comes to hacking
instead of blackhead hackers the assist
firms in conducting penetration tests to
analyze the security index and make the
necessary improvements
ethical hacking provides a full audit of
your security policies and in the case
of bug bounties can assist you in
identifying holes in existing
operational systems it takes a far
broader approach to cyber security than
penetration testing
whereas penetration testing focuses on
system flaws ethical hacking allows
actors to utilize any attack tactics
available to them
they can take advantage of system
misconfigurations send phishing emails
launch Brute Force password assaults
reach physical boundaries or do whatever
else they feel will get them access to
critical information
because thieves are progressively
changing up the approaches and launching
multi-layered complex attacks this is
incredibly useful for determining just
how exposed the organization is to cyber
threats
considering the vast domain that is
ethical hacking we have multiple
categories of penetration testing
methodologies let's cover them in the
next section
when configuring a security system
testing is critical to preventing
Hackers from penetrating the perimeter
there are three sort of tests Black Box
gray box and white box
in the Black Box testing the tester
receives no information during the
penetration test in this case the pen
tester takes the method of an
unprivileged attacker from initial
access and execution until exploitation
this scenario is the most realistic
showcasing how an attacker with no
inside knowledge May Target and
compromise an organization
however because of this it is also the
most expensive alternative
white box penetration testing which is
also known as Crystal Box testing
entails sharing all Network and system
information with the tester which
includes Network maps and passwords this
saves time and lowers the overall cost
of a project
a white box penetration test effectively
simulates a focused assault on a given
system using as many attack paths as
feasible
in a gray box penetration test also
known as a transparent box test very
restricted information is present with
the tester gray box testing is
beneficial for understanding the extent
of access a privileged person may get
and the possible damage they could wreck
pre-book tests achieve a mix between
depth and efficiency and may be used to
mimic either an Insider danger or an
assault that has infiltrated the network
pyramid
now that we covered the basics of
penetration testing and the relative
categories one must know how these
testing campaigns benefit the
organizations conducting them
let us go through a few perks of
penetration testing
regular penetration testing helps your
business assess the security of online
applications internal networks and
external networks it also assists you in
understanding what security measures are
required to achieve the degree of
protection your company needs to protect
its people and assets
prioritizing these risks offer firms an
advantage in anticipating hazards and
preventing harmful assaults
penetration testing is similar to a
real-life hacker rehearsing for a
real-life hack regular penetration
testing helps you be proactive in your
real world approach to reviewing the
security of your it infrastructure the
process identifies gaps in your security
allowing you to correct any flaws before
an actual attack happens
it is undeniably expensive to recover
from the effects of a data breach legal
fees ID cleanup consumer protection
programs lost revenue and dissatisfied
customers may cause businesses Millions
penetration testing regularly is a
proactive strategy to remain on top of
your security and may assist in
preventing Financial damage from a
breach while safeguarding your brand and
image
penetration testing Aid in meeting the
compliance and security duties imposed
by industry standards and regulations
such as PCI HIPAA fisma and ISO 27001
having these tests done regularly help
demonstrate due care and a commitment to
information security all while avoiding
the significant fines associated with
the non-compliance
with the entire process seeming to be a
lengthy ordeal what are the multiple
phases in the process
theoretically we have to follow a five
stage process
reconnaissance is the first phase of the
penetration test in this phase the
security researcher collects information
about the target it can be done actively
meaning you are collecting information
by sending a request directly to the
Target and interpreting it
passively where you are collecting data
without contacting the Target or both
it helps security firms gather
information about the target system
Network components active machines Etc
this activity can be performed by using
information available in the public
domain and using different tools
the scanning phase is more tool oriented
rather than performed manually
the penetration tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the Target by using scanners such
as war dialers port scanners Network
mappers and vulnerability scanners the
penetration tester collects as many
vulnerabilities which help in turning to
attack a Target in a more sophisticated
way
the third phase is gaining access of the
system
in this phase the penetration tester
tries to connect with the Target and
exploit the vulnerabilities found in the
previous stage the exploitation will
buffer overflow attacks denial of
service dos attacks session hijacking
and many more
pen tester extracts information and
sensitive data from the servers by
gaining access using different tools
in the fourth stage the hacker has to
maintain access the penetration tester
tries to create a backdoor from himself
it helps the penetration tester to
identify hidden vulnerabilities in the
system and can later access the machine
should the need arise
in the Final Phase of clearing and
covering tracks the penetration tester
removes all logs and Footprints which
help the administrator identify his
presence
this allows the penetration tester to
think like a hacker and perform
corrective actions to mitigate those
activities
with the cost of cyber security
platforms going up train penetration
testers receive an excellent level of
remuneration for the efforts as per
reports the average yearly salary for a
penetration tester is 6 lakh Indian
rupees of 110 000 in the American
counterpart
finally let's go over some of the ways
hackers can identify vulnerable
positions on a system to gather
information in a live demonstration
in this demo we will start by setting up
a VPN connection that will allow us to
access to a vulnerable Network by
creating a local virtual group over the
internet
we then try to scan the victim machine
for breachable entry points find the
username and password of the user in
question and eventually grab the root
password from the device
to start our demonstration we're going
to need a vulnerable machine to work on
now this vulnerable machine can be found
on the website known as dry hack me
which is a service catered towards
penetration testers
before we connect to the machine we need
to
join the network where the machine is
located
we can do that using an ovpn file which
is short for openvpn protocol
to connect to this ovpn file we're going
to go into a new workspace on parrot
security
we're going to activate the root
access
and we're going to connect to it
hack this Dot ovpn
once you see the message initiation
sequence completed
we can be sure that we have connected to
the network which has the vulnerable
machine
now to start the vulnerable machine
we're going to click this button and
wait for a few seconds
as you can see it gives a one minute
countdown before it shows you the IP
address
now remember whatever the IP address we
receive here it is a machine being
launched on the try hack me servers but
we can access that machine because of
the ovpn connection that we have just
set up using this file this ovpn file
can be found on the try hack me servers
profile section which I downloaded
beforehand
as you can see we now have the IP
address of our victim machine
let's try if we can reach this machine
or not
we're going to copy the IP address
and we're going to try and ping to the
machine
if the connection is successful and we
have joined the network we should be
able to see some response over here
as you can see we're receiving request
pings from the victim machine which
means that we have already joined the
victim Network
now that we are confirmed we are able to
access the vulnerable machine
let's run the first step in a
penetration test which is reconnaissance
let's run up and map scan
we're going to use the flag of SV so
that we can know which version of the
service it is running
we're going to take up the IP address
and paste it here
this can only be possible if the open
VPN connection is up and running
as you can see it is still running
and we have our results over here by
running the scan so that we can find the
services running on the host machine
that we will run nmap against
we conclude that a web service is
running actually on Port 80 as we can
see over here which is using the Apache
server system
in addition to this there is a SMB Samba
Service as well
running on ports 139445
now that you know we have an Apache
server we can use this IP address
to open it on a browser
okay
since the current home page is not
accessible we can use some other URLs as
well
Express Apache servers are concerned
there are a certain set of URLs that can
be used to open
however if we go to the URL which is IP
address slash
development
this opens up a new folder
if we try to check the contents of these
files this is for the dev.txt
you can see the version of the Apache
HTTP server that is being run
this is the dev.txt
if we go back and we check the second
file as well
it says the contentsy shadow has the
credentials
okay if we go back again
SMB has been configured
which we have already found out n map
that it is running a Samba server
now with this version of the Apache
server we can find version specific
exploits that can be run on Metasploit
but there is sometimes no no need of
that we can use another technique as we
now know that there are multiple users
that is being run over here we can use a
tool known as enum for Linux
what it does is acts and enumerates the
windows and assamba systems
to run that command we're going to use
enum for Linux
minus a
and we're going to take IP address of
the machine
I'm going to paste it here
what this will essentially do is provide
us usernames that are being stored in
the victim machine
it's going to take some time to find out
the usernames once we find those out we
can run the necessary attacks
as we have already seen on the nvap it
is also happening in SSH port
so if you find the username and we find
a single hash that can be cracked we can
use the SSH to get inside the machine
right now we have to wait for the
results
of the enum fall Linux command
as you can see
we have found two users of the machine
known as K and Jan
I think we can stop the enumeration
right now since we have the two users of
this machine
Next Step what we can do is we can try
to SSH into the machine
now to run the SSH command we're going
to need the password of one of the users
for this example let's say we go with
the user of Jan
to Brute Force we're going to use the
Hydra 2
this is like an example command this is
how we can use let me just copy this
and paste it over here
all right
Hydra minus L user as we have already
decided we're going to use the user Jan
and
we're going to use SSH
for the IP address we're going to copy
it from here
and paste it here
now for the password list we're going to
use a word list
which has a few passwords already
present in it for this example I am
going to use the rocku.txt file which
has like millions of passwords already
stored in it what the Hydra will do it
will try to bypass the SSH console on
the machine using the passwords present
in the rocky.txt file
we will give the path of block Q over
here
like this
and we're going to run it
as you can see it's mentioned that it's
attacking SSH at this IP address
now this attack is going to take a while
and after this attack is done we are
going to get the SSH password which is
basically the credentials of the Jan
user in the victim machine
for now I am going to stop this attack
what I would recommend is for you to run
this attack and write down the password
that you received in the comment section
below
the password that we receive from here
can be used to login into the machine
let's try that once
put SSH into the machine we're going to
the SSH user at the rate
IP address
we're going to write yes and press enter
now we're going to enter the password
that we have found after running the
Hydra command
I am going to type the password and
press enter
and we have logged in
as you can see
now if we try to look around
there are no directories over here okay
so let's go one step back
give a space over here okay
let's go to the second users folder
okay
these are the contents of the K folder
and you can see there's a DOT SSH folder
over here so we're going to enter that
let's have a look the files in this
folder
and we can file in RSC ID over here
which if I'm not wrong should be an RSA
private key
which can be used to SSH into the
machine here we go you can see it's a
begin RSA private key and
it should end
here as well now what this private key
does this hash will be used to log SSH
into the machine when using the user k
once this hash is cracked using Hydra or
any other cracking software like John
the Ripper we can easily use the
passphrase to login into the machine
with the user of K
what I am going to do is copy this
private key
I'm going to launch a new terminal
we'll create a new file known as nanoid
paste the private key over here
and save it
as you can see you have saved the file
over here
now this hash can later be used to crack
into the machine using the user of K
this hash can be cracked using either
John the Ripper Hydra or there are other
Cloud mechanisms that can be used to
crack this machine
after it is cracked
we can use the passphrase derived from
it to SSH into the machine
to perform the SSH entry we're going to
use this command SSH minus I
we're going to use the same file
which we received
we're going to write the username which
is K
10.10
you can just copy it from the
here
right
minimize this and paste the IP address
over here
or we can do one more thing we're going
to use a sudo command together as well
Spectrum
sudo SSH
enter the system password
this passphrase is the one that we
received after cracking the hash in this
ID file
whichever password you received after
cracking this using Hydra or John the
Ripper please write the password in the
comment section so that we can know that
we have successfully cracked the
password we're going to write the
passphrase over here press enter
and as you can see we have entered the
system of K
here we're going to press LS
and we find
the backup file of the password we're
going to write
cat
password back
and
here is the final root password
so as you can see we have now we have
now received the final root password of
the primary user and we have already
cracked the password of the other user
that is Jan
so this is the entire process of how you
can use nmap to find out the vulnerable
points you can see which are the
softwares that are running which
versions they are running and which of
those versions have a legitimate claim
as an insecurs exploit
malware is a malicious software that is
programmed to cause damage to a computer
system Network and Hardware devices
many malicious programs like Trojan
viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive data
let's take a look at the introduction
for two different types of malware virus
androgen
firstly let's take a look what exactly
is a virus program
a computer virus is a type of malicious
program that on execution replicates
itself
they get attached to different files and
programs which are termed as host
programs by inserting their code if the
attachment succeeds the targeted program
is termed as infected with a computer
virus now let's take a look at the
trojanos
Trojan Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms a system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create bad doors into a
system to allow the Cyber criminal to
steal our information
let's take a look how they function
after getting installed into a system
firstly we have virus programs the
computer virus must contain two parts to
infect the system
first is a search routine which locates
new files and data that is to be
infected by the virus program
and the second part is known as the copy
routine which is necessary for the
program to copy itself into the targeted
file which is located by the search
routine now let's take a look at the
Trojan Horse functioning
for Trojan horses entryway into a system
is through emails that may look
legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the closure
program gets installed and infects the
system
they also infect the system on the
execution of infected application or the
executable file and attacks a system
now that we understand what virus and
Provisions are let's understand
different types of virus androgens
let's take a look at different types of
viruses the first one is known as the
boot sector virus this type of virus
damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the master board
record which is also known as MBI
this damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the system
then we have the macro virus microvirus
is a type of virus that gets embedded
into the document related data and is
executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale
and lastly we have the direct action
virus
this type of virus gets attached to
executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system
once the infection of the file is
completed they exit the system which is
also the reason it is known as a
non-resident virus
let's take a look at different types of
approaches
the first type of corrosion is the back
door
they are designed to create a back door
in the system on execution of an
infected program
they provide remote access of a system
to the hacker this way the Cyber
criminal can steal our system data and
may use it for illegal activities next
we have
Crick Source Trojan
they enter the system by clicking the
random pop-ups which we come across on
the internet
they tell the user to give their
personal details for different
transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the Cyber Criminal
and the last Trojan type is Ransom
Trojan this type of Trojan program after
entering the system blocks the user from
accessing its own system and also
affects the system functioning
the Cyber criminal Demands a ransom from
the targeted user for the removal of the
Trojan program from the device now that
we understand some details regarding
viruses and Trojan let's solve a
question
the question is Jake was denied access
to his system and he wasn't able to
control the data and information in a
system
now the actual question is what could be
the reason behind a systems problem
option a macro virus option b Ransom
Trojan option C Backlot version
give your answers in the comment section
now let's understand how to detect the
activity of viruses and Trojan in our
system
to detect virus or Trojan activity in a
system we can refer to the following
points for viruses we have slowing down
of the system and frequent application
freeze shows that the infection of the
virus is present in the system
then we have the viruses can also steal
sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected logout from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system
for Trojan we have frequent system
crashes and system also faces slow
reaction time
then we have there are more random
pop-ups from the system which may
indicate Trojan activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the desktop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a Trojan program
next let's take a look at a famous Cyber
attack for virus and atrogenous
for virus we have the mydum virus which
was identified in the ER 2004 which
affected over 50 million systems by
creating a network of sending spam
emails
which was to gain backdoor access into
our systems
next for the Trojan Horse we have the
emote at Trojan program
which is specifically designed for
financial theft and for stealing Bank
related information
next we have few points for how to
prevent virus entry or Trojan attack for
a system
the most basic way of virus protection
is to using antivirus and do regular
viruses can this will prevent virus
entry in the system and also having more
than one antivirus provides much better
protection
then avoid visiting uncertified websites
can also prevent virus entry into a
system
then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry
for erosion we have using certified
softwares from legal sites to prevent
any Trojan activity in a system
and also avoid clicking random pop-ups
that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and firewalls
for protection against Trojan horses is
a good habit
now that we have reached the end of the
video Let's Take a look what we learned
for the first part we saw the main
objective of the virus is to harm the
data and information in a system whereas
for the Trojan we have stealing of the
data files and information
effect of viruses is more drastic in
comparison to the Trojan horses
then we have viruses which are
non-remote programs whereas Trojan
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
Trojan does not have the replication
ability let's take a look at some of the
famous potent attacks
the first one is Mirai botnut which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a network of bots
that on command perform basic and medium
level denial of service attacks
then we have the zoo spot specifically
designed for attacking the system for
Bank related information and data
now let's take a look at the agenda for
today's video
firstly we will understand what is a
botnet then we'll see how exactly a
botnet works
after that we'll learn some of the
architectures how our botnet works on in
the end we learn how to protect
ourselves from botnet attacks
now let's see what exactly a botnet is
botnet refers to a network of hijacked
interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious quotes known as
malware
each of these infected devices are known
as Bots and a hijacked criminal known as
bot hoarder remotely controls them
the Bots are used to automate large
scale attacks including Data Theft
server failure malware propagation
and denial of service attacks
now that we know what exactly a button
it is let's dive deeper into learning
how botnet works
during the preparation of a bottleneck
Network the first step involves
preparing the botnet Army after that the
connection between the botnet Army and
the control server established and the
end the launching of the attack is done
by the bot hoarder
let's understand through our
illustration
firstly we have a bot order that
initiates the attack
according to the control server commands
the devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system let's see some
details regarding the preparation of the
botnet army
the first step is known as the prepping
the botnet army the first step is
creating a botnet is to infect as many
as connected devices as possible this
ensures that there are enough Bots to
carry out the attack
this way it creates Bots either by
exploiting the security gaps in the
software or websites or using phishing
attacks they are often deployed through
Trojan horses
for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with a specific malware that
connects the device back to the control
button server a bot header uses command
programming to drive the bot's actions
and the last step is known as launching
the attack
once infected a bot allows access to
admin level operation like Gathering and
stealing of data reading and rewriting
the system data monitoring user
activities performing denial of service
attacks including other cyber crimes
now let's take a look at the important
architecture
the first type is known as client server
model the client server model is a
traditional model that operates with the
help of a command and control center
server and communication protocols like
IRC
when the bot order issues a command to
the server it is then relayed to the
clients to perform malicious actions
then we have peer-to-peer model here
controlling the infected Bots involves a
peer-to-peer Network that relies on a
decentralized approach that is the ports
are topological interconnected and acts
as both CNC servers that is the server
and the client to the hackers adopt this
approach to avoid detection and single
point failure
in the end we will see some points on
some counter measure against botnet
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates
after that we should avoid clicking
random pop-ups or links that we often
see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti-spyware software's and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack
Jaden is relaxing at home when she
receives an email from a bank that asks
her to update her credit card pin in the
next 24 hours as a security measure
judging the severity of the message Jane
follows the link provided in the email
on delivering her current credit card
pin and the supposedly updated one the
website became unresponsive which
prompted her to try sometime later
however after a couple of hours she
noticed a significant purchase from a
random website on that same credit card
which she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
Intel credit card brought
this is a classic example of a phishing
attack
phishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted source
its basic purpose is to trick the victim
into revealing sensitive information
like passwords and payment information
it's based on the word phishing which
works on the concept of baits if a
supposed victim catches the bait the
attack can go ahead which in our case
makes Jane the fish in the phishing
emails the bait if Jane never opened the
malicious link or was cautious about the
email authenticity an attack of this
nature would have been relatively
ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials a phishing attack
starts with a fraudulent message which
can be transmitted via email or chat
applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of phishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just providing often
carried out in campaigns or an identical
fishing mail sent to thousands of users
the rate of success is relatively low
but never zero between 2013 and 2015
corporate giants like Facebook and
Google were tricked off of 100 million
dollars due to an extensive phishing
campaign where a known common associate
was impersonated by the hackers apart
from credit access some of these
campaigns Target the victim device and
install malware when clicked on the
malicious links
which can later function as a botnet or
a target for ransomware attacks there is
no single formula for there are multiple
categories of phishing attacks the issue
with Jane or the hacker stole our bank
credentials falls under the umbrella of
deceptive fishing a general email is
sent out to thousands of users in this
category hoping some of them fall prey
to this scam
spear fishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive phishing
techniques on the other hand a simple
screenshot of a Spotify playlist being
shared on social media indicates a
probable point of entry the hacker can
send counterfeit messages to the Target
user while implying the source of such
messages being Spotify tricking them
into sharing private information
since the hacker already knows the
target uses Spotify the chances of
victims taking the bait increase
substantially
for more important targets like CEOs and
people with a fortune on their back the
research done is tenfold which can be
called a case of whaling the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their phishing attack often to
still industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price
apart from just emails farming focuses
on fake websites that resemble their
original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit webpage which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cash poisoning but they
are rarely carried out due to time and
resource constraints
now that we know how phishing attacks
work let's look at ways to prevent
ourselves from becoming victims while
the implications of a phishing attack
can be extreme protecting yourself
against these is relatively
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that it redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or pop-up
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti-phishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prevent fishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all times
so here is a question for you if both me
and my friends receive the same email
that instructs us to change our Spotify
password before the end of the day even
though one of us never use Spotify what
bracket does this phishing attack fall
under
one whaling two spear fishing three
deceptive fishing four farming
think about it and leave your answers
Below in the comments section and three
lucky winners will receive Amazon gift
vouchers
cyber attacks are becoming more
prevalent due to the pandemic where work
from home is the norm and people spend
possibly more than half their day with a
laptop but we cannot stop every attack
at the root we must be informed and
Vigilant to phishing attacks among
others to safeguard our data it's the
year 2015 and Richard has just finished
playing games on his computer
after a long gaming session Richard
tries to shut it down but find some
random text file in the desktop that
says Ransom note the text file mentioned
how a hacking group had encrypted
Richard's game files and private
documents and he had to pay a ransom of
500 worth of bitcoin in this specified
Bitcoin address Richard quickly checked
his files only to see them being
encrypted and unreadable
this is the story of how the Tesla Crypt
ransomware spread in 2015 which affected
thousands of Gamers before releasing the
master key used for encrypting the files
so what is ransomware
for Richard to be targeted by such an
attack he must have installed
applications from untrusted sources or
clicked an unverified link both of them
can function as gateways for a
ransomware breach ransomware is a type
of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
a password a text files available to the
victim explaining how to make the ransom
payment and unlock the files for it just
like Richard found the ransom note text
file on his desktop even after the money
has been paid there's no guarantee that
the hackers will send the decryption key
or unlock the files but in certain
sensitive situations victims make the
payment hoping for the best having never
been introduced to ransomware attacks
before this gave Richard an opportunity
to learn more about this and he began
his research on the topic
the spread of ransomware mostly starts
with phishing attacks to know more about
phishing attacks click the link in the
button above users tend to click on
unknown links received via emails and
chat applications promising rewards of
some nature once clicked the ransomware
files installed on the system that
encrypts all the files or blocks access
to computer functions they can also be
spread via malware transmitted via
untrusted application installation or
even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access
a computer can be accessed remotely
using this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is the type of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a lock
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers
once the files are encrypted finding the
decryption key is impossible unless the
ransomware variant is old and the keys
are already available on the internet
scareware is fake software that claims
to have detected a virus or other issue
on your computer and directs you to pay
to resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with pop-up
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security
one must always have backups of their
data cloud storage for backup is easy
but a physical backup in a hard drive is
always recommended
keeping the system updated with the
latest security patches is always a good
idea
apart from system updates one must
always have reputed antivirus software
installed many antivirus software like
Kaspersky and bitdefender have
anti-ransomware features that
periodically check for encryption of
private documents when browsing the
internet a user must always check for
the lock Sim on the address bar which
signifies the presence of https protocol
for additional security
if a system is infected with ransomware
already there is a website
nomoreransom.org it has a collection of
decryption tools for most well-known
ransomware packages it can also help
decrypt specific encrypted files if the
list of anti-ransomware tools didn't
help the victim
so here's a question for you
what should be the first course of
action after a ransomware attack
one contact the criminal authorities
two run antivirus scan for the entire
system
three recover from local or Cloud
backups
4. isolate device from the parent
Network
think about it and leave your answers in
the comments section
three lucky winners will receive Amazon
gift vouchers ransomware attacks have
become increasingly common due to the
shift in corporate work culture from
in-office to work from home in March
2021 a chicago-based company called CNA
Financial was attacked by a ransomware
that affected nearly 75 000 users the
company was later forced to pay out 40
million dollars to get their system
access back ransomware costs businesses
more than 75 billion dollars per year
and we must take the necessary steps to
incur as minor damage as possible so
that was ransomware in a nutshell a
growing concern among Security
Professionals worldwide to understand
the key logging problem better let's
take a look at an example
this is June she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data regularly
this is Jacob from the information
Department who is here to inform her
about some of the security protocols
during the briefing she informed him
about some of the problems a system was
facing with which included slow reaction
speed and unusual internet activity
as Jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems a system was facing with
the conclusion that he came across was
the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding it
for today's topic we learn what exactly
keyloggers are and how they affect our
system what are the harmful effects that
key logging can bring into the system
for today's agenda we learn what exactly
the key logging program is
then we will see how the system gets
infected what are different methods how
the key logging issue enter into the
system
then we'll take a look at different
types of methods how to detect the key
logging issue into the system
then we'll take a look at different
types of keyloggers that are present and
how the effect differently into the
system
then we'll take a look how the hackers
use the recorded data that has been sent
by the key logging program
and then we'll take a look at a case
where the mobile devices get infected
with the key logging issue
and lastly we will take a look what are
different prevention methods available
to prevent the system from getting
infected by the key logging issue
to begin with we learn what exactly the
key logging program is
as the name suggests keylogger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record keystrokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file then the same program
secretly sends these log files to its
origin
where they can be used for malicious
acts by the hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into a system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind a key logging issue entering into
the system
and lastly there are often cases where
different pop-ups that we often see on
social sites or different media sites
can lead to the installation of key
logging program into a system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system
the data that we enter sometimes is
stuck in between when we type through
the input
then there are cases when the system
freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system
and lastly there are different cases
when we often see suspicious internet
activity on the system that we don't
know about this could lead to the
identification of a problem into the
system
now we'll take a look at different types
of key loggers that are present on the
net which can harm our system
differently
the first problem that keyloggers arouse
is API based the most common key logging
case which uses apis to keep a log of
the type data and share it to its origin
for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and locks it
then we have form grabbing based
keyloggers as the name suggests they are
a based key loggers that store the form
data that is if we often use waveforms
or different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its origin
then we have kernel based keyloggers
these key loggers are installed deeply
into the operating system where they can
hide from different antivirus if not
checked properly and they record the
data that we type on the keyboard and
send it to its origin
and lastly we have Hardware Key loggers
these key loggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
now let's take a look how hackers
differentiate different type of recorded
data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the key logging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the company
also in some cases the key logging
program can also log data about military
Secrets which may include nuclear codes
or security protocols which are
necessary to maintain the security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
key loggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use on-screen
keyboard or virtual keyboard
but in some cases we often see different
kinds of malicious programs getting
installed into the hand device if we
often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites
and also the device that is infected
with the key login issue or different
kind of malicious program can often lead
to the exploitation of data that
includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that installed a particular
malicious program into the system
now to prevent a system from getting
infected by the key locking program
let's take a look at different points
the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering or
malicious program into the system
then keeping system security protocols
regularly updated is also a good habit
and lastly using virtual keyboard to
input are sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related different
websites
now that we have some understanding
about the topic of keyloggers let's take
a look at the demo to further increase
the knowledge about the topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the system
which is
this Library
now we'll run it
the system says the library is already
installed into the system
now let's take a look what exactly
modules are required from the particular
Library
from this Library we'll import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard
now from the same we'll also import
key module
and The Listener module
and also
the logging module
which will help us to record the data
into a log file
for the next part
we'll write a piece of code that will
allow us to save the data that is
recorded by the program into our text
file that will be named as key
underscore log text file along with the
date and time stamp let's take a look
now
we'll provide it with the file name
that will be given as
key log dot txt file
and also so the part where the format of
the data is recorded
put the brackets over here
to contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given as
the format would be the message and the
timestamp which would be given as
a long way
the timestamp
giving us percentage
and ending it with the bracket
now for the next step we will Design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a look
while press function
would be a function that will come into
play when the keyboard key has been
pressed
is
right
this would go for the
format that we designed
in the above line
and
logging
the Pressed key
info
a string file
to be recorded
into the log file
now
we'll design a function that is while
release
that will come into play
when
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from running
and in the end
we require for the functioning of the
program to Loop these functions that is
while press and while release to
continuous cycle
that will be going for
while
press
and
on
release will contain while release
function
as
listener
and now
this part
would join the different threads and
store them into the log file
now that we have completed the code for
the program let's run it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
no
to verify the program let's open Notepad
and on the notepad
we'll write
hello world
which will be the basic whether the
program is working or not let's take a
look
and we will go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page
go to the bottom
over here we see the key log text that
is a text file that we created
let's open it
and over here we have the data that is
created as we started with node
then this is a Hello World part that we
created just now
which shows that the program we created
is working properly
let's take a look at some of the
detection methods for keylogger in a
system
first one is
the stocks that we make become sluggish
that is the reaction speed from the
hardware keyboard which is slower than
usual
then we have instances where our system
gets hanged or freezes in between the
work
there are also cases when there is
suspicious unusual activity in the
internet
and lastly there are some unknown
programs that are running in the
background of the system
these four are General cases where we
can observe whether the system is
infected with a key logger program or
not
to better understand key logging
activity in a system let's take a look
at the demo for the same
for the first step let's execute the key
logging program in a system
over here I am using
a python key login program
and if you want to know more about the
key logging program in Python you can
watch our previous video on what are
keyloggers
let's begin now
let's execute the program
and wait for a second or two for the
program to continue execution
okay let's take a look whether the
program is working properly
we can see that the key logging program
would create a text file named key
underscore log let's take a look
here underscore log seems like the
program is working fine
let's try typing something on the
notepad
hello world
now let's see whether the recorded data
comes
seems like the program is working fine
the data is recorded hello world
with exclamation marks
along with the time
now let's try detecting the key log of
program using different detection
methods
for the first step
you can access your settings
where you should go for Windows update
over here you would often see some of
the updates regarding security measures
that is the very basic step if you want
to detect key logging activity in your
system
let's take a look at the second
detection method for this you can use a
start option and type task manager
using the task manager app you can see
some of the programs that are displayed
these programs are the ones that are
currently working or executed in my
system right now if you see any unusual
program that has been executed without
your knowledge May refer to a keylogger
program
and if you find any unusual program that
has been executed on your system right
now you should right click on the
program and choose option and task this
will immediately end the task that is
being executed which might protect your
data from being recorded
let's take a look at the third option
how we can detect the key loggers
in the task manager use the option
startup
in the startup option represents the
softwares or programs that get executed
when the system is turned on
if you see any unusual program or
software mentioned in any of these in
your system you might have to disable
that
this represents there's an unusual
program or a malicious tool that has
been executed when you start up your
system which may relate to a key logger
problem
and the last method to detect keylogger
activity is to type something
if you feel there is some restrictions
or there's a gap between when you type
the key on your keyboard and the
reaction speed becomes slow even by a
millisecond this might represent there
is a program that is interfering with
the keyboard
if you use the following detection
methods you might save yourselves from
being spied on or getting your data
recorded that you type on your system
Jude is waiting at the airport to hop on
her flight back home when she realizes
that she missed making an important Bank
payment
she connects her laptop to the public
Wi-Fi at the airport and goes ahead to
carry out the bank transaction
everything goes well and Jude completes
her transaction
after a couple of days she was wiped off
her feet when she learned that her bank
account was subjected to a Cyber attack
and a hefty amount was wiped from her
account
after getting in touch with the bank
Authority she learned that her account
was hacked at the airport
she didn't realize that the public Wi-Fi
she used might have caused her this
trouble Jude wishes that Hatter bank
transfer escaped the Hacker's eyes she
would not have been a victim of a Cyber
attack
Bank officials advise her to use a VPN
for future transactions especially when
connecting to an open or public network
like most of us Jude had come across the
term VPN several times but didn't know
much about it and little did she think
that the repercussions of not using a
VPN would be this bad
let's understand how the hacker would
have exploited Jude's transaction in the
absence of a VPN
in this process Jude's computer first
connects to the internet service
provider ISP which provides access to
the internet
she sends her details to the bank's
server using her IP address
a protocol address or IP address is a
unique address that recognizes a
particular device be it a laptop or
smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects Jude's Bank details
without being detected
more often or not in such an attack
payment information is likely to be
stolen
the targeted data here are the victims
username passwords and other personal
information such an unsecured connection
exposed Jude's IP address and Bank
details to the hacker when it passed
through the public network
so would Judith been able to secure her
transaction with the help of a VPN well
yes
picture Jude's Bank transaction to be
happening in a tunnel that is invisible
to the hacker in such a case the hacker
will not be able to spot her transaction
and that is precisely what a VPN does
a virtual private Network more often
known as VPN creates a secure tunnel
between your device and the internet
for using a VPN Jude's First Step would
be to install software-based technology
known as the VPN client on our laptop or
smartphone that would let her establish
a secure connection the VPN client
connects to the Wi-Fi and then to the
ISP
here the VPN client encrypts Jude's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure
next the VPN client establishes a VPN
tunnel within the public network that
connects to the VPN server
the VPN tunnel protects Jude's
information from being intercepted by
the hacker
Jude's IP address and actual location
are changed at the VPN server to enable
a private and secure connection
finally the VPN server connects to
Jude's Bank server in the last step for
the encrypted message is decrypted
this way Jude's original IP address is
hidden by the VPN and the VPN tunnel
protects her data from being hacked this
explains how VPN makes your data
Anonymous and secure when it passes
through the public network and the
difference between a normal connection
and a VPN connection
after learning about this viewed was
certain that she should start using a
VPN to carry out her online transactions
in the future this is also applicable to
each one of us even if you work remotely
or connect to public Wi-Fi using a VPN
is the safest option in addition to
providing a secure encrypted data
transfer vpns are also used to disguise
your whereabouts and give you access to
Regional web content
VPN servers act as proxies on the
internet
this way your actual location cannot be
established
PN enables you to spoof your location
and switch to a server to another
country and thereby change your location
for example by doing so you can watch
any content on Netflix that might be
unavailable for your region given the
current scenario cyber attacks are on
the rise now more than ever so we have
to stay alert and protect our digital
information
if you are interested in protecting
networks and computers from cyber
criminals a cyber security career is
what you should Venture into
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become a
cyber security expert let's move on to
learning about the Tor Network
Tor short for the onion router it's an
open source privacy Network that permits
users to browse the web anonymously the
thought was initially developed and
solely used by the U.S Navy to protect
sensitive government Communications
before the network was made publicly
available
the digital era has disrupted the
traditional way of doing things in every
sector of the economy the rapid rise in
development and innovation of digital
products has given way to frequent data
breaches and cyber thefts in response
consumers are increasingly opting for
products that offer data privacy and
cyber security
Tor is one such underground Network that
was implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the torn
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security concerns
the Tor Network intercepts the traffic
from your browser and bounces a user's
request of a random number of other user
IP addresses
then the data is passed to the user
requester Final Destination
these random users are volunteer devices
which are called as nodes or relays the
Tor Network disguises your identity by
encrypting the traffic and moving it
across different Tower relays within the
network
the Tor Network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router
to operate within the Tor Network a user
has to install the Tor Browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the
Tor Network it has its own feature set
which we will be covering over later in
this video
as we discussed already the data passing
through the Tor Network must follow a
unique protocol known as The Onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique characteristics
in our normal Network usage the data is
transmitted directly the sender has data
package to transmit which is done
directly over a line of communication
with either a receiving party or a
server of some kind
however since the data can easily be
captured while being transmitted the
security of this exchange is not very
reliable moreover it becomes very easy
to trace the origin of such requests on
many occasions websites with
questionable and controversial content
are blocked from the ISP this is
possible since the ISP is able to detect
and spy on user information passing
through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the internet
however in the onion routing protocol
things take a longer route we have a
sender with the top browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node one's IP address
which encrypts the information and
passes it on to node 2's address which
performs another encryption and passes
it on to node 3 address
this is the last address which is also
known as the exit node this last node
decrypts the encrypted data and finally
release the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user
the torn Network obfuscates user IP
addresses from unwanted surveillance by
keeping the user's requests untraceable
with multiple servers touching the data
it makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious attackers
now that we understand the way Tor works
let us learn more about the Tor Browser
the top browser was developed by a
non-profit organization as a part of the
Tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced
the Tor Browser is a browser forked from
the popular Firefox that anonymizes your
web traffic using the torn network if
you are investigating a competitor
researching and opposing litigant in a
legal dispute or just think it's creepy
for your ISP or the government to know
what websites you visit the top browser
might be the right solution
before the top browser were developed
using that Network to maintain anonymity
was a huge task for everyday consumers
starting from the setup to the usage the
entire process demanded a lot of
knowledge and practice the top browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers intor and
guarantee the privacy of the data
Exchange
a major feature of the Tor Browser is
the ability to delete all browser
history cookies and tracking data the
moment it is closed every new launch of
the browser opens an empty slate having
a usage habits from being tracked and
singled out
a major feature that is the highlight of
the Tor Network is the availability of
onion links
only a small portion of the World Wide
Web is available to the general public
we have the Deep Web that contains links
that are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
Tor Browser gives you access to these
dot onion websites which are only
available within the Tor Network
onion is a special used top level domain
which designates an anonymous onion
service which is also known as a hidden
service similar to The Links of the Deep
Web these onion links provide services
like online shopping cryptocurrency and
many other products not available in the
consumer Internet space
often being considered as a Haven for
illegal activities and sales on your
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by authorities
browsing the web over Tor is slower than
the clear net due to the multiple layers
of encryption
some web services also blocked our users
Tor Browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced store as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving towards
anonymity properties
let us take a look at some of the
advantages of using the Tor Browser of a
standard web browsers
the highlight of using the Tor Browser
is to maintain anonymity over the
Internet the cause for such requests can
differ from person to person but all of
these concerns are answered by the torn
Network
routing the information via multiple
nodes and relay servers make it entirely
difficult for the ISP to keep a track of
usage data
the entire top project is designed to be
completely free and open source allowing
the code for the browser to be inspected
and audited by Third parties helps in
the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile devices
a number of websites are blocked by
governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via tor usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the Tor Browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive circumstances
many people believe that a VPN offers
the same benefits as the top browser
let's put both of them to the test and
see the differences between them
coming to the first point of difference
Tower is completely free and open source
all of the code for the browser and the
network can be audited and has been
cleared for security concerns
when it comes to VPN there are many
different brands which have open source
clients but the same cannot be said for
their counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stored in further
moving on Tor has multiple relay points
in his data transfer protocol between
the server and the receiver there are
three different IP nodes that number can
increase but it will always be more than
two
once the data is passed from the
cylinder it goes through all of those
Julia points while in the case of a VPN
the connection is made from the client
device to the VPN server and then to the
requested destination there is no other
IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a
one-to-one between the client and a VPN
as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes through
similarly the multi-layer encryption of
Tor is consistent if you use Tor Browser
every single request passes so the same
layer of encryption and follows the same
routing protocol when the case of a VPN
different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multi-hop
some prefer a single one-to-one
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more variable
finally the nodes and relays being used
in the Tor Network are volunteer there
is no company holding over them so
jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward for instance in the case
of vpns many such vpns are hosted by
adware companies or are being monitored
by Central governments to note the usage
information
now that we have a better understanding
of the Tor Browser and its routing let
us take a look at how the Tor Browser
can anonymize and protect our internet
usage
on opening up the Tor Browser for the
first time this is the page that you are
going to be welcomed with you have the
option of connecting to the Tor Network
before we start our browsing
so let's press connect
and we can see that it is connected
coming to the anonymization
let's check my current location on
Google Chrome
currently is showing as Navi Mumbai in
Maharashtra
if we check this same link on the Tor
Browser we should get a different
address
now every link that we open in the Tor
Browser will be little delayed and the
speed will be hampered because of the
multiple layers of encryption like we
discussed now as you can see
it's showing a German IP and the state
of Bavaria
this is how the anonymization works
there is no VPN configured there is no
proxy attached it's straight up the out
of the box settings that come inbuilt
with the Tor Browser
similarly we have an option of cleaning
up the data let's say if you want to
refresh your location and you want to
use a different ID for the next browsing
session if we just restart it once
and you can have to check it again
we should be seeing a different country
this time
as you can see we have Netherlands right
now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that it
cannot be tracked when it browsing the
internet
like we discussed we have some onion
links that can only be used on the Tor
Network
as you can see these kind of lanes do
not open in the Google Chrome browser
but once we copy these over to the Tor
Browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the Tor
Network
this is kind of an alternative Wikipedia
website where we can find articles to
read and more information to learn
similarly we have another onion link
over here
which is once again available only for
the tall browser
now these kind of delays are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire
similarly we have found a hidden wallet
which is a cryptocurrency wallet which
is specifically for dark web members
this operates over the Tor Network and
this is used by mostly journalists and
people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing money
all of the transactions that occur over
the torn Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available with every aspect of corporate
culture going online and embracing cloud
computing there is a plethora of
critical data circulating through the
internet all worth billions of dollars
to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack
a brute force or known as Brute Force
cracking is the Cyber attack equivalent
of trying every key on your keyring and
eventually finding the right one
Force attacks are simple and reliable
there is no prior knowledge needed about
the victim to start an attack most of
the systems falling pre-to Brute Force
attacks are actually well secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until the final
one that works
due to this repeated trial and error
format the strength of password matters
a great deal although with enough
timeline resources brute force will
break a system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is Baba from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
take a look at the topics we need to
cover today
we start by learning about what a brute
force attack is and its reliability as a
hacking technique
next we take a look at a step-by-step
approach to how the hackers can take
control of a system using Brute Force
techniques
moving on we learn about the harmful
effects of getting our personal devices
brute forced or compromised and how it
can affect not only our devices but our
friends and family as well
we also understand a few steps that we
can enforce to make a better security
system again brute first attack
specifically and finally we have a
demonstration that explains how The
Brute Force mechanism Works in a real
world situation
but before we begin make sure you
subscribed to Simply learn Channel and
click the Bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's begin with learning about Rufus
attacks in detail
a Brute Force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
Network peripheral devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be time
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data obfuscation are
used and at times downright impossible
however if the password is weak it could
merely take seconds with hardly any
effort
dictionary attacks are an alternative to
Brute Force attacks where the attacker
already has a list of usernames and
passwords that need to be stretched
against the target it doesn't need to
create any other combinations on its own
dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
there is a three-step process when it
comes to brute forcing a system let's
learn about each of them in detail
in Step 1 we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing there are some popular names on
the market like hashcat
Hydra
and John the Ripper while each of them
has its own strength and weaknesses each
of them perform well with the right
configuration all of these tools come
pre-installed with certain Linux
distributions that cater to penetration
testers and cyber security analysts like
Kali Linux and parrot security
after deciding what tool to use we can
start generating combinations of
alphanumeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six digit password will create 900 000
passwords with only digits involved
add alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially
the popular tools allow customizing this
process let's say the hacker is aware of
the password being a specific eight
digit word containing only letters and
symbols this will substantially increase
the chances of being able to guess the
right password since we remove the time
taken to generate the longer ones we
omit the need for including digits in
such combinations these small tweaks go
a long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken
we can try and break into a specific
encrypted document a social media
account or even devices at home that
connect to the internet let's say there
is a Wi-Fi router
the generated passwords are then fed
into the connection one after the other
it is a long and arduous process but the
work is left to the computer rather than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and The Brute Force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely lead to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
Brute Force Works let's see if we can
answer this question
we learned about how complex passwords
are tougher to crack by Brute Force
among the ones listed on the screens
which one do you believe will take the
longest to be broken when using Brute
Force tools leave your answers in the
comments section and we will get back to
you with the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
Brute Force attacks
a hacked laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends list
one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam
this reduces the chance of circling back
the source to single device which
belongs to the hacker once brute forced
A system can spread malware via email
attachments sharing links file upload
via FTP Etc
personal information such as credit card
data usage habits private images and
videos are all stored in our systems be
it in plane format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other things
once a system is hacked it can also be
used as a mail server that distributes
spam across lists of victims since the
Hacked machines all have different IP
addresses and Mac addresses it becomes
challenging to trace the spam back to
the original hacker
with so many harmful implications
arising from a Brute Force attack it's
imperative that the general public must
be protected against such let's learn
about some of the ways we can prevent
ourselves from becoming a victim of
Brute Force attacks
using passwords consisting of alphabets
letters and numbers have a much higher
chance of withstanding Brute Force
attacks thanks to the sheer number of
combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them
having alphanumeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or a
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the incident
two-factor authentication involves
receiving a one-time password on a
trusted device before a new login is
allowed this OTB can be obtained either
via email SMS or specific to fa
applications like authi and Aegis
email and SMS based otps are considered
relatively less secure nowadays due to
the ease with which SIM cards can be
duplicated and mailboxes can be hacked
applications that are specifically made
for 2fa Cores are much more reliable and
secure
captures are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
captcha for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent Brute Force attempts many
websites lock account for 30 minutes
after three failed password attempts to
secure the account against any such
attack and an additional note some
websites also send an email instructing
the user that there have been three
insecure attempts to log into the
website
let's look at a demonstration of how
Brute Force attacks work in a real world
situation
the world has gone Wireless with Wi-Fi
taking the reins in every household it's
natural that the security will always be
up for debate to further test the
security index and understand Brute
Force attacks we will attempt to break
into the password of a Wi-Fi router for
that to happen we first need to capture
a handshake file which is a connection
file from the Wi-Fi router to a
connecting device like a mobile or a
laptop
the operating system used for this
process is parrot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
starter demo we're going to use a tool
called air Garden which is made to hack
into wireless network specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the system
to crack into a Wi-Fi and to capture the
handshake file we're going to need an
external network card
the significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the wlx1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in manage mode right now
so we're going to select option 2 which
is to put the interface in monitor mode
and its name is now wlan0 monitor
the monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air
that is the necessary Json why we need
an external card since a lot of inbuilt
cards that come with the laptops and the
systems they cannot have a monitor mode
installed
once we select the mode we can go into
the fifth which is the handshake tools
menu
in the first step we have to explore for
targets and it is written that monitor
mode is necessary to select a Target
so let's explore for targets
and press enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network jio 24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi's this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices
this channels features on one or two or
there are some many channels that the
networks can focus on
this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example
the station that you can see 5626 this
is supposed to be the macro test of the
device that is connected to a router
this basis ID is supposed to be which
wi-fi it is connected to for example 58
95 d8
is this one which is the jio 24 router
so we already know which router has a
device connected to it and we can use
our attack to capture this handshake
now that we it has already ran for one
minute now that we press Ctrl C
we will be asked to select a Target see
it has already selected the number five
which is the jio 24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake for
select Network 5
and we run a capture handshake
it says we have a valid WPA WPA2 Network
Target selected and that the script can
continue
now to capture the handshake we have a
couple of attacks a Dior air replay
attack what this attack does is click
the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the handshake
for our demo let's go with the second
option that is the Dior air replay
attack
select a timeout value let's say we give
it 60 Seconds
and we start the script
you can see it capturing data from the
jio 24 Network and here we go
we have the WPA handshake files
once the handshake file is captured you
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a peak MK
ID from the target network has
successfully been captured this is the
file that is already stored the dot cap
file for the path we can let's say we
can keep it in a desktop
okay we give the path
and the handshape file is generated
we can already see
a Target over here same jio 24 router
with the BSS ID
now if we return to its main menu
we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key
so let's go to the offline WPA WP to
decrypt menu
since you'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option one
now to run the Brute Force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
air crack or we can go the hashcad
let's go with aircac plus crunch which
is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option two
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated
so we select yes
the bssid is the one which denotes the
jio 24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA to psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10. and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as 20.
the character set that we are going to
use for checking the password
will affect the time taken to Brute
Force for example if we already know
that or we have seen a user use the
password while connecting to the router
as something that has only numbers and
symbols then we can choose accordingly
let's say if we go with only uppercase
characters and numeric characters
go with option seven
and it's going to start decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this passphrase over here
the first five or six digits are a it
starts working its way from the end from
the last character it keeps trying every
single combination you can see the last
the fourth character from the right side
the D it will eventually turn to E
because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end
this will keep going on until all the
single characters are tested and every
single combination is tried out
since the handshake file is encrypted
using the security key that is the WPA
Tookie of the router whichever
passphrase is able to decrypt the
handshake key completely will be the key
of the Wi-Fi router this is the way we
can Brute Force into Wi-Fi routers
anywhere in the world apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a
DDOS attack
these DDOS attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to botnet farms and compromise devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020
lately cyber criminals have been
actively seeking out new services and
protocols for amplifying these DDOS
attacks active involvement with hacked
machines and botners allow further
penetration into the consumer space
allowing much more elaborate attack
campaigns apart from General users
multinational corporations have also had
their fair share of problems
GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DDOS
attack in 2018. widely suspected to be
conducted by Chinese authorities this
attack went on for about 20 minutes
after which the systems were brought
into a stable condition it was the
strongest leaders attack to date at the
time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks even after years of
experimentation DDOS attacks are still
at large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space
hey everyone this is Baba from Simply
learn and welcome to this video on what
is a DDOS attack let's take a look at
the topics we will be covering today
we start by learning what is the DDOS
attack and how it works on a phase by
phase level
we learn about the distinct categories
in DDOS attacks and the potential aim of
hackers when the launch Adidas attack
campaign
we also look at some preventive measures
that can be taken to protect oneself
from these DDOS attacks finally we have
a demonstration of how such attacks can
hamper the working of a server system
using VMware and parrot security
operating system
but before moving forward make sure you
are subscribed to the simple learn
YouTube channel don't forget to hit the
Bell icon to receive updates about more
informative videos from our channel so
let's learn more about what is a DDOS
attack
a distributed denial of service attack
or DDOS is when an attacker or attackers
attempt to make it impossible for a
service to be delivered
this can be achieved by thwarting access
to virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications
in a Dos attack it's one system that is
sending the malicious data or requests a
detours attack comes from multiple
systems
generally these attacks work by Drowning
a system with requests for data this
could be sending a web server so many
requests to serve a page that it crashes
under the demand or it could be a
database being hit with a higher volume
of queries the result is available
internet bandwidth CPU and RAM capacity
become overwhelmed
the impact could range from a minor
annoyance from disrupted services to
experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center
the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DDOS
campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how DDOS attack work
Adidas attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
botnet of devices
simply put a vast network of computers
are hacked via malware ransomware or
just simple social engineering
these devices become a part of the
botnet which can be triggered anytime to
start bombarding a system or a server on
the instruction of the hacker that
created the botnet
the devices in this networks are called
Bots or zombies
in the second phase a particular Target
is selected for the attack
when the hacker finds the right time to
attack all the zombies in the botnet
network send these requests the target
thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth
these can be simple ping requests or
complex attacks like SYM flooding and
UDP flooding the aim is to overwhelm
them with more traffic than the server
or the network can accommodate the goal
is to render the website or service
inoperable
there is a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to the type of DDOS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DDOS
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks
the size of volume based attack is
measured in bits per second
these attacks focus on clogging all the
available bandwidth for the server
thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warranty reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate users
next we have the protocol level attacks
these attacks are meant to consume
essential resources of the target server
they exhaust the load balances and
firewalls which are meant to protect the
system against the DDOS attacks
these protocol attacks include syn
floods and Smurf DDOS among others and
the size is measured in packets per
second
for example in an SSL handshake server
replies to the Hello message sent by the
hacker which will be the client in this
case but since the IP is poofed and
leads nowhere the server gets stuck in
an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgment without any end in sight
finally we have the application Level
attacks application layer attacks are
conducted by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests the size of
application layer attacks is measured in
requests per second
these are relatively sophisticated
attacks that Target the application and
operating system level vulnerabilities
they prevent the specific applications
from delivering necessary information to
users and Hawk the network bandwidth up
to the point of a system crash
examples of such an attack are HTTP
flooding and bgp hijacking a single
device can request data from a server
using HTTP post or get without any
issues
however when the requisite botnet is
instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and unusable
but what about the reasons for such an
attack there are multiple lines of
thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a DDOS attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them
the first option is to gain a
competitive advantage
many DDOS attacks are conducted by
hacking communities against rival groups
some organizations hire such communities
to stagger their Rivals resources at a
network level to gain an advantage in
the playing field
since being a victim of a detours attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some ground
secondly some hackers launch these DDOS
attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom
the resources are jammed and the only
way to clear the way is if the target
company agrees to pay a designated
amount of money to the hackers even a
few minutes of inactivity is detrimental
to a company's reputation in the global
market and it can cause a spiral effect
both in terms of market value and
product security index most of the time
a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a while
titos attacks have also found use in the
political segment certain activists tend
to use redos attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
forum primarily political these attacks
also focus on online communities ethical
dilemmas or even protests against
corporations
let's take a look at a few ways that
companies and individuals can protect
themselves against redos attacks
the company can employ load balancers
and firewalls to help protect the data
from such attacks load balances reroute
the traffic from one server to another
in a DDOS attack this reduces the single
point of failure and adds resiliency to
the server data
a firewall blocks unwanted traffic
indoor system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect adidos attack in action
early detection of Adidas attack goes a
long way in recovering the data lost in
such an event
once you've detected the attack you will
have to find a way to respond for
example you will have to work on
dropping the malicious DDOS traffic
before it teaches your server so that it
doesn't throttle and exhaust your
bandwidth here's where you will filter
the traffic so that only legitimate
traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by a cluster
resources
the most important stage in DDOS
mitigation is where you will look for
patterns of readers attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first step
Cloud providers like Amazon web services
and Microsoft Azure who offer high
levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DDOS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandwidth than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased tdos
attacks
additionally reputable Cloud providers
are for Network redundancy duplicating
copies of your data systems and
equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DDOS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a Beat
one can also increase the amount of
bandwidth available to a host server
being targeted since tdos attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection
this solution can prove expensive as a
lot of that bandwidth is going to go
unused most of the time
a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boosts
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates DDOS attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular cdns include echo
my CDN cloudflare AWS cloudfront Etc
let's start with a demo regarding the
effects of DDOS attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a dose
attack of sorts
once a botnet is ready multiple devices
can do the same and eventually emulate a
DDOS attack
to do so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parrot security operating system
running
for a Target machine we will be running
another VMware instance of a standard
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use Wireshark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly
this is Linux like which is a target
machine and this is parrot security
which is used by the hacker when trying
to launch a DDOS attack this is just one
of the distros that can be used
to launch the attack we must first find
the IP address of our Target
so to find the IP address we open the
terminal
we use the command ifconfig
and here we can find the IP address
now remember we're launching this attack
in VMware now the both the instances of
parrot security and Linux light are
being run on my local network so the
address that you can see here is
192.168.72.129 which is a private
address this IP cannot be accessed from
outside the network basically anyone who
is not connected to my Wi-Fi
when launching attacks with public
servers or public addresses it will have
a public IP address that does not belong
to the 192.168 subnet
once we have the IP address
we can use a tool called
hp3
hp3 is an open source packet generator
and analyzer for the TCP protocol
to check what are the effects of an
attack we will be using Wireshark
Wireshark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux light distro
is being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to
once we have the Dos attack launched you
can see the results coming over here
from The Source IP which will be parrot
security Now to launch the hp3 command
we need to give sudo access to the
console which is the root access
now we have the root access for the
console
the hping 3 command will have a few
arguments to go with it which are as you
can see on the screen
minus s and a flood
a hyphen V
hyphen p18 and the IP address of the
target which is 192.168.72.129
in this command we have a few arguments
this such as the minus s which specifies
syn packets like in an SSL handshake we
have the syn request that the client
sends to the server to initiate a
connection
The Hyphen flood aims to ignore the
replies that the server will send back
to the client in response to the syn
packets here the parent security OS is
the client and Linux slide being the
server
minus v stands for verbosity as in where
we will see some output when the
requests are being sent
The Hyphen p80 stands for Port 80 which
we can replace the port number if we
want to attack a different port
and finally we have the IP address of
our Target
as of right now if we check Wireshark it
is relatively clear and there is no
indication of a DDOS attack incoming now
once we launch the attack over here
we can see the requests coming in from
this IP which is
192.168 72.128
till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux light
the requests keep on coming and we can
see the http
flooding has started in flood mode
after a few seconds of this attack
continuing
the server will start shutting down
now remember Linux light is a distro
that can focus on that serves as a
backend
now remember Linux light is a distro and
such Linux distros are served as backend
to many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack
now the system has become completely
irresponsive this has happened due to
the huge number of requests that came
from Pilot security
you can see whatever I press nothing is
responded even the Wireshark has stopped
capturing new requests because the CPU
usage right now is completely 100 and at
this point of time anyone who is trying
to request some information from this
Linux distro or where this Linux distro
is being used as a backend for a server
or a database cannot access anything
else the system has completely stopped
responding and any request any
legitimate request from legitimate users
will be dropped
once you stop the attack over here it
takes a bit of time to settle down now
remember it's still out of control but
eventually the traffic dies down and the
system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into
that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
Adidas attack comes into play what we
did right now is a Dos attack as in a
single system is being used to penetrate
a Target server using a single request
now when a DDOS attack multiple systems
such as multiple pirate security
instances or multiple zombies or bots in
a botnet network can attack a Target
server to completely shut down the
machine and drop any legitimate request
thereby rendering the service and the
target completely unusable and
inoperable
as a final note we would like to remind
that this is for educational purposes
only and we do not endorse any attacks
on any proven domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on the important
question is how to become a certified
ethical hacker in order to become a
certified ethical hacker you need to
pass the certified ethical hacker or the
ceh exam from EC Council which tests the
broad knowledge of subject matter that
is required for someone to Be an
Effective ethical hacker well since its
Inception in 2003 the certified ethical
hacker has been the absolute choice of
the industry globally it is recognized
worldwide and has been endorsed by
governmental agencies like the NSA the
CH exam is also is accredited by NC
which adds credibility and value to the
credential members the Cs exam is
computerized proctored exam you will
have four hours to complete 125
questions there are some sources of
information that mentions that in order
to pass you need to score about 60 to 80
percent the actual percentage of
questions that you must answer correctly
varies from exempt exam and depends on
the difficulty of the exams delivered
when you take the exam the harder the
questions that are asked the fewer
questions you need to get right to pass
the exam if you get easier questions
then you will need to get more of the
questions right to pass the exam however
keep in mind that when you take the
actual exam at the testing center the
passing grade may vary the CH
certification exam costs 500 plus an
additional eligibility fee of hundred
dollars the exam duration is for four
hours the questions are all multiple
choice the exam is only available in
English as of today candidates can take
the CES exam online using a remotely
proctored service from anywhere in the
world 24 7 as long as they have a
computer equipped with a webcam and a
microphone let's just discuss the exam
outline the exam is broken into seven
domains networking and information
background covers about 32 percent
analysis assessment covers 12 percent
security covers 23 percent tools system
programs 29 procedures methodology nine
percent regulation policy 2 percent and
ethics three percent let's discuss these
domains a little more in detail
networking and information background
this first domain of the ceh exam is
designed to test your knowledge of
everything that you need to know to
practice ethical hacking which isn't
specific to any information security
domain the objectives of this domain
include Network and communication
Technologies next is information
security threats and attack Vector such
as malware's OAS top 10 Etc the final
object active covers information
security Technologies such as mobile
technologies telecommunication
Technologies backups archiving
Etc analysis assessment this domain of
the certified ethical hacker exam is
designed to test your knowledge of what
goes into performing a penetration test
or ethical hacking the objectives of
this domain are information security
assessment and Analysis and information
security assessment process combination
of ethics and regulation policy domains
covers five percent of the total exam
weightage the objectives of this domains
are ethics of information security which
covers what is considered ethical and
unethical from the perspective of the
ceh certification not only you will be
expected to behave ethically you will be
expected to adhere to a code of ethics
next objective is information security
policies laws ax which covers some of
the major information security
regulations and the evaluation of
organizational security policies this is
an important procedures methodology this
is an important domain and carries a
weightage of nine percent there are two
objectives the first objective covers
information security procedures which is
the step-by-step methods that is used to
identify prevent and enforce security
controls against unwanted Behavior the
next objective is information security
assessment methodologies which covers
security assessments to determine
security gaps that may pose a risk to
the organization tools systems programs
this domain carries the maximum
weightage of 29 percent and so you
should expect the maximum number of
questions from here this domain is
heavily focused on knowledge of the
specific systems programs and tools you
use in ethical hacking there are three
objectives first objective covers
information security systems such as
firewalls intrusion detection and
prevention systems Siem Solutions
Etc next objective covers information
security programs that are used to
secure a host system against malicious
attackers these programs include
antivirus anti-spyware anti-riskware ad
blockers anti-root kit Etc the final
objective covers information security
tools used for performing footprinting
and reconnaissance performing
enumeration conducting Network scanning
performing web application hacking Etc
this security domain is the second
largest domain on the exam with 23
percent weightage this domain is divided
into three objectives the first
objective covers information security
controls such as administrative controls
Tech technical controls and physical
controls the second objective
information security attack detection
covers various methods to detect attacks
against an organization's information
security the final objective information
security attack prevention covers
proactive methods that organizations can
use to protect themselves from malicious
attackers from malicious attacks let us
understand the importance of the CH
certification before getting to know
about its content
so why should you take up the CH version
11 the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification and a recommended one by
employers around the globe
since the introduction of the C8
certification in 2003 it is globally
recognized as a standard within the
information security field the CH
version 11 by EC Council continues to
keep up to the standard and it
familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you Advanced
hacking tools and exploits used the CH
version 11 aligns with the current cyber
security Market requirements and adds
the latest advancements in the cyber
security field
the CH certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker and this in
turn helps you beat a hacker and defend
your network after obtaining the ca
certification you'll be a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a skilled professional working
in a red team environment who safeguards
networks and understands attack
strategies and mimics the skills of
malicious hackers certified ethical
hackers discover vulnerabilities in a
system and operate with permission from
the system owners only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the ca
certification let us have a look at that
now
in the first case to be eligible for the
CH certification exam you need to attend
the official training from authorized
easy Council training Partners it can be
an online training or tutor let training
from Easy Council learning Partners only
then are you eligible to take up the Cs
certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official easy Council training is
eligible to take up the exam without
going through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential you need
to have at least two years of work
experience in the information security
domain and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee and submit an
eligibility application form once it is
approved you can take up the CH exam
after the application is approved you
can purchase the test voucher
in the latest version of the CH we will
see the addition of various Core
Concepts moving on to our next topic let
us see how different the CH version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
Concepts cyber kill chain Concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security the certification
briefs you about the faces of system
hacking attacking techniques and how you
can maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
Concepts and ways of utilizing
footprinting tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment along with
a hands-on experience of various
scanning tools
next we have cyber security threats like
malware threats analysis of various
worms viruses and Trojans various
malware Concepts package sniffing
Concepts and techniques have been
introduced into this domain it also
highlights the concepts related to
social engineering denial of service
attacks SQL injection and Aviation
techniques it also speaks about Wireless
hacking Concepts and mobile device
management the concept of operational
technology is a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with Security
Solutions like firewalls honey ports IPS
derivation and protection
our fifth point is knowing various
topics in cryptography like encryption
algorithms public key infrastructure and
cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate parrot security OS as it
offers better performance on Lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to Kali Linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot-based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the CH version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving Cloud industry you would need
to learn how to identify and defend
cloud-based threats and attacks
the latest version of CH includes new
operating systems and Windows 10
configured with domain controller and
vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the CH version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges via easy Council Labs
easy Council leads in this aspect of the
industry now that we saw the CH exam
objectives let us look into the CH exam
topics weightage
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with nine domains in ch along with
their weightages you can prepare for
your exam accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking overview
this domain consists of questions from
information security cyber kill chain
Concepts ethical hacking Concepts
various hacking Concepts and information
security laws and standards
you can expect a total number of eight
questions from this domain the weightage
of this section is six percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance at first
this covers various topics like
footprinting Concepts footprinting
methodology email footprinting
footprinting through web services DNS
footprinting footprinting through social
engineering Etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks scanning networks
covers various Concepts like scanning
tools host Discovery port and service
Discovery OS Discovery draw Network
diagrams scanning Beyond IDs firewall
Etc
and our third subdomain under
reconnaissance techniques is enumeration
various topics like SNMP enumeration ntp
and NFS enumeration SMTP and DNS
enumeration and enumeration
countermeasures are covered under this
subdomain a total of 26 questions will
be asked from this domain under
footprinting and reconnaissance you will
have 10 questions and under scanning
networks and other 10 and finally under
enumeration you'll have six questions a
total weightage of 21 is given to this
particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques under a third
domain our first sub-domain is about
vulnerability analysis this subdomain
covers topics on vulnerability
assessment vulnerability classification
vulnerability assessment Solutions and
tools and various vulnerability
assessment reports our next subdomain is
about system hacking you have Concepts
like gaining access cracking passwords
vulnerability exploitation escalating
privileges maintaining access covered
under this subdomain and finally we have
malware threads under this domain
malware threads incorporate Concepts
like apt Concepts Trojan Concepts virus
and worm Concepts malware analysis and
so on a total of 21 Questions will be
asked from this domain under
vulnerability analysis there will be
nine questions asked system hacking and
other six questions and finally under
malware threats you will have six other
questions asked
that sums up to a total 21 with a
weightage of 17 for this domain
our fourth domain is about Network and
perimeter hacking
here you have various subdomains and one
of it is social engineering under social
engineering you will be asked questions
based on social engineering techniques
Insider threats impersonation on social
networking sites identity theft and so
on it you'll also have various question
on the sniffing Concepts as it is
another subdomain you can also expect
questions from the denial of service
subdomain here questions related to
botnets and DDOS attacks will be asked
various session hijacking concepts are
another crucial part of this domain
the final subdomain is about evading IDs
firewalls and honey pots
here various Concepts on IDs IPS
firewall and honeypots are covered you
will need to understand how to evade
ideas and firewalls and how to detect
honeypots
a total number of 18 questions will be
asked from the fourth domain that is
network and perimeter hacking and the
weightage for this domain is 14 percent
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and a first
sub-domain in it is hacking web servers
this incorporates concepts related to
web server attacks web server attack
tools patch management and so on the
next subdomain is about hacking web
applications here you have various
concepts related to bypass client-side
controls analyze web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls and how to perform
injection attacks and so on
finally under the SQL injection
subdomain you'll have questions based on
SQL injection the types of SQL injection
the SQL injection methodology SQL
injection tools Aviation techniques and
SQL injection countermeasures
here a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain and that is a
weightage of 16 will be given to the web
application hacking domain our sixth
domain is solely devoted to wireless
network hacking this domain focuses on
hacking wireless networks various
Wireless Concepts wireless encryption
Wireless threats Wireless hacking tools
various hacking methodologies Bluetooth
hacking and wireless countermeasures are
covered a total of eight questions will
be asked from this domain with a
weightage of six percent our seventh
domain is all about mobile platform iot
and OT hacking our first subdomain here
is hacking mobile platforms here the
concepts that are touched upon our
mobile platform attack vectors hacking
Android OS hacking iOS mobile device
management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next sub domain here is about iot
and OT hacking which covers Concepts on
iot hacking tools its methodologies
countermeasures and it also speaks about
OT Concepts OT attacks OT hacking tools
and OT countermeasures you have a total
of 10 questions asked from this domain
with a weightage of eight percent the
next domain is very interesting and it
is all related to Cloud the cloud
computing domain covers Concepts based
on cloud computing serverless Computing
cloud computing threats Cloud hacking
and Cloud security the weightage given
to this domain is six percent with the
total number of questions of seven and
finally we have cryptography as our
ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography Concepts
encryption algorithms cryptography tools
public key infrastructure Email
encryption disk encryption cryptanalysis
and countermeasures
and seven questions will be asked from
this domain with a weightage of six
percent now that you saw the CH exam
topics weightage let us have a closer
look at the CH exam details let us first
have a look at the CH exam based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of 312-50 this
exam will have 125 questions with a time
limit of 4 hours the test format is
multiple choice questions the past
percentage varies ideally between 60 to
85 percent now let's have a look at the
CH practical exam details in order to
gain the CH Master recognition it is
mandatory that you take up the CH
practical exam as well the exam title is
certified ethical hacker practical and
this practical exam will have 20
questions with a duration of 6 hours
the exam format will be iLab cyber range
and finally the passing score for the CH
practical exam is at 70 percent after
clearing both the McQ based exam and the
Practical exam you can get the CH Master
recognition now that we had a look at
the CH exam details let us have a look
at the career prospects for a
professional with this certification
let's look at the critical skills you
need to become a certified ethical
hacker
first is coding
ethical hackers should have an excellent
grasp of the various programming
languages and understand the coding
techniques to gain access to any
software it will help you understand the
tools hackers develop to infiltrate a
security system
some of the popular coding languages
ethical hackers need to know are python
JavaScript PHP and SQL
coming to the second skill
so ethical hackers should know the
basics of different operating systems
specifically Linux as it is more secure
than any other operating system
most web servers run on Linux operating
system gaining access to the server to
check for false is another must-have
skill for ethical hackers
now they also need to understand how
firewalls work as well
coming to the third skill so to become
an ethical hacker you must understand
both wired and wireless networks they
must know networks like DHCP n80 and
subnetting to investigate the different
interconnected machines in a network and
the possible security threats that this
may create now moving on to the fourth
skill
having good knowledge of Wireless
Technologies like wired equivalent
privacy or WEP Wi-Fi protected access or
WPA and Wi-Fi protected setup or WPS
will help ethical hackers who guard
systems against sending information via
hidden streams ethical hackers need to
grasp how to write SQL statements for
in-band out of band and blind SQL
attacks which can swiftly compromise a
database operation and the detail tools
cryptography deals with transforming a
normal text message to a non-readable
form during the transmission to make it
incomprehensible for hackers
an ethical hacker ensures that
conversation between different people
within the organization does not leak
now coming to the final skill
ethical hackers additionally require
analytical thinking and problem solving
skills to succeed at this job
they should be able to reverse engineer
security Frameworks come up with
uncommon ways to break into a network
this also requires thinking outside the
box
now companies across various Industries
hire ethical hackers for several job
roles so once you become a certified
ethical hacker you can get into multiple
job roles let's look at a few of them
first we have security analyst
the security analysts execute security
systems to safeguard the organization's
networks data and also help to maintain
security standards
they document the security breaches and
measure the damage cost security
analysts also analyze the security
issues thoroughly to identify the root
cause
the second job role we have is
penetration tester
so penetration testers conduct tests and
purposefully try to exploit existing
computer systems and software to
identify and correct system weaknesses
they Implement solutions to enhance data
security and provide recommendations
based on an assessment of hardware and
software systems
the third job role we have for a
certified ethical hacker is security
engineer
so security Engineers understand
complicated technical issues and manage
them with a fast-paced business
environment
they also conduct proactive research to
investigate security vulnerabilities and
recommend suitable strategies
and finally we have the job role of a
security consultant
cyber Security Consultants are highly in
demand today and are amongst the heavily
paid professionals a cyber security
consultant is responsible for protecting
sensitive data that come from various
aspects of the digital world the evade
security risk and prevents cyber attacks
Security Consultants study security
criteria or cyber security criteria
security systems and validation
procedures
now before we go further I have another
question for you people so which role do
you think is the most exciting do let us
know your responses in the comments
section of the video we would be glad to
hear from you now moving ahead
with the increasing number of cyber
attacks across the globe ethical hackers
are in demand like never before
very recently a United Nation official
warned that cyber crime went up by 600
percent during the covid-19 pandemic
as per the government data presented in
Parliament India alone reported 1.16
million cyber attacks in 2020.
that's almost 3x times more than 2019.
now according to cyber security Ventures
cyber threats will cost nearly 6
trillion US dollars in 2021. cyber
security Ventures also expects Global
cyber crime costs will grow up by 15
percent per year over the next five
years and reach 10.5 trillion US dollars
annually by 2025.
now there is a huge shortage of ethical
hacking professionals globally according
to the Bureau of Labor Statistics the
information security industry is
expected to grow 32 percent in the next
decade
another report by cyber security
Ventures tells that the world will have
3.5 million unfilled cyber security jobs
by the end of 2021.
according to a report by the data
security Council of India the Indian
cyber security services industry is
expected to grow to about 7.6 billion
dollars in 2022 and would be worth 13.6
billion dollars by 2025. so companies
are looking for trained ethical hackers
who can protect their networks and
Safeguard them from potential threats a
few of the industries that heavily rely
on ethical hackers are healthcare
companies financial institutions energy
companies and government agencies
with ample opportunities lying ahead
what's stopping you from starting a
career in cyber security and before we
begin with the course if you are someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security by graduating from the
best universities then try giving a show
to Simply learn's post-graduate program
in cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered so we'll start with the
first question that is what is CRF or
you can say the into us can you explain
what csrf in the context of cyber
security and we can answer that
certainly csrf stands for Crow site
request forgery it is a type victim is
authenticated the attack takes advantage
of the trust a website has in the
authenticated users browser now we'll
see how it works so security
vulnerability that occurs when an
attacker tricks a victim into performing
an unwanted action on a web website or
web application in which the attacker
creates a malicious website or injects
malicious code into a legitimate website
that the victim visits and when the
victim visits the attacker's website or
the compromised legitimate website the
malicious code can execute without the
victim's knowledge the malicious Court
sends a request to the targeted website
or application on behalf of the victim
this request may include sensitive
actions like changing the victim's
password making Financial transactions
or modifying personal information since
the request originates from the victim's
browser the targeted website or
application considers it legitimate and
processes the request the victim's
account is compromised and the attacker
gains unauthorized access or performs
unwanted actions to protect against csrf
attacks web developers can Implement
several countermeasures including using
anti-cis RF tokens using anti-csrf
tokens web applications can generate and
include unique tokens in each form or
request these tokens are verified by the
server before processing the action
ensuring that the request originated
from the same website the next is same
side cookies attribute web developers
can set the same site attribute on
cookies which prevents them from being
sent with close site request thus
reducing the risk of csrf attacks
verifying the origin header servers can
check the origin header to ensure the
request originate from the same domain
the next is implementing strict Access
Control web applications should enforce
strict access controls and authorization
mechanisms to ensure that only
authorized actions can be performed and
the next measure can be by implementing
these countermeasures organizations can
significantly reduce the risk of csrf
attacks and protect their users
sensitive information and account and
the next question is that is the most
important question which interviewer
asks that is difference between xss and
csrf so access that is xss Crow site
scripting and CSR RF close site request
forgery are both common web application
vulnerabilities but they differ in their
nature and the risk they pose so access
is a vulnerability that occurs when an
attacker injects malicious scripts into
a trusted website which is then executed
by the user's browser this can happen
when the website does not properly
validate or sanitize use an input the
injected scripts can be used to steal
sensitive information such as login
credentials or session cookies and can
also be used to modify the content of
the website or redirect users to
malicious websites csrf on the other
hand is a type of attack where an
attacker picks a user's browser into
making unattended or unauthorized
request to a website this attack relies
on the fact that many website use
cookies or other mechanisms for session
management and these cookies are
automatically sent with every request
made to the website by tricking a user
into visiting a specially crafted
website or clicking on a malicious link
the attacker can perform action on
behalf of the user without their
knowledge or consent potentially leading
to unauthorized actions data
manipulation or account compromise in
summary xss is concerned with injecting
and executing malicious scripts within a
website while csrf involves tricking
users into performing unintended actions
on a trusted website both
vulnerabilities can have serious
consequences and it is important for web
developers to understand and mitigate
these risks through proper input
validation output encoding and security
mechanisms such as csrf tokens and
secure session management now moving to
next question is xss client-side attack
or server side attack so xss that is
cross-site scripting attack can occur on
the client side which means it targets
vulnerabilities in the user's web
browser or the client application this
type of attack takes advantage of
security weaknesses in the client-side
code allowing an attacker to inject
malicious scripts into a trusted website
or web application once the script is
executed by the user's browser it can
lead to unauthorized actions data theft
or other malicious activities and it's
important to note that while accessor
attacks primarily Target the client side
they can have significant consequences
on the server side as well the injected
script May interact with the server or
exploit vulnerabilities in the server
side code to perform actions on behalf
of the attacker therefore xss attacks
can have an impact on both the client
and server components of a web
application security and the next
question is what is ioc in cyber
security iuc stands for indicators of
compromise these are pieces of evidence
or artifacts that suggest the presence
of malicious activity or a security
breach within a system or network iucs
are used to identify detect and respond
to potential security incidents there
are several types of iocs that Security
Professionals look for the most common
types include file based iocs these
include malicious files such as malware
executables scripts or documents that
have been identified as part of a Cyber
attack file based iocs can be identified
through file hashes file names or
specific file content the next is
network based iucs these indicators
relate to network traffic associated
with malicious activities they can
include suspicious IP addresses domain
names URLs or patterns of network
communications that indicate a potential
security threat the next we have is
behavioral ioses these indicators are
based on abnormal behavior exhibited by
users systems or applications for
example a sudden increase in failed
login attempts unusual file access
patterns or unauthorized system
modifications can serve as behavioral
iocs the next is registry or system
configuration iucs these indicators
involve changes or additions to the
Windows registry system configuration
files for other system settings
attackers May alter these configurations
to gain assistance on a compromise
system the next is threat intelligence
iocs these iocs are derived from
external sources such as cyber security
vendors government agencies or threat
intelligence platforms they provide
information about non malicious actors
their tactics techniques and procedures
and specific indicators associated with
their activities when organizations
collect and analyze iosis they can
proactively detect and respond to
security incidents by monitoring for
these indicators security teams can
identify potential threats investigate
the scope of an attack and take
appropriate measures to mitigate the
risk it's worth noting that iocs are not
static and continuously evolve as
attackers develop new techniques
therefore staying up to date with the
latest threat intelligence and sharing
information within the cyber security
Community is crucial for Effective
defense against cyber threats and now
moving to another question that is fifth
question and it is that can you explain
the difference between antivirus and ADR
in cyber security so antivirus and
endpoint detection and response that is
EDR are both important components in
cyber security but they serve different
purposes we'll see them that is first
antivirus that is also known as
anti-malware software it is designed to
detect prevent and remove known types of
malicious software such as viruses bombs
Trojans and iron severe it relies on
signature based detection where it
compares the code patterns or files or
programs against a database of known
malware signatures when a match is found
the antivirus software takes appropriate
action to quarantine or delete the
infected file on the other hand the EDR
goes beyond traditional antivirus
solutions by providing real-time
monitoring detection and response
capabilities at the endpoint level EDS
Solutions are designed to detect and
respond to sophisticated and advanced
threads that may evade traditional
antivirus software they use a
combination of techniques including
behavioral analysis machine learning and
threat intelligence to identify
malicious activities and potential
threats ADR Solutions continuously
monitor endpoints such as workstations
servers and mobile devices for any
suspicious activities or anomalous
Behavior they collect and analyze vast
amounts of endpoint data including
process executions network connections
file changes and system configurations
to identify potential security incidents
if a threat is detected EDS Solutions
provide detailed visibility into the
incident allowing security teams to
investigate contain and respond to the
threat in real time while antivirus
focuses on known threats and relies on
signature based detection EDS Solutions
are more proactive and capable of
identifying previously unseen for zero
day threats they offer enhanced threat
hunting capabilities allowing security
analysts to search for indicators of
compromise that is iocs and identify
potential vulnerability or security gaps
in the environment in summary antivirus
is an essential component in protecting
against known malware while EDR provides
Advanced threat detection real-time
monitoring and incident response
capabilities to defend against
sophisticated and emerging threats
combining both antivirus and EDS
Solutions can significantly enhance an
organization's overall cyber security
posture now moving to another question
that is IPS vs firewall that is can you
explain the difference between IPS and a
fireball in cyber security so an IPS
that is intrusion prevention system and
a firewall are too distinct but
complementary security mechanisms let's
see the differences between them so
firewall acts as a barrier between an
internal Network and external network
typically the internet it examines
incoming and outgoing Network traffic
based on predefined rules or policies
its primary function is to enforce
access controls and permit or deny
Network traffic based on factors such as
IP addresses ports protocols and
application types firewalls work at the
network layer layer 3 or the transport
layer layer 4 of the network stack on
the other hand an IPS is designed to
detect and prevent network based attacks
it goes beyond the basic Access Control
functions of a firewall an IPS monitors
Network traffic in real time searching
for signs of non-attack patterns for
suspicious Behavior it can detect and
block unauthorized access attempts
manual Network intrusions and other
malicious activities IPS systems are
typically placed in line with network
traffic and can operate at the NATO
clear that is layer 3 transport layer
layer 4 or even the application layer
that is layer 7 to summarize a firewall
acts as a gatekeeper controlling the
flow of traffic into and out of a
network based on predefined rules it
focuses on access control on the other
hand nips is a more advanced security
mechanism that actively inspects Network
traffic identifies potential threats or
attacks and takes action to prevent them
it focuses on detecting and preventing
intrusions in practice organizations
often use both firewalls and IPS systems
together to provide layered security
firewalls protect against unauthorized
access and filter out unwanted traffic
while IPS systems add an additional
layer of protection by actively
monitoring and blocking malicious
activities so this was all for firewall
and IPS now moving to what is security
misconfiguration so security
misconfiguration refers to the improper
or insecure configuration of systems
software applications or network
components that can lead to potential
security vulnerabilities it occurs when
security settings permissions or
configurations are not appropriately
defined or implemented leaving systems
and data exposed to potential attacks or
unauthorized access security
misconfiguration can take various forms
such as using default or weak passwords
leaving unnecessary services or ports
open not applying necessary security
patches or updates means configuring
access controls or polling to implement
secure communication protocols these
misconfigurations can provide attackers
with entry points into a system allowing
them to exploit vulnerabilities gain
unauthorized access or carry out
malicious activities organizations often
face security misconfigurations due to
human error lack of awareness or
inadequate security practices it's
crucial to regularly review and audit
system configurations approach secure
defaults disable unnecessary features
Polo security best practices and stay
updated with the latest patches and
updates by addressing security
misconfigurations organizations can
significantly reduce their attack
surface and enhance the oral security
posture of their systems and networks so
moving on to next question that is what
is Waf and its types so WF stands for
web application firewall it is a
security measure used to protect web
applications from various types of cyber
attacks a Waf acts as a filter between
the web application and the external
network monitoring and analyzing
incoming and outgoing web traffic there
are primarily two types of wfs commonly
used in cyber security that are network
page WF this type of WF is implemented
at the network parameter typically as a
dedicated Hardware Appliance or a
virtual Appliance it intercepts web
traffic before it reaches the web
application server and network based wfs
examine packets at the network layer
inspecting IP addresses ports and
protocols to detect and prevent
malicious activities they are effective
in protecting multiple web applications
hosted on the same network
infrastructure and the next is host
paste WF this type of WF is installed
directly on the web application server
or within the application itself it
operates at the application layer and
has a deep understanding of the
application structure and logic host
based wafs Monitor and analyze HTTP
https traffic inspecting the content of
requests and responses they are often
integrated as a module or a plugin
within the web server or the application
framework host based wafs provides
granular control and coin protect
specific applications or modules within
a server both Network waste and host
based wfs have their strength and can
complement each other for enhanced
security network base wfs are suitable
for large scale protection across
multiple applications and servers while
host based wfs offer more precise
control and visibility into application
specific vulnerabilities and attacks
it's important to note that while wfs
are valuable in safeguarding web
applications they should be used in
conjunction with other security measures
like regular application patching secure
coding practices and vulnerability
assessments to ensure comprehensive
protection against evolving cyber
threats now we'll see another question
that is could you please explain the
difference between Bluetooth and red
teaming so blue teaming and red teaming
are two distinct approaches used in
cyber security to enhance the overall
security posture of an organization and
blue teaming primarily focuses on
defense and proactive measures blue
teams are responsible for protecting the
organization's assets system and data
from potential threats and attacks they
typically include cyber Security
Professionals within the organizations
who work to identify vulnerabilities
monitor networks and Implement security
controls blue teams conduct risk
assessments perform security Audits and
develop incident response plans they
also monitor security system analyze
logs and use various tools to detect and
mitigate threats essentially blue teams
act as a Defenders ensuring that the
organization's defenses are strong and
resilient on the other hand red teaming
takes an offensive approach that teams
are independent groups or individuals
who stimulate real-world cyber attacks
to evaluate the effectiveness of the
organization's security controls and
practices their goal is to identify
weaknesses gaps and vulnerabilities in
the system red teams use tactics similar
to those of real attackers such as
social engineering penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments to Encore
potential security Force by adopting the
perspective of an attacker teams provide
valuable insights into the
organization's security vulnerabilities
allowing The Blue Team to improve their
defenses in summary blue teaming is
focused on defense while red teaming is
focused on offense blue teams work to
prevent and mitigate cyber threats while
red teams act as adversaries to identify
weaknesses and improve the
organization's security
the collaboration between blue and red
team is crucial in maintaining a strong
security posture and effectively
protecting sensitive information so this
was all that is the difference between
glutamine and vitamin now moving on to
the 10th question that is what is false
positive and false negative in case of
ideas so in the context of intrusion
detection system that is IDs false
positive and false negative are two
important terms used to describe the
accuracy of the system in identifying
and classifying security events a false
positive occurs when an ID is
incorrectly identifies a Banning
activity or event as malicious on the
other hand a false negative happens when
an IDs fails to detect an actual
malicious activity or event it occurs
when an intrusion or attack goes
unnoticed and is not flagged by the
system this can be quite dangerous as it
allows malicious activities to go
undetected potentially causing harm to
the system or network ideally an IDs
should strive to minimize is both false
positives and false negatives however
there is often a trade-off between the
two increasing the sensitive and ideas
to reduce false negatives may result in
more false positives and vice versa
balancing the detection accuracy is
crucial to ensure that genuine threats
are identified while minimizing the
number of false alarms so to improve the
effectiveness of an IDs continuously
monitoring fine tuning of detection
rules and incorporating machine learning
algorithms can be employed additionally
it's important for security teams to
carefully analyze and validate alerts to
distinguish between false positive and
true threads ensuring efficient incident
response and mitigation now moving to
another question that is what is TLD
so TLD stands for top level domain in
the field of cyber security in the
context of the internet a top level
domain refers to the last segment of a
domain name located after the final load
it is also commonly known as domain
extension example of tlds
include.com.org.net.gov.edu and Country
specific tlds like dot UK dot FR or dot
a U tlds play a significant role in
cyber security as they help identify the
purpose or category of a website cyber
Security Professionals often analyze
tlds to assess potential security risk
or determine the legitimacy of a domain
malicious actors May exploit certain
tlds such as those associated with
phishing malware distribution or fraud
land activities security measures like
blacklisting or filtering can be
implemented based on tlds to protect
users from accessing potentially harmful
websites overall understanding tlds is
essential in the cyber security field as
it aids in identity find and evaluating
potential threats enhancing website
security and safeguarding users online
experiences so this was all about TLD so
the next question is can you explain
what name servers are in the context of
cyber security so in the realm of cyber
security name servers play a crucial
role in functioning of the internet a
name server also known as a DNS server
domain name system is responsible for
translating human readable domain names
such as www.example.com into IP
addresses such as numerical
representations that computers use to
communicate with each other in simple
terms when a user types a domain name
into a web browser the name server is
responsible for resolving that domain
name to the corresponding IP address of
the server hosting the website this
process is essential for establishing
connections and enabling communication
between devices on the internet from a
cyber security perspective name servers
are vital because they act as
authoritative sources for domain names
solution however they can also be
targeted by malicious actors in various
attacks such as DNA spoofing or DNS
hijacking which aims to manipulate the
translation process so to mitigate this
risk organizations employ various
security measures such as implementing
TN ssec domain name system security
extensions will secure ensure the
integrity and authenticity of DNS data
DNS firewalls and intuition detection
systems can also be utilized to detect
and prevent malicious activities
targeting name servers overall name
servers serve as critical infrastructure
component for the internet and
safeguarding their integrity is
essential in maintaining a secure online
environment so the next question is what
is canonical name in the context of
cyber security so chronomical name
refers to a standardized and
authoritative named assigned to a
network resource such as a domain host
or IP address it is used to establish a
consistent and unambiguous naming
mentioned across different systems and
networks the canonical name serves as a
unique identifier for the resource
ensuring that it can be accurately
located and accessed within a network or
across the internet the canonical name
is commonly represented as a fully
qualified domain name fqdn for a website
which includes the domain name and OLED
subdomains for example
www.example.com is the canonical name
for the website example.com by using the
canonical name organizations can
maintain a centralized and reliable
reference point for accessing resources
making it easier to manage and secure
the network infrastructure in cyber
security the concept of canonical name
is particularly relevant when dealing
with activities such as network
monitoring access control and threat
detection it allows security
administrators to establish policies and
rules based on the canonical names of
resources ensuring consistent
enforcement and effective security
measures by leveraging canonical names
organizations can Advance the cyber
security posture by effectively managing
and protecting their network resources
facilitating accurate identification and
control of assets and enabling efficient
incident response and mitigation
strategies so this was all about
canonical name in cyber security Now
moving on to another popular question
that is what details you find when you
search IP or domain for DNS lookup so
when performing a DNS lookup for an IP
domain in the field of cyber security
there are several key details that can
be obtained these details provide
valuable information for assessing the
cyber security posture and potential
risk associated with the IP or domain in
question here are some important details
that can be found that is IP or domain
ownership so the DNS lookup reveals the
registered owner of the IP address or
domain this information helps identify
the entity responsible for the IP or
domain and can be useful in determining
its legitimacy the next next is IPO
domain reputation the DNS lookup May
provide information about the reputation
of the IPO domain this reputation score
indicates whether the IPO domain has
been involved in malicious activities in
the past High reputation scores indicate
a secure or lower risk level while low
scores may suggest a higher risk of
involvement in cyber threats the next we
have is IP or domain geolocation the
geolocation information obtained from
the DNS lookup reveals the physical
location associated with the ipodomy
this can be useful in identifying
potential jurisdictional issues and
determining the origin of suspicious
activities the next we have is IPO
domain history the DNS lookup can incur
historical data related to the IPO
domain this includes information such as
previous ownership changes in IP
addresses or change in domain
registration details examining the
history can help identify any patterns
or suspicious behavior for previous
environment in cyber incidents the next
is DNS records a DNS lookup provides
information about the DNS reports
associated with the IPO domain this
includes details such as the IP
addresses associated with the domain
mail server information subdomains and
other records like txt records used for
various purposes such as SPF standard
policy framework or DM Arc domain-based
message authentication reporting and
conformance configurations the next is
IPO domain blacklisting a DNS lookup can
reveal whether the IPO domain is listed
on any known Blacklist blacklisting
occurs when an IPO domain is identified
as being associated with malicious
activities spamming or other undesirable
Behavior such listening can indicate a
higher risk level so by analyzing these
details obtained from a DNS lookup cyber
Security Professionals can access the
potential security risk associated with
an IP or domain and take appropriate
measures to protect systems and networks
and now moving to next question that is
what is DHCP that is can you explain
what DHCP is and its role in cyber
security so DHCP stands for dynamic host
configuration protocol it is a network
protocol commonly used in computer
networks to automatically assign IP
addresses and network configuration
settings to devices within a network
DHCP plays a crucial role in cyber
security as it helps in managing and
securing network resources effectively
one of the primary functions of thcp is
to introduced or provide IP addresses
dynamically to devices when they join
the network by assigning IP addresses
dynamically DHCP prevents the need for
manual configuration making it easier to
manage a large number of devices in a
network this automated process helps
ensure that devices are correctly
connected and can communicate with other
devices and Network Services in the
context of cyber security DHCP helps in
enhancing Networks security by enabling
features such as IP addresses management
and network access control here's how
that is IP address management DHCP
allows Network administrators to
centrally manage IP addresses by
controlling IP address assignments
administrators can prevent unauthorized
devices from connecting to the network
this help in mitigating the risk of
unauthorized access and potential
security breaches the second is network
access control DHCP can be used to
enforce network access control policies
for example an organization can
configure DHCP to assign different IP
addresses that ranges or provide
specific network settings based on user
roles or device types this allows for
granular control over network access
ensuring that only authorized devices
can connect to specific Network segments
or Services additionally DHCP servers
can be configured to provide additional
information to Connected devices such as
DNS server addresses default gateway
settings and other configuration options
by centrally managing these settings
DHCP reduces the likelihood of
misconfigurations that could introduce
security vulnerabilities moving to next
question that is what is CV which
authority generate CV annual answer cve
stands for common vulnerabilities and
exposures it is a system used in the
field of cyber security to identify and
track known vulnerabilities in software
and Hardware the purpose of CV is to
provide a standardized way of
referencing And discussing security
vulnerabilities across different
organizations vendors and researchers
The Authority responsible for generating
CVS is the mitr corporation that is
Mitre is a non-profit organization that
operates the cve program under contract
with the national cyber security
ffrdc that is federally funded research
and development center they maintain the
official CV list assign unique
identifiers to an vulnerabilities and
facilitate the sharing of vulnerability
information among cyber Security
Professionals and organizations by
signing a CV identifier to a
specifically vulnerability Mitre enables
cyber security researchers vendors and
organizations to refer to
vulnerabilities consistently allowing
for effective communication and
collaboration in addressing and
mitigating the identified security
issues so this was the explanation so we
can also think of providing an example
of a CV identifier so let's take an
example of CV 2021 34567 in this case CV
2021 represents the year the
vulnerability was assigned or discovered
and 34567 is a unique numerical
identifier by referring to this CV
identifier Security Professionals can
easily search for information related to
the specific vulnerability and access
details such as its description severity
affected so software versions and
recommended remediation steps now moving
to another question that is what is a
loopback address so a loopback address
refers to a specific Network address
that allows the device to send and
receive data to itself it is commonly
represented by the IP address that is
127.0.0.1 in ipv4 or colon colon 1 in
IPv6 the loopback address is often used
for testing and troubleshooting purposes
as it enables a device to simulate
network communication without actually
sending data or a physical Network when
a device communicates with the loopback
addresses the data packets and routed
internally within the device's network
stack by passing the physical network
interface this allows the device to test
its own network services or applications
without relying on external latto
connectivity by sending data to the
loopback address a device can verify the
functionality and integrity of its
networking protocol software or security
configurations
from a cyber security perspective the
loopback address can be valuable during
the development and testing of security
measures such as firewalls intrusion
detection system or antivirus software
it allows Security Professionals to
assess the effectiveness of these
measures by emulating attacks or
monitoring the device's response or
stimulate malicious activities all
within the controlled environment of the
loopback interface Additionally the
loopback address is sometimes used by
software developers to create a local
development environment for by running
services on the loopback address
developers can test and debug their
applications without exposing them to
potential external threats or
interfering with other network resources
in summary the loopback addresses
provide some means for a device to
communicate with itself internally
offering a convenient and secure method
for testing troubleshooting and software
development in the field of cyber
security and moving to next question
that is 18th question here we will
explain the concepts of threats and
processes so in the context of cyber
security threats and processes are
important Concepts that relate to the
execution and management of software and
how they can impact the security of a
system so process can be understood as
an instance of a computer program that
is being executed it represents a set of
resources such as memory files and
System state allocated by the operating
system to execute the program each
process runs independently with its own
memory space and resources and can
perform various tasks processes can
communicate with each other through
their inter-process communication
mechanism provided by the operating
system on the other hand a thread is a
unit of execution within a process a
process can have multiple threads and
each thread represents an independent
flow of control within the process
threats within a process share the same
memory space allowing for efficient
communication and data sharing by
utilizing threats a program can execute
multiple tasks concurrently improving
performance and responsiveness from a
cyber security perspective understanding
threats and processes exclusion
malicious actors can expert
vulnerabilities in processes or threats
to compromise security system for
example a vulnerability in a process
might allow an attacker to execute
arbitrary code gain unauthorized access
to sensitive data on manipulate system
resources similarly if a thread is
compromised it could be used to execute
malicious code bypass security
mechanisms or launch attacks on other
threats or processes to enhance cyber
security it is important to secure
processes and threats by implementing
various protective measures this
includes regularly updating software to
patch known vulnerabilities employing
secure coding practices to prevent
common programming errors implementing
access controls and permissions to limit
process Privileges and utilizing robust
monitoring and intuition detection
system to detect and respond to
potential threats in summary processes
and threats are fundamental Concept in
cyber security as they determine how
software is executed and how resources
are allocated understanding their
implications and securing them
effectively is essential in maintaining
a secure Computing environment so moving
to next question that is 19th question
and it is what is cadburos so Kerberos
is a widely used Network Authentication
Protocol that plays a crucial role in
ensuring secure Communication in
computer network it was developed by
mesochets Institute of Technology that
is MIT and has become a fundamental
mental component of many security
infrastructures as its core Kerberos
provides a framework for Mutual
authentication between a client and a
server allowing them to establish trust
and securely communicate over an
untrusted Network it relies on a
centralized authentication server known
as the key distribution center which act
as a trusted third party when a client
requests access to a Network's resource
the Kerberos protocol enables the client
to authenticate itself to the KDC using
its credentials typically a username and
password the KDC then verifies the
client's identity and issues a Time
limited ticket also known as ticket
granting ticket which serves as proof of
authentication once the client processes
a valid TGT it can present it to the
desired server to request a service
ticket for a specific resource the
server in turn contacts the KDC to
verify the tgt's authenticity and grants
the client access to the requested
resource if the validation succeeds one
of the significant advantage of Kerberos
is that it uses symmetric key
cryptography which ensures
confidentiality and integrity of the
communication between the client and the
server the KDC shares a secret key with
each client and this key is used to
encrypt the communication tickets making
it difficult for adversaries to forge
and tamper with them moreover Kerberos
incorporates the concept of single
signal allowing users to authenticate
months and obtain multiple tickets for
different services without needing to
re-enter their credentials this enhances
usability and reduces the burden of
remembering and managing numerous
passwords overall Kerberos is a robust
Authentication Protocol that addresses
many security challenges in network
environments its widespread adoption in
various systems and its proven track
record make it a valuable asset in
safeguarding sensitive information and
preventing unauthorized access now
moving to the next question that is can
you explain the significance of 0 18 and
012 in cables with authentication so in
kerberus authentication the value 0x18
and 0 x 12 represents specific message
types within the Kerberos protocol the
Kerberos protocol is a widely used
Authentication Protocol designed to
provide secure authentication for
Network Services in Kerberos each
message exchanged between the client and
the key distribution center as a special
message for a specific message type
associated with it these message types
are represented by hexadecimal values so
0x18 corresponds to the message type krb
underscore as underscore req which
stands for Kerberos authentication
Service request this message is sent by
the client to request a ticket granting
ticket from the KDC the TGT is then used
to request service tickets for specific
Services 0x12 represents the message
type that is krbt GSR EQ which stands
for Kerberos ticket granting service
request this message is sent by the
client of the KDC to request a service
ticket for a particular service the
client includes strategy obtained from
the krb underscore as underscore req
message and specifies the desired
service these message types are
essential in the kerberus authentication
process as they allow the client and the
KDC to exchange the necessary
information for authentication and
authorization the Kerberos protocol uses
the message types to ensure secure
communication and prevent unauthorized
access to Network Services overall the
values 0x18 and 0x12 in Kerberos
authentication represent specific
message types within the Kerberos
protocol enabling the secure exchange of
authentication and authorization
information between the client and the
KDC and the next question we have is
Define unicasting multicasting and
broadcasting so unicast multicast and
broadcast are the three methods by which
will transmit data over a network so
unicast it sends the information from a
single user to a single receiver we use
this for point-to-point communications
and multicast here data is sent from one
or more sources to multiple destinations
then we have brought first that is known
as one tool that is the communication is
between a single user and several
receivers and the next question is
explain SSL encryption secure sockets
layered SSL is the standard followed in
the security knowledge industry to
develop encrypted connections between
the browser as well as the web server
this standard ensures that data privacy
is maintained and that online
transactions are protected from external
attacks the following steps have to be
followed to established an SSL
connection the browser will connect to
the web server which is secured by SSL
the browser will send a copy of the SSL
certificate the browser verifies if the
SSL certificate is trustworthy if
trustworthy the browser will send a
message to the server requesting to
establish an encrypted connection the
web server acknowledges and starts to
build an SSL encrypted connection the
encrypted SSL communication begins
between the browser and the web server
and now we have the 23rd question that
is what steps will you take to secure a
server so the secure socket layer SSL is
a protocol where data encrypting and
decrypting will protect it from being
intercepted by authorized users the
simple ways to secure the server are as
follows ensure that the password for
root and administrative users is secured
new users can be included in the system
now they will manage the system as per
the policies established remote access
is removed from default administrator
accounts the following steps have to be
followed to configure firewall routes
for remote access now we have the 24th
question that is what is data protection
in transit versus data protection at
rest so when data is protected in
transit the data goes only from the
server to the client the effectiveness
of data protection repeat the
effectiveness of data protection is
critical for ensuring that there is no
loss of data data protection at test it
is when the database is on the hard
drive the data at rest is sometimes less
vulnerable than the data in transit so
this was all about it and the next
question is what is the difference
between VPN and VLAN so VPN the group
workstations are within the same
locations and in the same road cost the
main logically segregated networks and
have no physical connection whereas VLAN
this is related to remote access to the
company Network the connection of two
points within a secured and encrypted
tunnel there is no encryption technique
in bold and it slices The Logical
Network into different sections to
manage and secure different aspects and
this was all for this tutorial or the
interview questions hope you guys found
it informative and helpful and this was
all for this Advanced ethical hacking
course hope you guys found it
informative and helpful let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers
[Music]
foreign
you're never too old to learn anything
new whether it's an art a new language a
new sport or learning new skills to
advance your career hi I'm Phillip I'm
61 years old and last year I upskill was
simply learns post-graduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the I.T sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course a funny
story I want to share with you
I started off as fine to be a DJ where I
became interested in electronic stereo
systems and how they connected and how
they operate and what made them function
and four years ago I began a journey to
understand and learn more about the
cloud on the way I developed a natural
understanding for the security needs and
began to focus my studies to understand
more about the cyber security aspect of
the cloud landscape
I work with many companies before the
security analyst and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course I've been an adjunct
faculty member at particulars in college
and been in many different learning and
training experiences but the experience
as a student is simply learning
something I will always cherish of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors that I
believe in living a fulfilling life at
61. I am still trained students in
martial arts I've been practicing
martial arts for the past 40 years and
my efforts were acknowledged by the
Eastern United States International
Martial Arts Association
where I was inducted into the Hall of
Fame for a lifetime achievement of
dedication service and martial arts I've
been many things in my life
first and foremost I've been a learner
be a learner first
and if you like this session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching stay tuned for more from Simply
learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you